[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le sur le
figarolive oui vous le voyez il pleut il
pleut sur cette manifestation du 1er mai
qui s'élance de la place de la
République ça vient de commencer il y a
une dizaine de minutes et je vous avoue
qu'on a rarement vu autant de autant de
pluie c'est très impressionnant on a
même entendu l'orage gronder il a il y a
quelques il y a quelques instants nous
sommes en tête de ce de ce cortège pour
débuter ce live ce live de couverture de
ce 1er mai enfin 1er mai 1er mai ou
faites du travail ou 13e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites c'est la grande question
évidemment qui se pose aujourd'hui et ce
sera en tout cas ça c'est une certitude
un 1er mai trempé mouillé parce que
c'est une averse très impressionnante
qui s'abat au moment où on se parle sur
sur la capitale on a vu passer tout à
l'heure plusieurs personnalités des
personnalités politiques qui étaient là
Jean-Luc Mélenchon notamment il était là
pour défendre lui
dans la lutte il veut continuer à se
battre contre cette réforme des
retraites on a aussi entendu Sophie
Binet de la CGT elle est dans le même
courant que que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
puis on aura aussi entendu Laurent berlé
c'est l'une des grandes questions de
cette journée lui c'est un légitimiste
comme il dit cette réforme est passé par
le biais d'un 49-3 elle a été validé par
le Conseil constitutionnel et maintenant
et maintenant que faire la lutte
pourrait s'essouffler petit à petit nous
verrons aujourd'hui les chiffres de la
de la manifestation les chiffres de
mobilisation les Français et les
Français contre la réforme des retraites
se mobiliseront-ils dans la rue c'est
l'une des grandes questions également
que nous nous poserons cet après-midi
voilà pour lancer cette cette journée de
manifestation sous la pluie évidemment
on va suivre ça en espérant que ça se
calme un petit peu on a entendu Laura
tout à l'heure Vincent vous êtes en
plateau vous êtes au chaud et vous avez
la main évidemment
au chaud et au sec mon cher Thibault
nous sommes donc effectivement en
plateau avec vous chers internautes tout
au long euh de la journée tout au long
de l'après-midi bien sûr on va revenir
sur ces différents enjeux qui vient
d'être ces questions qui viennent d'être
soulevées par Thibault Gauthier l'enjeu
syndical l'enjeu politique on va en
parler donc avec vous tout au long de
l'après-midi et bien sûr on va en parler
avec les dirigeants politiques et
syndicaux qui battent le pavé on les a
vu tout à l'heure on les a aperçus et
Thibault Gauthier vous pouvez compter
sur lui avec l'aide de François
Carpentier valait les pister pour
pouvoir répondre à leurs questions à vos
questions vous nous les posez je salue
notamment pas de 75 qui nous rejoint sur
le site du Figaro et je vous salue
également vous chers internautes qui
nous rejoignaient actuellement sur le
live du Figaro sur Youtube on va en
parler également avec les journalistes
et experts qui se succéderont tout au
long de l'après-midi sur ce plateau on
parlera politique sociale sondage avec
Joseph touvenel à partir de 15 heures
sous le président et fondatrice de
backbone Consulting qui a réalisé pour
le Figaro un sondage sur la question on
reviendra sur les chiffres mais tout de
suite on va essayer de retrouver dans
l'autre partie du cortège plutôt devant
le en tête de cortège Damien Canivez et
Julien Leclerc
Damien Julien quel est l'ambiance là
quelle est la situation là où vous vous
trouvez
des rideaux de pluie s'abattent sur la
capitale mais ça ne devrait en principe
pas durer trop longtemps je ne somme pas
très loin d'eux de la tête de cortège
mais nous avons pris un petit peu de
temps avant de rejoindre cet endroit
tout simplement parce que il y a eu de
nombreux contrôles de police aux abords
de la place de la République les
policiers redoutent effectivement
l'arrivée de 1000 à 2000 éléments
ultra violent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le dispositif ici est une fois
de plus très impressionnant 5000
policiers et gendarmes sont en train de
quadriller cet itinéraire donc il va
s'étendre de la place de la République à
Paris jusqu'à la place de la Nation les
manifestants ici défilent dans le calme
on a vu quelques slogans aussi
évidemment au gouvernement et plus
particulièrement contre la personne
d'Emmanuel Macron une banderole a même
été à même été noué autour du cou de
l'allégorie de la République qui se
trouve Place de la République vous savez
cette grande statue qui surplombe la
place de la République un drap marqué
Macron démission a noué autour du coup
de cette statue voilà pour l'ambiance
ici Vincent nous allons essayer de
rejoindre la tête de cortège d'ici
quelques instants et on reviendra vers
vous pour vous faire un nouveau un
nouveau point d'ambiance merci beaucoup
Damien et bien sûr on va vous retrouver
très vite on va justement aborder
l'angle et l'enjeu de la sécurité au
cours de ce live avec Mathieu Valley qui
nous a rejoint dès le début de ce live
bonjour Mathieu Valley merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous porte parole du
syndicat indépendant des commissaires de
police avec un peu plus tard également
Grégory Joron d'unité SGP Police
auparavant peut-être on va faire un
détour place de la République on
retrouve Thibault Gauthier le cortège
est parti vous nous disiez Thibault et
sous une pluie torrentielle comme le
signal en tous les cas comme le signal
des autres envoyé spéciaux du Figaro et
effectivement à vous voir elle ne vous a
pas ménagé
[Musique]
les syndicats surtout ne veulent pas que
les personnes étaient politiques et les
mouvements politiques s'approprient
s'approprient la lutte voilà il faut le
dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon et la nupes a
depuis le mois de janvier essayez à
plusieurs reprises de lancer des
manifestations on se souvient d'un
samedi qu'il y avait réuni très peu de
monde place de la République alors que
la terre syndicale unie depuis de très
nombreuses années d'ailleurs c'est la
première fois pour un premier mai depuis
2009 que la terre syndicale est unie et
bien elle a réussi à amener du monde
dans la dans la rue plus d'un million
presque un million et demi de personnes
selon les chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc forcément les syndicats
ils ne veulent pas laisser et bien la
réussite de ce mouvement au parti
politique qui d'ailleurs ne semble pas
vraiment en profiter ça se voit dans les
sondages non ce n'est pas la nipples qui
bénéficie de cette lutte et de cette de
cette colère sociale selon les sondages
voyez ici c'est jeune gens masqués c'est
toujours l'une des inquiétudes c'est fam
eux Black Bloc ce qui pourrait se former
pour l'instant nous n'en sommes pas là
nous avons entendu quelques pétards mais
rien de très grave pour l'instant
merci Thibault pour ces précisions 418
000 personnes dans la rue à 14h c'est le
premier pointage alors que on prévoit 5
à 600 000 personnes dans la rue dans au
cours dans les 300 rassemblements qui
sont annoncés quelques images
effectivement on voit des jeunes marches
masqués bonjour Mathieu Valley est-ce
que question est-ce que vous policiers
est-ce que vous tremblez à l'heure
actuelle
non tremble pas on est vigilant et on a
surtout une appréhension cet après-midi
quand on voit que à Lyon depuis ce matin
10h et que le cortège n'est toujours pas
fini on a des exactions violentes contre
les policiers il y a des magasins des
banques des agences immobilières des
véhicules donc tout ce qui est l'outil
des commerçants assez paradoxal pour une
fête des travailleurs qui en fait et la
fête transformée par certains casseurs
en véritable dégradation et cet
après-midi à Paris on dispose de
nombreux policiers gendarmes à 5000 je
le rappelle ce qui se décompose
quasiment 50 escadron et compagnies
républicaine de sécurité on a 12
compagnies d'intervention transformée en
brigade de répression violente notamment
avec les brigades actionnantes à moto et
donc
aime que désormais tout le monde comme
les bacs c'est vrai qu'il y a des
acronymes qui rentrent dans la tête plus
vite que certains d'autres parce que ils
font du bon travail et en réalité on va
voir ce que donne la physionomie de la
manifestation cet après-midi à Paris et
je rappelle vous voyez que dès le début
du cortège quand on a le visage masqué
dans un manifestation c'est une
contravention et quand il y a des
dégradations qui sont commises avec le
visage masqué ça devient un délit donc
j'ai toujours un peu de mal avec les
gens qui
[Musique]
prédit par les services de
renseignements qui passent à l'action
cet après-midi ça reste d'être très
violent le but c'est que les gens
pacifiques les syndicalistes et les
personnes qui viennent revendiquer des
aspirations politiques ou écologistes ou
sociales puissent se faire correctement
et je pense qu'on reviendra aussi sur le
sujet des drones alors oui bien sûr on
va revenir sur le projet des drones si
vous faites toutes les questions avant
la je pense une grosse mais j'en étais
autre j'en ai d'autres à vous poser
justement je reviens le rang Nunes
encore
c'est déclaré en tous les cas
relativement serein assez serein
lors des précédentes prises de parole
qui ont été les siennes il ne craint pas
dit-il les débordements il ne les craint
pas plus que lors des manifestations
précédentes est-ce que vous partagez sa
sérénité
oui alors les policiers sont serein et
ils agissent avec professionnalisme mais
exemplarité après moi je suis toujours
quand même inquiet de voir des collègues
grièvement blessés si on prend le cas
des précédentes manifestations on a une
commissaire de police devant la rotonde
qui avait été violemment blessé par un
jet de pavé je rappelle que l'auteur est
interpellé par le troisième district de
police judiciaire Loïc se polissait dont
je parle à l'instant qui s'était
effondré boulevard
Strasbourg-Saint-Denis près de la place
de la République sont agresseur a
également été interpellé condamné par la
justice grâce encore au travail de la
troisième le troisième district de
police judiciaire donc vous savez moi la
plus grande crainte c'est qu'on est des
policiers grèves ont blessés à la fin
des manifestations puisqu'on se rend
bien compte qu'on a des gens qui portent
uniforme pour protéger pas pour se faire
agresser et que finalement les personnes
qui défilent les syndicalistes qui sont
en tête de cortège et qui sont là pour
revendiquer le peuvent le faire grâce
aux policiers aux gens sans eux ça
serait impossible et là on voit
actuellement à Lyon la situation est
très difficile avec des scènes de
guerrière urbaine et la cortège faut
modifier n'est pas encore pas encore
terminée on va continuer évidemment ce
qui se passe
à Nantes aussi à Rennes après je veux
dire c'est assez traditionnel c'est
toujours de ces endroits là qu'il y a
des incidents que c'est le plus sensible
c'est le plus chaud j'allais venir en
réalité ces personnes radicalisées ces
personnes qui adaptent de la pratique du
black bloc qui sont-ils ce sont des
éléments de l'ultra gauche ce sont des
éléments radicalisés d'un mouvance de
l'ultra gauche et en France on arrive à
lutter contre l'ultra droite par des
enquêtes par des interpellations par des
surveillances par des filatures par un
système de renseignement qui a prouvé
son efficacité et sur l'ultra gauche on
n'arrive pas à faire la même chose donc
comme on met pas les mêmes moyens pour
l'ultra gauche que pour l'ultra-grotte
comme la volonté politique n'y est pas
pour l'ultra gauche comme pour
l'ultra-droite on constate qu'on a des
foyers des nids à ultra gauche qui
s'aiment le chaos à chaque manifestation
à chaque rassemblement social économique
écologique ou même festif comme par
exemple la fête de la musique et en
réalité Nantes Rennes Lille Lyon
Bordeaux sont devenus des nids
radicalisation du train à gauche qui est
urgent de combattre si on veut plus voir
ces images et ses policiers et ces
gendarmes blessés ces manifestations
volés par qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour justement éviter d'avoir ces
actions là c'est dégradations là c'est
ces phénomènes là et c'est même c'est
c'est pour que ces personnes ne
commettent pas ces méfaits je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut réfléchir sur les
outils juridiques que l'État droit de
nous donne on s'est donné des outils
très très puissants pour lutter contre
les talents pour lutter contre les
proxénètes pour lutter contre les
terroristes et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que notre démocratie est mise en danger
et minée par ces individus radicalisés
qui cassent tout qui brûle tout qui
agresse nos forces de l'ordre qui
empêche les gens d'exprimer leurs droits
qui sont consacrés par notre
Constitution et à ce moment-là quand on
est dans cette tyrannie de cette
minorité radicalisée d'ultra gauche qui
pourrit notre démocratie il est urgent
de se donner des moyens de pouvoir les
interdire de venir de manifestations de
pouvoir les contrôler les surveiller de
manière beaucoup plus près de pouvoir
aussi comme on le fait par exemple pour
toutes les personnes qui ont des liens
avec la mouvance terroriste de pouvoir
par exemple par des mesures
individuelles de contrat administratif
et de de pouvoir les empêcher aussi de
venir semer le chaos dans les cortèges
j'en ai connu ils sont souvent fichés
ils sont souvent associés à des
groupuscules on les connaît mais bien
sûr la plupart l'une des difficultés et
je pense qu'on le verra et peut-être
cet après-midi c'est que on l'a en tous
les cas Christophe Cornavin la décrit
dans un journal dans un article pour Le
Figaro de publier ce samedi c'est
l'extrême volatilité de ces éléments là
l'extrême
plasticité également de leur
rassemblement c'est difficile de de les
ce sont des organisations horizontales
c'est extrêmement difficile de les de
les appréhender bon d'abord par exemple
vous prenez les mouvements comme les
soulèvements de la terre ou comme par
exemple les groupes antifa Lyon ou à
Bordeaux ou à Nantes c'est des
structures qu'on connaît sur lesquelles
d'ailleurs il y a des procédures de
dissolution qui étaient engagées par le
gouvernement ensuite il faut pas
confondre les profils des personnes
qu'on connaît et leur mode d'action qui
est effectivement est très volatile en
mode d'action effectivement il se Grimm
en noir il sera adeptes de la pratique
donc c'est à dire que vous êtes en train
de dire Mathieu c'est que quand ils font
un black bloc au sein d'une
manifestation c'est trop tard c'est
avant qu'il faut tout à fait enfin en
manifestation souvent on arrive à
interpeller des personnes qui commet des
exactions des dégradations des
agressions sur les policiers les
gendarmes et qui sont adeptes du black
bloc et qui sont fichiers on peut les
faire en flagrandir ce qui est très
difficile et ce qui fait souvent arrivé
déjà oui on est arrivé bien sûr dans les
manifestations dans les nombreuses
interpellés alors on se focalise
beaucoup sur les cortège ou la justice
remet dehors beaucoup des interpellés
mais oui on se consacre pas à ceux qui
passent en comparution immédiate et qui
sont par exemple pour une partie
fichesse ou pour une partie adepte du
black bloc et qui ont été interpellés en
flagrant délit de dégradation d'outils
bancaires d'agence immobilière
d'établissements commerciaux comme les
agences ou les Carrefour City etc donc
ce que je vais vous dire c'est que ce
que je disais c'est que le mode d'action
est très compliqué c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs fait des mauvaises images en
public vous savez quand vous allez au
contact de ceux qui sont violents quand
vous allez les interpeller à travers une
foule à travers des personnes qui se
désolidarisent pas face à ces compliqué
de pouvoir le faire en toute sérénité et
en toute facilité ensuite sur leur
profil on les connaît c'est souvent des
personnes issues de milieu assez bourge
c'est pour ça que le misator a évoqué
une expression très juste qui est
blackburge parce que sont souvent des
enfants de grande famille qui ont
normalement été éduqués qui habitent
dans des quartiers très huppés et qui
finalement pour donner un sens à leur
vie et se mettre de l'adrénaline ce qui
dit sur d'ailleurs dans leur audition en
tout cas dans les échanges avec les
policiers qui les interrogent c'est
qu'il commettent ces exactions c'est
dégradations et à chaque fois c'est
pareil quand on avait eu aucun accent
matin des policiers qui avaient été
agressé avec un véhicule de police
brûlée quand on a eu toutes les
exactions depuis les 12 journées
d'action très minoritaires mais quand
même assez conséquente pour nos
policiers gendarmes c'est souvent et
toujours les mêmes profils et en partie
qui sont fichés sauf que la fiche s elle
permet de suivre surveiller et tracer
les déplacements de ces personnes
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande c'est qu'on
est une législation qui soit plus forte
pour pouvoir les empêcher de passer à
l'action et de confisquer et de prendre
un otage une démocratie alors vous venez
de répondre justement à une question que
je voulais vous poser si vous étiez
savoir si vous étiez toujours favorable
à une extension du cas de légal pour
apprendre des Black Blocs et autres
éléments radicaux c'est là je la barre
pâte vous fait une une objection on va
peut-être vous couper un instant à
l'autre parce que je vois que Olivier
Faure et Jean-Paul Huchon sont en grande
discussion à côté de Thibault Gauthier
et
si les interrogeaient bien ont le
diffusera
pâte vous fait une objection l'ultra
droite et dissoute dans la semaine
l'ultra gauche détruit et casse devant
les caméras TV et on ne fait rien
alors d'abord c'est ce que je disais
effectivement l'ultra-droite à une
organisation structurée beaucoup plus
appréhendable que de gauche c'est-à-dire
que l'ultra-droite il y a des structures
il y a des organisations il y a des
personnes identifiées en tant que tel
par exemple génération identitaire par
exemple d'autres groupes qu'on connaît
sur le territoire national ensuite
l'ultra gauche comme elle est très peu
structurelle mais qu'elle est très
individualisée c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure Vincent c'est que en fait
en organisation elle est très volatile
puisqu'elle passe à l'action dans les
cortèges et se dispersent rapidement
d'elle-même lorsqu'elle est pas
interpelée par les forces de l'or en
revanche c'est pour ça que nous on dit
qu'il faut se consacrer sur les profils
individuels quand on voit sainte Soline
ce dispositif gendarmestre avec l'appui
des policiers ou ils étaient chargés de
protéger des méga bassines on voit bien
que les individus qui étaient vus
d'abord ils étaient venus de la France
mais aussi de toute l'Europe de
l'Espagne de l'Italie de l'Allemagne
parfois même de la Grande-Bretagne donc
on voit bien aussi aujourd'hui qu'il y a
un sujet européen que ça soit sur
l'immigration clandestine que ça soit
sur le terrorisme que ça soit sur des
individus radicalisés par l'ultra gauche
on a une européenne puisque d'abord ils
font fi des frontières grâce à l'espace
Schengen et ensuite il y a une
coopération des services de
renseignement qui est assez forte entre
ces pays parce qu'on voit bien que les
projets contestés en Allemagne comme en
France comme par exemple en Espagne ou
en Italie il y a une porosité entre les
frontières et les groupuscules qui
viennent se donner un coup de main pour
semer le la terreur faire du saccage et
mettre le chaos dans les sites où ils
vont que ça soit derrière les sites
ruraux comme à Sainte-Souline en France
que ça soit les sites urbains comme les
grandes villes les grandes
agglomérations qu'on voit sur vos images
à travers les manifestations par exemple
aujourd'hui alors on verra justement
quel est l'ambiance dans un instant avec
Damien Canivez le temps que on le
retrouve
12000 policiers gendarmes sont déployés
vous le disiez sur toute la France
[Musique]
5000 à Paris est-ce que ce dispositif
est suffisant oui il y a beaucoup de
policiers et de gendarmes de toute façon
après c'est une question stratégique on
peut mettre autant de policiers de
Jordan s'il y a pas une stratégie une
doctrine claire on [__] dans la
semoule ce qui est important c'est que
dès qu'on est et ça on l'a éprouvé à
travers les manifestations et les
différentes phases de revendication que
le pays a connu d'ailleurs depuis 2016
dès qu'on a un black bloc qui se
constitue souvent en tête de cortège
c'est ça aussi qui donne nous inquiéter
avant qu'ils étaient en fin de cortège
aujourd'hui ils veulent se mettre devant
les syndicats pour dire que il confie sa
démocratie et ceux qui donnent de l'un
on voit bien que il faut aller au
contact il faut disperser et interpeller
ce bug parce que si on laisse prospérer
si on laisse augmenter si on laisse
dégrader brûler cassé agresser nos
forces de l'ordre au pus il prend de
l'aisance au plus il prend de la
confiance c'est pour ça que nous on dit
que la stratégie qui a d'ailleurs été
changé dans le schéma NASA du matcha
note qui a été adopté il y a un an et
demi en septembre 2021 on voit bien que
la doctrine c'est plus de faire que de
la mise à distance pour sa fonctionne
pas la technique c'est d'aller au
contact d'interpeller et quand la
situation redevienne normale c'est de se
retirer c'est cette fameuse des esclaves
à des escalades c'est pas d'être lâche
et de laisser des gens vous casser la
désescalade c'est intervenir quand c'est
chaud et de repartir quand ça refroidit
vous indignez sur Twitter contre le coût
de l'opération
oui non mais ça me fait rire parce que
la mairie de Paris réclame un million
600 millions 1 million 600.000 euros
elle dit à l'état mais l'état c'est qui
bah c'est vous c'est moi c'est pardon de
le dire tous ces gens qui travaillent à
la sœur de leur font et qui payent des
impôts pour pouvoir rembourser et
éponger en fait la dette qu'occasionne
s'est casseurs donc moi j'aime bien
qu'on disait ça mais c'est qui il est
assez vous et moi vous payez l'impôt sur
le revenu vous payez la TV alors ce que
vous achetez des produits alimentaires
quand on voit aujourd'hui le coup de la
façon aussi parce que parfois ils
achètent des produits ils payent la télé
enfin quand je vois les profils des
interpellés c'est pas souvent des gens
qui travaillent c'est souvent des gens
qui profitent d'une rente ou d'une
situation de famille assez aisée pour
pouvoir faire de la casse et pas avoir
payé derrière c'est des profils que vous
avez majorité mais c'est la majorité des
profils mais c'est ça qui rageant c'est
que quand on avait compris que
l'islamisme radical était une menace
pour une démocratie on y a mis les
moyens en termes de renseignements en
termes d'outil juridique en termes de
volonté politique quand on a compris que
les le trafic de stupéfiant ou le
proxénétisme était aussi une atteinte
grave à la dignité humaine à nos
fonctions de société en amis aussi les
moyens je dis simplement aujourd'hui et
il va falloir attendre qu'on ait encore
des victimes encore de la cas encore des
images choc pour pouvoir réfléchir à un
cadre légal qui correspond à notre
Constitution à nos libertés
fondamentales qui je le rappelle sont
celles de pouvoir manifester pas celle
de casser et aujourd'hui il y a rien qui
a changé sur l'ultra gauche on le voit
au fur et à mesure de voir une
manifestation les Français en sont les
meilleurs juges puisque votre internaute
le dit on a des personnes se saisissent
des autres qui agissent impunément parce
que soit la justice les condames passent
vers moi soit on met pas la volonté
politique pour les interpeller faire des
procédures en amont comme on l'a fait
sur les sujets que je ne vous évoqué je
salue les internautes qui nous
rejoignent au lieu de samozatland
starter à la France du coq qui nous dit
ce soir aux infos 200 000 selon la
préfecture 2 millions selon la CGT alors
pour l'instant ce qui est prévu c'est
plutôt 500 à 600 000 personnes sur
l'ensemble du du territoire c'est en
tout cas les estimations qui sont
données par les services de
renseignement et au que reprenez le
Figaro ce week-end on verra précisément
ce qu'il en est en fin d'après-midi
selon les les premières estimation qui
nous parviendrons et selon les
estimations que l'on fait également ici
au Figaro ce que je peux vous dire en
tout cas c'est que en début d'après-midi
c'était 480 000 manifestants à 14h sur
tout le territoire c'est en tout cas ce
que nous rapporter les agences on va
retrouver bien 12h43 14h40 retrouver
dans quelques instants Damien Canivez
une question encore Mathieu Valle est-ce
que vous partagez la crainte de
retrouver les gilets jaunes c'est une
crainte exprimée par les services de
renseignement notamment non mais il y a
un fond de contestation qui a été mené
par les gilets jaunes depuis novembre
2018 qui s'est jamais éteint il y a une
partie assez motivée déterminée qui
manifeste d'ailleurs toutes les semaines
et qui se jeûne à chaque cantèle
syndical moi c'est pas les gilets jaunes
qui posent problème c'est les Ultra
jaune ces personnes en fait qui
basculent dans la radicalisation et qui
ne sont plus dans les revendications
pacifiques qui sont dans la
revendication violente mais souvent un
filet d'ailleurs à l'ultra gauche que
derrière ultra gauche à récupérer lors
des mouvements des gilets jaunes pour
dévoiler leurs causes et puis se met la
violence et en faire des véritables
diffuseur de haine et de sa cage dans
les rues de Paris ce qui est d'ailleurs
malheureusement a tué le mouvement au
sens des services de renseignement et
qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ne reste plus
grand chose et c'est ce fameux lit de
dernière contestation qu'on peut avoir
dans les cortèges question de Hugues qui
dit Macron aurait mieux fait de faire
passer une loi antiqueur plutôt qu'une
loi anti salarié il y a des lois en tout
cas non alors il y a une anti-casseurs
qui a été proposé par les républicains
en 2016 qui prévoyait d'ailleurs à
l'instar des hooligans dans les stades
de foot de pouvoir interdire par le
préfet ces personnes connues fichées et
qui ont un passif de casseurs des
interdire de venir la manifestation en
les faisant pointer au commissariat ou à
la brigade des gendarmerie avant pendant
et après elle a été retoquée par le
conseil social et vous savez pour les
drones on a attendu deux ans donc
peut-être qu'il faut représenter de
nouvelles lois à force de représenter et
d'exprimer la motivation sérieuse et
indispensable de ce texte pour protéger
nos manifestation on aura peut-être des
sages qui porteront réellement leur nom
à protéger les pacifiques manifestants
plutôt que les casseurs alors on va
revenir justement sur le début du
cortège où on va retrouver
Damien Canivez Damien quel est
l'ambiance où vous trouvez en risque
d'ailleurs de vous couper puisque on a
également Ollier fort en ligne de mire
mais d'abord les dernières informations
avec vous apparemment il y a des jeux de
la de lacrymogène
ouais c'est assez tendu ici et ça arrive
très tôt dans le cortège la dernière
fois que j'ai suivi ces manifestations
pour Figaro live avec vous Vincent roux
la dernière le Black Bloc c'était
constitué très tôt dans la manifestation
mais aujourd'hui plus que jamais le
black bloc en fait a démarré en même
temps que le cortège syndical et c'est
vrai que les esprits sont extrêmement
tendus ici jamais de depuis le mouvement
social qui s'est amorcé en janvier on
avait eu autant d'éléments radicaux dans
une manifestation le préfet de police
Laurent Nunez le préfet de police de
Paris attendait à peu près 2000 élément
radicaux ils s'en sort de plus ici
aujourd'hui peut-être même des éléments
qui viennent de l'étranger on a entendu
parler étranger des personnes en
cagoulées parler une langue slave
peut-être ou en tout cas des pays de
l'Est voilà il y a beaucoup de fumigènes
aussi qui sont activés sous nos yeux ce
qui peut paraître étonnant regarde ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
puisque la place de la République a été
quadrillée par les forces de l'ordre et
tous les manifestants présumés
[Musique]
Damien je vous repose une question
est-ce que il y a un élément qui était
assez inédit dans ce que vous a dit vous
avez entendu parler d'autres langues que
le français
oui tout à fait tout attendant entendu
effectivement des éléments qui se
trouvent autour de nous parler d'autres
langues que le français ce qui pourrait
effectivement accréditer la thèse de
leur Younes qui a indiqué que des
éléments radicaux venus de l'étranger ce
sont greffés au cortège parisien qui
sont évidemment très très éloignés de
mouvement de contestation contre la
réforme des retraites mais en effet on a
entendu des personnes en cagoulés
impossible de vous dire leur âge bien
évidemment parler d'autres langues que
le français merci beaucoup Damien pour
ces précisions d'abord vous prenez
toutes les précautions pas de risque
bien évidemment et on reviendra vers
vous tout au long bien sûr de la
manifestation
c'est est-ce que vous êtes étonné de ce
que vous venez d'entendre Mathieu Valley
sans prétention vous voyez bien que tout
ce que je vous explique depuis qu'on a
commencé le live il se confirme par vous
reporter sur Terre les meilleurs juges
je vous l'ai dit c'est les Français
c'est les commerçants c'est les
contribuables qui sont honnêtes qui
payent leurs impôts et qui veulent vivre
dans un état démocratique ser calme et
dans lequel on peut exprimer des
revendications pacifiques sans être en
otage par des individus violents moi je
dis que ces images elles peuvent changer
si on a une volonté politique si on
donne un cadre légal qui évolutif par
rapport à cette nouvelle menace de
l'ultra gauche dans l'Europe et vous
voyez votre reporter sur le terrain
comme je dis toujours c'est le terrain
moi qui suis policier le terrain qui
parle beaucoup plus simplement
efficacement que les grands discours sur
les plateaux et dans les grands de
pensées dominante c'est que c'est pour
ça que fait du live tout à fait
exactement mais je fais les deux je
travaille à côté je suis pas détaché à
Platon c'est pour ça que je garde les
pièces sur le terrain parce que à mon
sens c'est ce qui te permet de garder
avec le contact avec les réalités mais
moi je vous dis ça ces images là on peut
les réduire on peut mettre hors établir
ces individus si on a une volonté
politique et une volonté juridique de
nous donner les moyens de les
interpeller en amont non pas en faisant
de la prédiction ou de l'interpellation
préventive mais en judiciarisant des
comportements des structures des
mouvances qui ont qu'une idéologie c'est
de mettre à bas notre État de droit
c'est de faire tomber des policiers des
gendarmes et c'est de se mettre chaos et
la terreur dans les rues de Paris ou
dans les rues de nos grandes
agglomérations et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
toute l'Europe est menacée et vous
l'avez dit dans votre portage sur le
terrain on entend des langues étrangères
ça m'étonne pas on a souvent des
Espagnols des Catalans des Italiens voir
des Allemands qui sont aussi des
spécialistes dans leur pays et qui
viennent évidemment avec plaisir
s'immiscer dans nos cortèges pour
pouvoir semer les images que vous voyez
et que vous dénoncez régulièrement enfin
en tout cas qu'une majorité des
Françaises et des Français dénoncent
alors oui nous on les montre justement
et on laisse les uns et les autres jugés
justement question
on voit qu'effectivement il y a beaucoup
de slogans qui sont hostiles
mais est-ce qu'on exagère pas les
intentions de ceux qui les tiennent je
lis dans le Figaro samedi un policier
qui dit certains sont là pour tuer
vraiment ah bah écoutez quand vous jetez
un pavé sur la tête et le visage d'un
policier ou d'un gendarme la tension
elle est claire enfin quand on voit tous
les cadeaux que ce ministre ces
personnes pour venir dans les cortèges
on voit bien que c'est pas pour nous
faire plaisir mais c'est pour se faire
plaisir et donc faire tomber un policier
ou un ou un gendarme quand on jette des
cocktails des engins agricoles des
artisanale quant à Sainte-Souline on a
des éléments explosifs qui sont
retrouvés sur des objets inflammables
qui peuvent provoquer des blessures
graves voire mutilés ou tuer des
policiers ou des gendarmes on doit se
réjouir aujourd'hui qu'on ait eu aucun
mort ni des policiers des gendarmes ni
du côté des manifestants mais c'est là
le drame c'est que ces activistes et ses
individus radicalisés violents prennent
en otage toute notre démocratie et que
quand on a un sujet de société et que ça
fait des années qu'on en parle c'est pas
comme si qu'on avait vu émerger ces
problématiques en début d'année avec le
moment des retraites quand ça fait
depuis les loyers de khomri 2016 donc ça
fait quasiment 7 ans qu'on évoque ces
sujets là il y a un moment il faut que
le politique qui est censé régler le
problème des Français et faciliter le
travail des services de renseignement et
des services de police de gendarmerie
puisse donner un nouveau cadre légal moi
je vais le répéter tout le temps parce
qu'on peut bien dire que c'est pas
possible d'interpeller les fichiers que
c'est pas possible de mettre en état de
nuit en amour ces individus violents
écoutez pour tous les autres sujets on
l'a fait je vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on se priverait d'un débat
ou en tout cas d'un cas de juridique
adapté à notre État de droit qui
permettrait de lutter eff franchement
contre ceux qui veulent mettre à bas
plusieurs vitrines saccagées des gaz
lacrymogènes qui ont été tirées une
ambiance tendue en tête de cortège parce
que nous disait à l'instant d'American
hiver ce qui est notre envoyé spécial
avec Julien Leclerc en tête de cortège
en continu bien entendu sur la situation
est en direct avec vous en étant directe
avec Mathieu vallée du syndicat sCIP
poli SCP syndicat
ça dépendait
effectivement le syndicat indépendant de
les commissaires de police
également de feu de poubelles également
de ce qu'on peut revoir également en AFP
c'est des images qui impressionnent mais
ce qu'il faut pas dézoomer aussi dans
ces cas-là c'est c'est je vais vous
donner les premiers chiffres en tête de
cortège là on a un bloc de 2500
personnes qui s'est constitué sur les
images que vous montrez on a des
services de renseignement qui évidemment
suivent ces mouvements radicalisés de
l'ultra gauche on est à peu près 2500
personnes qui lancent des grenades
artisanales et des mortiers sur les
policiers et les gendarmes qui sont
effectivement en train de s'attaquer à
des établissements bancaires on a vu la
Société générale je crois sur vos images
également et donc non il y a pas de
grossissement ou d'exagération du
phénomène je pense vraiment et les
élections européennes d'ailleurs
arrivent dans un an si je dis pas de
bêtises on aura vraiment ces sujets là à
évoqué on a aujourd'hui une réponse
européenne à avoir sur ces sujets
d'ordre public européen quand on a un
sujet qui dépasse nos frontières ou dont
les frontières facilitent la porosité
entre les pays pour permettre à ces
personnes de basculer de l'Allemagne à
la France de la France à l'Espagne ou de
l'Espagne à l'Italie on voit bien que
aujourd'hui dans notre coin tout seul
c'est pas possible de le faire je vous
le dis encore une fois pour des sujets
comme la criminalité organisée comme
pour le terroriste comme le proxénétisme
on a une coopération forte on a des
résultats tangibles faisons la même
chose avec un cadre légal adapté pour
ces personnes là on va retrouver tout de
suite Damiens Canivez ce qui est à côté
et qui a vu effectivement de de nouveaux
de nouvelles scènes de casse Damien vous
êtes en tête de cortège
oui absolument je suis toujours en tête
de cortège et nous trouvons toujours
boulevard Voltaire en poète très précis
au niveau du numéro 104 et une
entreprise d'imprimerie est en train
d'être vandalisé au moment où je parle
c'est très tendu ici et ce qui est assez
étonnant je dois vous dire mais
peut-être que votre invité en plateau
pourra vous vous expliquez pourquoi on
voit pas les forces de l'ordre arriver
sur ce boulevard Voltaire alors que je
peux vous assurer que l'ambiance est
vous l'entendez au regard des grenades
qui sont en train de des bombes
artisanales qui sont en train d'exploser
autour de nous les policiers sont très
peu présents voire pas du tout présent
ici on les a vu dans des rues parallèles
au boulevard Voltaire puisque des Black
Blocs ont indiqué que les forces de
l'ordre étaient en train d'arriver
simplement c'est force de l'ordre ce
sont réfugiés plus dans une rue
parallèle alors sans doute sont-ils en
train de préparer une riposte ici sur ce
boulevard Voltaire mais on a du mal à
voir comment dans la mesure où ce black
bloc est très compact et ultra motivé à
l'idée de saccager des vitrines alors il
faut dire que sur cet itinéraire qui
relie la place de la République à la
place de la Nation il y a beaucoup de
symboles qui irritent c'est 12h
ultra gauche à savoir des banques des
assurances on en a parlé tout à l'heure
d'un courtier en crédit là c'est une
entreprise une chaîne d'imprimerie qui
est en train d'être saccagé enfin là
c'est vrai que l'ambiance est
extrêmement tendue mais pas de force de
l'ordre pour le moment à l'horizon
merci Damien
l'horizon c'est une tactique c'est une
stratégie nous expliquer comment non là
on a des policiers des gens qui
interviennent en tête de cortège alors
peut-être que depuis l'endroit où est
votre journaliste il voit peut-être pas
la tête de cortège tout au début mais
moi j'ai des policiers sur le terrain
qui me disent qu'ils sont en train
d'intervenir en tête de cortège et on a
actuellement aussi bah des manœuvres en
cours de préparation je veux pas trahir
le dispositif puisque on peut avoir des
éléments radicalisés qui nous écoutent
puisqu'ils adoptent aussi ben des
techniques des services de renseignement
à savoir en milieu ouvert comme vos
médias voir un peu ce qui se passe et
les manœuvres ils voyaient sur vos
images on a des policiers qui
interviennent donc tout ça ces dernières
qui se prépare on n'envoie pas nos
collègues au casse-pipe au milieu d'une
foule mais en tout cas d'individu
violent hasardeuse avec des blessés à la
clé des mauvaises images où on pourrait
dire violence policière telle que
l'ultra gauche a inventé ce mot pour
nous démolir et discréditer l'action de
police donc on voit sur une partie de
vos images l'intervention des policiers
et des gendarmes et on a d'autres
manœuvres qui se préparent il faut que
ça soit coordonné on a des compagnies
d'intervention on a des CRS on a des
escades gendarmes mobiles on a beaucoup
de rue perpend iculaires à l'axe du
boulevard Voltaire donc il faut pouvoir
cadrer encadrer intervenir en sécurité
et si possible faire des interpellations
toute sécurité et pour nos collègues et
pour nos camarades de la gendarmerie et
pour les personnes qui sont dans les
cortèges et sur place parce que si le
but c'est d'interpeller les gens le plus
on va dire professionnel possible
Vous contestez le terme de violences
policières non mais c'est un terme qui
en fait pour moi ne veut rien dire le
mot violence policière est utilisé pour
démolir et discréditer l'insertion de
police il peut y en avoir non il peut y
avoir et puis il y a parfois des bavures
aussi
une erreur moi j'appelle passer le
bavure médicale après une erreur
médicale donc c'est une erreur qui
forment pas correctement les élèves
jamais passer le bavure scolaire
j'appelle ça un professeur qui fait pas
correctement son travail c'est marrant
en fait que à chaque fois pas marrant je
rigole parce que forcément au bout d'un
moment à force d'être désespéré par des
mots qui veulent rien dire on essaye de
détremasser les choses mais si vous
voulez je vais être très court le mot
violence policière veut dire que tous
les policiers sont violents sert la
soupe à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent discréditer l'action de police
et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il y a un
sujet qui doit nous inquiéter on est
dans un aspect systémique de discrédité
notre réaction légitime et notre
incarnation légitime de la violence
unique on a aujourd'hui une partie ultra
gauche et d'extrême gauche qui sont dans
une visée systémique de discréditer des
forces de l'ordre par des propos tels
qu'on l'a connu comme qualifier par
certains partis politiques de policiers
de barbares de factieux de bons rien des
borner c'est encore été dit cet
après-midi par Monsieur Mélenchon et on
a en réalité aujourd'hui ils vont monter
de mettre à mal notre démocratie en
s'attaquant à ses premières remparts que
sont les policiers journalistes ne sont
pas là pour frapper se faire plaisir ils
sont là pour ruser de la force légitime
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas d'autres moyens de
faire respecter la loi et protéger
autrui il y a un débat sur les drones
Darmanin en encourage l'usage la justice
a parfois interdit aux limiter l'usage
elle l'a autorisé ici à Paris est-ce
qu'ils sont vraiment utiles ah mais ils
sont indispensables pourquoi mais parce
que en fait tout le monde les utilise
des drones quand vous êtes un
particulier que vous déclarez une
demande d'utilisation préfecture c'est
accepter souvent et c'est possible les
dealers dans les cités utilisés drone
pour détecter la précision bah ça nous
permet d'avoir un panorama beaucoup plus
large des sites qu'on surveille ça nous
permet de suivre des groupes à risque
sans engager des efforts sur le terrain
ça d'avoir une mobilité beaucoup plus
forte donc on voit bien que ces drones
ils sont indispensables mais vous n'êtes
pas précisé donc je vais le faire en
Seine-Maritime le juge administratif a
censuré une partie de l'arrêter de
l'utilisation des drones et
qui c'est cette contestation c'est
syndicats de la magistrature en partie
donc je suis encore ravi de voir que le
mistrature pour ceux qui savent pas qui
c'est ce sont ceux qui ont fait oui
qui est un peu radicalisé quand on voit
que c'est souvent qui ont fait le mur
des cons c'est pas trop la conception du
projet démocratie lorsqu'on est un
syndicat qui est censé rendre la justice
au nom du peuple français donc c'est un
syndicat qui a fait beaucoup de mal à
notre justice et quand on a 44% des
Français et des Français qui croient la
justice je pense que ça décale la
magistrature porte une partie de la
responsabilité de se discrédit des
Français vis-à-vis de leur justice parce
que quand on est plus prompte à défendre
des délinquants que les victimes quand
on est plus sprint à dénoncer l'action
des policiers gendarmes plutôt que les
exactions des personnes radicalisées là
il y a un sujet dans notre démocratie
moi je compte sur les magistrats pour
protéger nos libertés je compte pas sur
des syndicats minoritaires de magistrats
pour contester des actions de police qui
servent à protéger les victimes
donc pour retenir pour revenir à ce
qu'on disait sur le plan opérationnel
les drones vous connaissez aucun police
qui a fait un mur des cons moi j'avais
fait ça dégage
des drones en Seine-Maritime par exemple
on l'a entendu on l'a compris on le
conteste pas moi la question qui veut
reposer reposer c'est sûr le
l'efficacité et l'utilité des drones ça
vous permet d'avoir une meilleure
exemple très concret quand on a des
groupes à risque qu'on a identifié par
exemple en amont de la manifestation
mais pas de bloc par exemple peut être
repéré par la formation la Black Bloc
c'est un outil d'action donc on va dire
que les individus radicalisés avant
qu'ils passent en Black Bloc ils sont
parfois quatre ou cinq on a
malheureusement pas d'éléments pour les
interpeller très précis parce que vous
savez que les procédures elles doivent
être carré et fissées et c'est bien
normal dans un état droit ce que je veux
dire c'est que quand on veut suivre des
éléments radicaux quand on fait de
manière aérienne et de manière beaucoup
plus mobile ça facilite le travail des
forces sur le terrain parce que quand on
travaille par exemple un groupe à risque
il faut trois quatre ou cinq policiers
là où avec un drone il va falloir un
outil technologique qui sera beaucoup
plus rapide mobile et adapté à
l'évolution sur le terrain de ces
individus donc c'est un outil
indispensable et je pourrais on pourra
vous donner les les premières efficacité
quand on aura fait l'utilisation
beaucoup plus souvent puisque je vous
rappelle que c'est tout à fait ça a été
utilisé au Stade de France ça a été
utilisé sur la manifestation du 1er mai
ça a été utilisé dans d'autres contextes
depuis 15 jours la loi enfin
l'adaptation est récente et décrire
l'application sont récents donc il faut
encore un peu de temps pour en démontrer
concrètement l'efficacité mais en tout
cas c'était à nouveau une dernière
question je voulais vous poser avant de
retourner sur le sur le terrain
c'est
ces images là qu'on était en train de
voir j'étais à la place de ceux qui
filment en 2017
il y a eu la même chose en 2018 il y a
eu la même chose en 2019 il y a eu la
même chose l'an dernier il y a eu il y a
la même chose cette année
enfin comment ça se fait quand même à
revoir les les dispositifs avoir les
choses empêcher que les choses se
passent ici ah non la police est la
gendarmerie c'est les administrations
qui se réforme qui se réorganise et qui
s'adapte plus dans la fonction publique
d'ailleurs j'aimerais que la justice
fasse pareil le code de pénale par
exemple il a pas changé depuis des
années vous voyez par exemple c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi on a un taux aussi
faible de confiance de nos constructeurs
vis-à-vis de la justice dans la police
et la gendarmerie on a adopté le schéma
national de maintiendlord donc c'est à
dire que par exemple on a fait évoluer
la tactique et la doctrine des forces
avant on était dans une mise à distance
systématique mais quand cette mise à
distance elle ne fonctionne pas puisque
vous voyez bien que malgré les gaz à
crimogènes malgré par exemple les engins
lanceurs de qui étaient principalement
utilisés pour mettre à distance
individus violents on voit qu'il
continue à casser agresser ouais on va
on va prendre Olivier fort et je
reprends après
nombre en fait un président de la
République qui pense que tout va
s'arrêter ça peut durer des mois encore
des mois descendre dans la rue comme ça
purée des mois effectivement ça peut
durer des mois pas forcément sous les
mêmes formes je ne dis pas qu'il y aura
des manifestations qui se prolongeront à
Nam parce que c'est elle coûte cher à
celles et ceux qui manifestent mais ce
que je crois c'est quand un syndical
prendra utilisera les moyens qu'elle
voudra nous la suivons et que
parallèlement dans le monde politique
nous allons continuer aussi avec les
pouvoirs qui nous sont conférés et donc
je voulais dire par le rip par les
niches parlementaires par l'élection
d'actualité par les amendements on fera
tout ce qui permet de revenir sur ce
débat et de ne jamais le laisser tomber
pour permettre d'avoir en fait l'échange
que nous n'avons pas pu avoir à cause du
49-3 Emmanuel Macron semble être au
milieu d'une crise politique est-ce que
vous aussi vous êtes au milieu de cette
crise politique est-ce que vous avez une
part de responsabilité dans ce qui se
passe en ce moment mais il y a
aujourd'hui une crise démocratique une
crise qui est liée au fait qu'on a un
président qui ne veut pas entendre
la force de l'évidence c'est pas on
n'est pas dans un débat qui se jouerait
à 51 49 et où le président pourrait dire
j'assume en responsabilité une réforme
que je connaissais nécessaire il est là
face à l'immensité d'un peuple qui est
en colère qui le manifeste par tous les
moyens par la rue par les sondages pas
ses représentants à l'Assemblée donc à
l'Assemblée proche du 51 49 on a vu que
c'était très serré avant le vote sur le
49-3 c'est pour ça qu'Emmanuel Macron
jusqu'au dernier moment voulait faire
vos tests mais je comprends très bien
que ils veulent passer en force à chaque
fois mais quand on a gagné l'élection
présidentielle qu'on a une majorité
relative et qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
passer son texte c'est que vraiment on
n'a pas réussi à convaincre sur un
projet comme celui-là et donc il est
impératif pour lui soit de revenir par
les urnes et donc ça il est possible de
le faire en fait il peut décider d'un
référendum si lui pense que les Français
sont disposés à le suivre cet agréable
mais qu'il en prenne le risque et qu'il
convoque un référendum pour le mois de
juin et on verra bien ce qui se passe
mais on voit bien que il est sec très
bien lui-même qui est minoritaire c'est
la raison pour laquelle il a dû dire
49-3 et c'est la raison pour laquelle il
ne veut pas de référendum et donc nous
ce que nous lisons c'est que prenez
votre courage monsieur le Président ne
jouez pas les enfants gâtés de la
République faites en sorte au contraire
de d'être un président qui peut se
nourrir de rendre la parole à son peuple
et de lui dire ben voilà j'ai compris
que on ne peut pas passer au dessus de
la démocratie c'est comme ça que les
choses auraient fonctionner on ne peut
pas écouter ce que dire aux emballons
aujourd'hui écoutez enfin la démocratie
ça n'est pas de donner un ticket et une
carte blanche enfin un chèque en blanc
un pouvoir quel qu'il soit pendant 5 ans
la démocratie elle est continue ou
plutôt elle devrait être continue elle
s'exprime par tout moyen et s'exprime
par la démocratie sociale par la rue
aussi par les votes intermédiaires et
donc tout ça il faut tenir compte si on
en tient pas compte forcément on crée
une question de crise et de défiance
démocratique qui peut nous conduire au
pire et le pire c'est l'excédent au
pouvoir merci beaucoup Olivet merci
Thibault merci Olivier fort d'avoir
répondu aux questions sans concession de
Thibault Gauthier on va conclure Mathieu
vallée sur cette première partie en tous
les cas de Live
qu'est-ce que
on voit encore des images assez tendues
là en tête de cortège avec des jeux de
gaz lacrymogènes on va revenir dans un
instant retrouver Damien Canivez est-ce
que c'est scène voulait redouter tout au
long de la manifestation première
question et est-ce qu'elles sont
spécifiques apparues ou bien on a vu des
scènes comparables en province vous ne
lisiez tout à l'heure à Lyon mais
également dans notre vie la
manifestation a commencé vers 10h30 ce
matin elle est toujours pas terminé il y
avait encore des dégradations des
exaçons comics contre les banques contre
les établissements commerciaux contre
les agences immobilières contre les
outils des commerçants finalement
curieux paradoxe je disais de saccager
le l'outil des travailleurs le jour du
1er août c'est leur fête plutôt que de
les soutenir et démontrer l'engagement
des Françaises des Français à pouvoir
travailler et vivre à la sueur de leur
front ensuite donc on a à Lyon et à
Paris quand un match en Lord démarre dès
le début de la manifestation souvent
c'est pas très bon au plus le matcha
note commence tôt au plus il se
terminera d'ailleurs souvent tard donc
en réalité là j'ai des retours de
terrain à Paris des images que on voit
ou qu'on pourra avoir ensuite sur votre
live en fait on a des bons artisanales
des mortiers des engins agricoles qui
sont lancés en masse sur les policiers
gendarmes ça c'est un peu calmé mais le
cure d'entrée de jeu obligé les forces
de l'ordre policiers gendarme à aller en
tête de cortège pour disperser le Black
Bloc constitué environ 2500 personnes de
disperser et pour l'instant on joue pas
il y a pas encore d'interpellation mais
j'ai malheureusement le pressentiment
que ça va être très tendu cet après-midi
au fur et à mesure de l'évolution du
cortège jusqu'à nation qui passera
d'ailleurs pour la place de la Bastille
les places c'est toujours très compliqué
parce que ça c'est vaste assez grand
assez difficile à c'est là où il y a
vraiment une tension notamment avec des
forces de l'Orne sur Bastille ça sera
déjà un premier test si j'ose dire après
il y aura nation la nation il y aura la
dispersion qui prendra du temps là sans
être trop
dans la prédiction à mon avis on aura
une manifestation qui se terminera pas
avant 20h tel qu'on a pu voir d'ailleurs
dans les dernières manifestations
lorsqu'elles s'éternue à Place d'Italie
encore en place de la Nation combien de
personnes ça me donne l'impression
d'être
merci de policier de gendarme ont été
laissés au cours des trois autres
au cours des autres ah depuis le début
de l'année 2023 on est à plus de 2000
policiers gendarmes qui ont été blessés
en moins de 5 mois dans dans les pas
seulement au cours de ces manifestations
si si moi je vous entends alors ce
chiffre que je vous donne là 2000
policiers
depuis le début de l'année 203 donc on
est à peine le 1er mai donc en moins de
5 mois c'est uniquement au cours de ces
journées nationales d'action de
manifestation non pas du fait des
personnes pacifiques qui viennent
revendiquer ou des syndicats mais de ces
éléments radicalisés qui viennent semer
le chaos donc c'est un chiffre assez
important et on n'a pas de la bobologie
on a des blessures assez graves avec des
traumatismes crâniens avec des blessures
notamment de mutilation au niveau des
jambes par des tirs de mortier ou de
bombes artisanales ou de bombes
agricoles notamment si Hassan swing on
avait un gendarme qui est en urgence
absolue donc le chiffre est assez
conséquent effectivement merci beaucoup
Mathieu Valley d'être venu dans les
studios du Figaro pour commenter ce
début de manifestation donc on voit
effectivement comme souvent dans ce
genre de manifestation
un cortège à l'arrière paisible ou on va
retrouver dès que les images de fiches
plus Thibault Gauthier et François
Carpentier et puis en tête de cortège
des images extrêmement d'ambiance
extrêmement tendue de confrontation
d'affrontements et plusieurs vitrines
qui ont été saccagées c'est ce que nous
disait tout à l'heure
Damien Canivez on va le retrouver Daniel
là où vous trouvez quel est quel est
l'ambiance à l'heure actuelle
[Musique]
que la police était invisible sur ce
boulevard Voltaire alors que de
nombreuses fonctions avaient été
commises les agences bancaires qui
avaient été saccagé on avait également
un courtier en prêt qui a été qui a été
qui a été vandalisé et bien tel que
quelques secondes après voilà j'enlève
mon masque je crois que vous m'entendiez
pas très bien parce que il y a j'allais
le poursuivre dans mon propos les
policiers sont ensuite arrivés rue du
Chemin Vert et ont et ont lancé de
nombreuses de nombreuses grenades
lacrymogènes sur ce boulevard Voltaire
ce qui a été très très efficace puisque
le Black Bloc constitué d'à peu près
2500 personnes c'est scinder en deux et
les policiers sont parvenus à aller sont
parvenu à aller à les disperser alors là
l'ambiance c'est un petit peu détendu
depuis tout à l'heure d'ailleurs vous
voyez que les policiers sont repartis
dans les rues adjacentes elles ne sont
plus vraiment présentes sur ce boulevard
Voltaire mais ça a été très tendu
pendant un instant des des jeux de
pierres évidemment on a pu le voir il y
a eu des mortiers d'artifice que les
manifestants ont pu lancer contre les
forces de l'ordre avec effectivement des
policiers qui ont aussi vacillé quelques
instants et on a senti que c'est
extrêmement tendu il y a des
manifestants qui ne présentaient pas
vraiment de danger qui ont essuyé quant
à eux des des coups de boucliers et l'un
d'entre eux même à terminer son vol
plané si j'ose dire dans un abribus 400
même l'abribus qui peut imaginer à
occasionner quelques blessures de son
côté donc voyez c'est c'est assez tendu
les policiers commencent à revenir sur
ce boulevard Voltaire en fait j'ai
l'impression que la stratégie est de
suivre vraiment ce black bloc de façon à
ce que et bien il ne se reforme pas en
tout cas c'est le risque parce que comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure ils
sont parvenus à le scinder en deux à
l'aide de grenades de désencerclement et
de grenades lacrymogènes et depuis
quelques minutes on a le sentiment que
on va le sentiment que voilà les le
Black Bloc est en train de se reformer
tout doucement
merci beaucoup Damien et bien sûr pas de
risque pas de risque inutile et pas de
risque du tout d'ailleurs on reviendra
vous voir bien sûr dans les dans les
minutes qui suivent on retrouvera
également Thibault Gauthier qui lui se
trouve à la tête du cortège parce que je
voudrais avoir également le commentaire
de Joseph touvenel qui vient de nous
rejoindre bonjour Joseph bonjour je
rappelle que vous dirigez la très
passionnante revue capital social et
vous avez été également vice-président
de la CFTC et notamment le responsable
de la puissance Fédération de Paris de
ce très vieux syndicat est-ce que
nonobstant ces images de tension vous ne
regrettez pas de ne plus être assez
fonctions à ce 1er mai qui est le
premier 1er mai unitaire pour une raison
sociale dit-on depuis
1936 non je n'ai pas de regret parce que
je pense qu'il faut laisser la place à
d'autres c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire
je suis toujours très attaché à la CFTC
la Confédération française des
travailleurs chrétiens parce que parce
que c'est les valeurs que je porte mais
on peut les porter aussi autrement et
tout aussi efficacement j'espère
on voit d'ailleurs que le problème
social qui a voulu être
ignoré par beaucoup pendant des années
qui pensaient que la priorité c'était
l'économique on ne fait pas de bonne
économie sans bons sociales comme on ne
fait pas de bon social sans bonne
économie et on retrouve ces fondamentaux
aujourd'hui avec en plus
des idéologues qui sont là depuis des
années mais qui ne font que croître
embellir et qui nous pousse à ce que
l'on voit ce qui correspond pas
d'ailleurs à la très très grande
majorité des syndicalistes ou des non
syndicalistes d'ailleurs les gens qui
sont dans la rue aujourd'hui mais moi
j'étais frappé ce matin j'ai entendu
Monsieur Mélenchon déclarer
l'insurrection demander l'insurrection
contre l'arbitraire et ce qu'il a
conscience de la responsabilité qui
porte
quand on voit ses exactions parce que ce
sont des exactions quand un homme
politique de premier plan qui a une
expérience qui n'a pas d'hier je
rappelle que il a été notamment sénateur
socialiste même si aujourd'hui la
tendance à l'oublier et à nous jouer
l'extrême gauche
insurrection non on peut se dire on peut
dire je ne l'aime pas cette loi je pense
que ce texte est mauvais il y a des
moyens de le dire il y a des moyens de
le faire savoir il y a des moyens
démocratiques de le faire la
manifestation paisible dans la rue on
est en étain on n'appelle pas
l'insurrection on n'appelle pas la
direction chez les forces de police
parce que c'est aussi ce qu'il a fait je
tiens à saluer les forces de police qui
font un travail admirable dans les
conditions très difficiles vous voyez
quand on a une foule comme celle-là
intervenir dans cette foule c'est
risquer de s'en prendre aussi à des
innocents qui sont là et donc c'est très
très difficile pour les forces de police
intervenir moi je les salue ça a été dit
à l'instant oui il y a de très nombreux
blessés et des blessés graves parmi les
forces de police parce que en face il y
a une minorité hyper violente mais cette
minorité
chez un certain nombre de politique dans
un incerter un nombre de penseurs de
philosophes et dans un certain nombre de
médias on ne la condamne pas et au
contraire on va justice fier leurs actes
violences et la haine qu'il propage ça
c'est très très grave c'est encore plus
grave que ce qu'on vit avec les
retraites je l'entends Joseph touvenet
j'entends ce que ce que vous dites d'un
autre côté
toutes ces violences et enfin ces
exactions c'est ses affrontements que
l'on voit régulièrement que l'on a vu
depuis en particulier depuis l'adoption
du 49-3 les sondages sont formels la
majorité des Français
en attribue la responsabilité au
gouvernement mais alors que le
gouvernement et sa responsabilité le
49-3 a été itinéraires d'abord la loi
sur les retraites c'est une loi
d'exception avec un S pour arriver
devant l'Assemblée nationale procédure
d'exception pour arriver devant le Sénat
procédure d'exception 49-3 c'est aussi
une procédure d'exception c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas laissé le jeu démocratique
se faire avec le débat l'utile débat la
porte avait été fermée au partenaire
sociaux rappelez-vous ça fait à peu près
un mois le président de la République
avait refusé de recevoir leur demande
les leaders syndicaux la première
ministre avait fait la même chose ça ce
sont des erreurs qui effectivement
provoque la colère là-dessus il y a les
profiteurs de la colère les profiteurs
de la colère c'est cette extrême
minorité c'est extrêmement violente mais
à qui un certain nombre de gens trouvent
toujours des excuses il n'y a aucune
excuse dans un pays comme le nôtre
aujourd'hui à faire preuve de violence
contre les forces de police et même si
on peut dire des déclarations
maladroites
voir des mensonges du gouvernement
peuvent attisser la colère à chacun de
prendre ses responsabilités et de ne
jamais aller dans cette violence
gratuite alors wolfazu très content de
vous entendre et d'entendre vos
analyses salut et vous il vous félicite
pour vous analyses monsieur touvenel
dit-il ou 17 internautes
il y a une question qui se pose
également là on a effectivement c'est le
retour des images qui sont envoyées
c'est des flux qu'on a ce sont donc en
tête de cortège d'un autre côté quand on
regarde les chiffres et quand on regarde
l'ensemble du cortège les images que
l'on avait tout à l'heure place de la
République qui était le point de départ
on voyait quand même qu'il y avait du
monde 480
000 personnes sur tout le territoire à
14h c'est c'est quand même c'est quand
même un chiffre conséquent est-ce qu'on
assiste à une démonstration de force ou
bien est-ce qu'on assiste à un champ du
signe selon vous alors d'abord le 1er
mai c'est une manifestation habituelle
là c'est un premier mec exceptionnel ou
visiblement il y a plus de monde que les
premiers mai habituels
c'est à la fois une démonstration de
force maintenant moi je n'ai pas les
chiffres on aura ce soir les chiffres de
la CGT et de la préfecture on sait que
les deux seront faux voilà ça sera on
sait que les chiffres de la préfecture
sont fous les chiffres de la préfecture
alors j'ai déjà fait ce travail d'estimé
les chiffres d'une manifestation et
j'étais plus proche de ceux de la
préfecture de police quand c'était les
stations syndicales que ceux de la CGT
cela dit rappelez-vous pour ceux qui se
rappellent de la masse considérable qui
a déferlé dans les rues de France au
moment de la manif pour tous là les
chiffres de la préfecture et du
carrément mensonger voire même ridicule
donc prenons voilà prenons les choses à
la fois paisiblement et avec recul
il y a du monde alors est-ce que ça veut
dire que c'est un dernier rassemblement
de force de l'intersyndicale ou le un
chant du signe je pense que les choses
vont changer ça va pu être les
manifestations toutes les semaines ou tu
dis 10 jours tous les 15 jours
ça ne veut le rythme c'était quand même
bien sûr les gens sortent pas d'abord
du mouvement ou pas de la méthode mais
il y a d'autres méthodes qui se mettent
en place et en partie cela m'inquiète si
ce sont des méthodes si ça devienne des
méthodes violentes des méthodes
d'interdiction de parole aux uns et aux
autres l'interdiction de déplacement aux
uns aux autres on risque d'arriver dans
des casseroles alors les casseroles les
casseroles ça me gêne pas mais regardez
bien vous avez les casseroles d'un côté
c'est la fin du dialogue on n'écoute
plus et on nous dit c'est parce que le
gouvernement nous a pas écouté soit mais
soyons plus intelligents que ceux qui
ferment les écouter c'est ça la vie
démocratique et puis j'ai vu ce qui
s'est passé lors de la finale de la
Coupe de France un président de la
République qui s'enferme dans un couloir
pour saluer des joueurs
et la télévision qui nous retransmet des
images sauf sur les écrans géants c'est
à dire que dans le stade il n'avait pas
les images du président de la République
on arrive dans une forme de censure
c'est-à-dire comment se fait-il que les
gens dans le stade n'ont pas eu la
réalité de ce qui se passait et ça c'est
très inquiétant pour la suite j'espère
que les organisations syndicales vont
rester telles qu'elles sont respectueux
aussi de la liberté de chacun de la
liberté d'expression et de les libertés
de communiquer et là on a vu pour moi
c'est très grave ce qui s'est passé je
ne sais pas qui a pris les décisions de
couper ces images et d'en passer
d'autres pour interdire au stade de voir
ce qui se passait mais regardez bien la
démarche laquelle nous sommes oui mais
d'accord mais alors dans ces cas-là si
on a peur de se faire siffler on y va
pas c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
comment vous interprétez la position de
votre de votre ancien syndicat qui était
connu pour sa modération sont réformisme
et qui a tenu avec un autre syndicat
connu pour sa modération réformisme qui
est la CFE-CGC une position très dure
tout au long de cette séquence la
position elle n'a pas été très dure ça a
été toujours le même position la
position c'est de dire voilà c'est un
mauvais texte alors on pourrait
développer pourquoi c'est un mauvais
testeur la première raison c'est que ça
ne résout en rien le problème des
retraites pour l'avenir puisque le
problème des retrait pour l'avenir quand
on est avec notre système ça s'appelle
la natalité personne ne nous parle de
politique familiale proactive et d'un
retour de la natalité on a encore une
génération pour le faire mais
visiblement ça intéresse personne on
s'intéresse plus à des points de détails
encore une génération qui nous
permettrait de remonter en termes de
natalité et de pouvoir sauver le système
oui bien sûr parce que le système il est
pas en faillite le système d'abord il y
a pas un système il y a des systèmes de
retraite en gros il y en a il y en a
deux pour les salariés et de gros il y a
celui des salariés du privé c'est 78%
des salariés il est à l'équilibre avec
plus de 72 milliards de réserves donc il
y a pas le feu au lac le problème c'est
le système public et par un public qui
lui est structurellement déficitaire
c'est la mauvaise gestion de l'État
c'est en partie la lâcheté des
politiques pas simplement ceux qui sont
au pouvoir aujourd'hui mais des pouvoirs
successifs avec aussi des raisons
qu'on peut mettre sur la table par
exemple il est normal que les pompiers
ou les militaires puissent partir en
retraite avant les autres et peut-être
un peu moins normal qu'on touche en rien
à d'autres systèmes je pense par exemple
au sénateur les sénateurs votent la
suppression des régimes spéciaux mais
garde un peu il garde le leur c'est pas
des Magos c'est stupide enfin c'est
stupide c'est moi ça me révolte je
comprends qu'on se réveille voilà les
sénateurs qui ont un régime très très
privilégié
qui disent on supprime pour les autres
mais on touche pas aux autres comment
voulez-vous qu'ensuite dans la rue et
pas une révolte et ça c'est grave de de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu comme on
fait les sénateurs on va retrouver
Thibault Gauthier qui est sur le cortège
mais effectivement sur la partie
pacifique du cortège en tout cas c'est
ce qui va nous confirmer ou pas quel est
l'ambiance là où vous trouvez Thibault
[Musique]
oui on est à peu près en retrait alors
ça bloque un peu je vais vous montrer on
se rapproche avec avec François
Carpentier avec cette immense camion de
la CFDT qui est complètement bloqué
depuis plusieurs minutes et il est
bloqué tout simplement au carrefour où
se sont retrouvés les les partis
politiques nous avons entendu tout à
l'heure avec Olivier fort du Parti
socialiste il y a quelques instants vous
voyez ici c'est ces affiches partout non
à la retraite à 64 ans avec dessous ce
logo la France insoumise voilà on a vu
plusieurs députés on a vu Eric Coquerel
on a vu Mathilde de panneau la patronne
du groupe LFI à l'Assemblée nationale on
a vu Alexis Corbère on n'a pas vu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il a l'habitude
de venir un peu avant il prend la parole
c'était tout à l'heure aux alentours de
13h 13h30 et après il quitte la
manifestation on sait qu'il y a toujours
un énorme dispositif de sécurité autour
des personnalités encore plus de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et écoutez cette
manifestation qui avance lentement elle
a du mal à progresser ici mais avec il
faut bien
[Musique]
souvent les les inconvénients du métier
merci beaucoup Thibault j'ai une
question Joseph toutvenel qui me fascine
c'est pourquoi il y a il y a un aussi
grand blocage on accorde autant
d'importance à l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est une excellente question
parce que c'est la ma réponse c'est
particulièrement stupide si je ne quand
même pas c'est un message envoyé à vos
ex camarades syndiqué oui je l'envoie je
l'envoie à tout le monde au gouvernement
un certain nombre de penseurs et et un
certain nombre de syndicalistes si je ne
colle pas l'âge et la durée de
cotisation ça ne veut rien dire moi je
peux être parfait des Magog et vous dire
je vous promets la retraite à 58 ans 58
ans c'est l'âge à laquelle le président
du Conseil constitutionnel d'ailleurs a
pris sa retraite le même qui
leur ont Fabius bon mais si je ne colère
pas avec une durée ça ne ça ne veut rien
dire aujourd'hui aujourd'hui non pas
avec la loi Macron qui est pas encore
sorti puisque il y a les décrets
d'applications qui sont en discussion
l'actuel loi quelqu'un qui a 50 ans
aujourd'hui qui a commencé à travailler
à 23 ans ce que la moyenne
cette personne ne pourra pas partir en
retraite avant 66 ans parce que elle
doit faire 43 ans 23 ans plus 43 = 66 et
donc se focaliser comme ça sur l'âge
c'est en plus donner
pour mes amis syndicalistes je leur dis
vous donnez des armes
à ceux qui vous critiquent pourquoi
parce que on s'aperçoit que la France on
nous dit c'est 62 ans c'est pas le pays
le plus jeune en Europe pour le départ à
la retraite il y a des pays comme
l'Autriche c'est 60 ans pour les femmes
je crois que les femmes travaillent il y
a d'autres pays où les femmes peuvent
partir plutôt que les autres mais la
France c'est un des pays où la durée de
cotisations obligatoires avant de
pouvoir bénéficier de la retraite c'est
une des duré les plus longues et je me
sens que l'argument il est là en France
c'est un des pays d'Europe où on doit
travailler le plus longtemps
avant de pouvoir dire je vais où je vais
pas la retraite parce que
l'âge on lui dit 62 ou 64 c'est pas vous
êtes à la retraite c'est l'âge à partir
de laquelle si je remplis les conditions
notamment de durée je peux choisir de
partir la retraite les personnes
travaillaient au-delà personne peut me
mettre dehors d'ailleurs l'entreprise
n'a pas le droit de vous mettre dehors
parce que vous avez atteint ce stage là
l'entreprise peut éventuellement vous
mettre à la retraite d'office à 70 ans
pas avant
le rassemblement national est au Havre à
Paris il n'y a que les syndicats pour
eux c'est une petite victoire culturelle
maintenant que le RN manifeste plus à
Paris je trouve que
un des reproches qu'on peut faire aux
organisations syndicales c'est de
confondre l'action syndicale et sociale
et l'action politique on devrait
totalement séparer les deux après chacun
pense ce qu'il veut vote comme il veut
mais le fait de ne pas attacher l'action
syndicale et l'action politique ça
permet d'être cohérent et d'avoir la
même démarche quel que soit les
gouvernements rappelez-vous quand la
gauche était au pouvoir et que l'arrivée
du Parti socialiste comment tout d'un
coup des syndicats de gauche
ce sont affaissés pour les entendait
plus après 80 etc parce que ils avaient
soutenu les gouvernements officiellement
ils avaient appelé à voter notamment
François Mitterrand en 80 et ça c'est
très mauvais que les saints Ligue 1
garde le indépendance qu'ils prennent
des positions sur les sujets qui les
intéressent et qu'ils ne confondent pas
la vie syndicale et la vie politique
c'est d'ailleurs quand on pose la
question aux salariés la réponse qu'il
donne nous ne voulons pas qu'une
confusion entre le politique et le
syndical c'est vrai que parfois on peut
se poser la question parce qu'on a vu
quand même pas mal les syndicats avec
mobilisés
contre notamment tel ou telle partie
près à mon sens c'est une erreur on peut
défendre des valeurs et dans ces cas-là
on dit voilà nos valeurs voilà
lesquelles si je peux te dire j'ai des
valeurs mais on peut dire voilà ce que
je défends
mais on a à mon sens pas prendre
d'opposition vis-à-vis de tels et telle
partie politique est-ce que les
syndicats ont intérêt à saisir selon
vous la main tendue par le gouvernement
la CFC d'ailleurs a dit que elle elle
n'était pas contre elle avait discuté
avec le condense alors là m'attendu pour
le gouvernement elle arrive un peu tard
mais après moi j'ai une expérience de
négociation au niveau national au niveau
de ma branche professionnelle et de mon
entreprise quand on nous propose de
négocier à mon sens il faut toujours y
aller c'est parce que c'est une chance à
saisir
ça fonctionne ou ça fonctionne pas mais
quand on négocie on discute on a des
interlocuteurs
du travail au Premier ministre mais il y
a les cabinets ministériels il y a des
liens qui se font et il y a la
possibilité de faire avancer les choses
Laurent Berger dit par exemple
aujourd'hui peut-être mais ça va être
très cher donc il fait monter les
enchères est-ce que est-ce que c'est une
bonne façon de répondre c'est à
négociation enfin venir négocier moi
j'ai négocié des accords nationaux
importants
avec les choses avec lesquelles j'ai oui
et d'autres j'ai dit non donc mais je
pense enfin nous ne sommes pas en
dictature on a un pays qui
je m'inquiète pour l'avenir de nos
libertés petit à petit nos libertés se
restreint d'excrait dur et ça c'est très
inquiétant mais on peut s'exprimer on
peut donc tant qu'on peut s'exprimer
tant qu'on peut négocier il faut y aller
jusqu'au bout d'ailleurs les meilleurs
défenseurs de la négociation ce sont nos
militaires de terrain que je connais un
petit peu
et que lequel j'ai discuté et ils disent
mais la négociation ce n'est jamais un
échec ce n'est jamais un échec quand on
est dans des dans des zones de conflits
si on peut négocier à leur faut y aller
ça veut pas dire qu'on va céder ça veut
dire qu'on donne une chance d'arriver à
quelque chose en apaisant sans passer
par la violence il nous reste quelques
minutes Joseph tournenel il y a trois
dossiers proposés par le gouvernement le
partage de la valeur l'assurance chômage
et l'emploi du seigneurs là sur ces
trois dossiers si je vous suis les
syndicats ont une carte à jouer oui mais
alors le partage de la valeur
gouvernement arrive un peu tard
puisqu'il y a eu un accord avec le
patronat
quelques semaines
tous les syndicats à l'acception de la
CGT se sont mis d'accord avec le Medef
la CPME et les artisans l'IPA donc le
gouvernement arrive il est bien gentil
mais il fallait sans saisir avant moi je
me rappelle d'Emmanuel Macron nous
disant qu'il fallait mettre une taxe sur
les super profits
c'est pas trop ce que ça veut dire mais
il faudrait peut-être affiner parce
qu'il y a effectivement notamment du
côté des compagnies pétrolières il y a
eu des supers profits grâce à la crise
mais on a entendu là-dessus alors est-ce
que ça veut dire que le gouvernement va
aller jusqu'au bout des des propos de
Monsieur Macron je sais pas et sur les
autres sujets c'est pareil ce sont des
vrais sujets la pénibilité c'est un vrai
sujet mais enfin il fallait peut-être en
traiter avant de faire un texte de loi
donc remettons les choses dans l'ordre
après si vous organisations syndicales
peuvent discuter et faire avancer les
choses mais en avant question
spécialiste des questions sociales et
sociétales on a assisté à un paradoxe
c'est on a eu la baisse relativement
continue des mobilisations en
particulier des grèves depuis le 19
janvier et un soutien en revanche
constant dans les sondages au mouvement
y compris assez formes y compris à ces
formes les plus radicales on en parlait
tout à l'heure de quoi est-ce le signe
selon vous déjà on a vu qu'il y avait un
échec quand du côté de des transports
publics de la SNCF il y avait journée de
blocage qui avait été lancé ça n'a pas
fonctionné et à mon sens c'est tant
mieux c'est tant mieux parce que bloquer
le pays bloquer les transports c'est
d'abord bloquer des centaines de
milliers de salariés c'est bloqué des
artisans des commerçants enfin du
travailleur des chefs d'entreprise c'est
bloqué l'activité économique et personne
ne s'en sort bien alors que un jour il y
a un coup de saumonce exceptionnellement
mais enfin on va pas le faire à
répétition déjà qu'on souffre dans les
transports en commun pour le
sous-équipement de façon criant tous les
jours c'est un peu égoïste à mon sens
c'est pas du reste syndicaliste c'est de
l'égoïsme de refaire donc que ça ne
marche pas je m'en réjouis que le
blocage du pays ne fonctionne pas je
m'en réjouis parce que je souffre quand
je vois dans quel état est mon pays ça
ne veut pas dire non plus que on est
d'accord avec ce texte et avec d'autres
pratiques sociales du gouvernement
ça mène à dire quoi ça mène à dire que
moins de rassemblement moins de
manifestation moins de grève mais ça
veut pas dire que les choses vont pas
rejaillir parce que le pays est
mécontent globalement n'a pu confiance
dans le gouvernement ni dans ses
promesses ni dans ses discours ça veut
dire que ça peut ça
totalement qu'on peut pas imaginer
aujourd'hui comme il y a eu des bonnets
rouges ou les gilets jaunes ou les
gilets jaunes parce que sinon on voit
pas comment enfin en tous les cas les
personnes qui tiennent ces causes
peuvent faire peuvent faire avancer ses
causes si la violence ça marche pas si
la manifestation pacifique vous savez le
moyen le plus est négociation ne marche
pas non non le moyen le plus efficace
dont on ne se rend pas compte mais qui
existe c'est à négociation dans nos
entreprises et regardez bien ce qui se
passe au niveau des salaires
au niveau des salaires dans les
entreprises pendant toutes mais dans
beaucoup il y a eu des décisions qui ont
été prises qui permettent de suivre
l'inflation ça se fait pas au niveau de
l'État ça et donc je comprends pas
compte en France c'est que la force des
organisations syndicales et là je mets
sur le même plan organisation patronale
et organisation salariés c'est d'arriver
dans les entreprises dans les branches
professionnelles à prendre les problèmes
et à les résoudre dans leur grande
majorité et je crois plus qu'on avancera
dans les entreprises que au niveau
national ok
apparemment on devrait avoir Alexis
Corbière dans un instant mais pour
l'instant les images figent encore donc
dès qu'on le voit apparaître à l'antenne
on le on le prendra en attendant Joseph
Tournelle deux dernières questions
est-ce que syndical reste aussi une
est-ce que le fait que l'international
reste aussi uni alors on va prendre
Alexis Corbières et on revient juste
après avec vous pour une dernière
question et après on retrouvera Grégory
Jaude
[Musique]
ouais
c'est vrai oui on est en direct avec
Alexis Corbière Alexis Corbière député
la France insoumise c'est la fête du
travail aujourd'hui ou c'est la 13e
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites d'abord si vous
tirez les oreilles parce qu'on dit pas
la fête du travail il y a un enjeu c'est
la journée internationale de lutte des
travailleurs c'est un vieux une vieille
chose c'est né en 1889 et c'est quelque
chose qui est dit au mont ouvrier si je
vous taquine c'est que la dénomination
j'ai vu il y a même je crois que c'est
Madame Le Pen qui parle de fête de la
nation fait du travail c'était un peu le
nom sur le régime de Vichy là c'est les
travailleurs et là ça vanillation alors
une fois qu'on a dit ça vous me disiez
non c'est pas un baroud d'honneur c'est
ça l'expression que m'avait dit non je
vous ai demandé si aujourd'hui on se
mobilisait contre la réforme des
retraites ou est-ce que on fêtait les
travailleurs quel est l'objectif de la
journée des deux en même temps si on
fait les travailleurs si on défend les
travailleurs évidemment qu'on n'est pas
pour les faire travailler plus longtemps
leur imposer deux ans de plus c'est les
usées d'un montage c'est leur demander
de travailler plus
[Musique]
honnêtement là la France est dans un
état turbulence politique et alors
est-ce que vous en êtes responsable
d'une certaine manière avec votre
attitude à l'Assemblée nationale par
exemple en faisant tout pour ne pas
voter cette loi est-ce que vous êtes
responsable de cette crise démocratique
vous aussi la France insoumise et la
nuit pêche alors ça c'est vraiment
l'expression mais je vous aime bien
d'être sympa comme ça merci
c'est à dire que moi j'ai pas vu des
gens manifester pour vous dire les
insoumis à l'Assemblée vous déposez trop
d'un moment par contre j'ai vu de mes
yeux et vous aussi parce que notre
journaliste que le jour où le 49-3 était
utilisé il y a des milliers de gens qui
sont sortis dans la rue on va être
sérieux ce qui choque des gens moi je
suis pas d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron
mais normalement en République et en
démocratie il y a un consentement à
l'autorité on fait des élections on
s'engueule vous défendez en candidats
j'en ai fait un autre et moi le peuple
est souvent en tranche et normalement
c'est lui qui prend la décision
représente la part majoritaire du peuple
le problème désormais qui déjà a été
contenu dans les dernières élections
c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron il est élu dans
un rejet de Madame Le Pen et par la
suite après il est même pas majoritaire
à l'Assemblée et il utilise tout ce
qu'il y a de plus Antilles démocratique
dans la 5e République pour imposer un
texte que selon les études d'opinion les
deux tiers des Français ne veulent pas
et ça ça choque donc ça ça participe à
la crise démocratique alors un homme
comme moi peut s'en féliciter sur un
aspect c'est que moi je dépends l'idée
qu'il faut sortir de la 5e République il
faut un régime plus parlementaire plus
de pouvoir au Parlement moins de
présidentialisme il faut des pouvoirs
pour que le citoyen puisse être un
acteur civique pas seulement le jour des
élections et après pendant 5 ans tu es
un mineur politique et une fois tous les
50 a le droit de vote et que tu puisses
intervenir politiquement comment par un
référendum par exemple il y a les trucs
on connaissait le riz que le rythme sur
un grand sujet comme la retraite il y
avait le souverain étant le peuple
aurait dû trancher cette question là
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas le faire
donc tout ça vous voyez bien on peut
faire oui mais la tranchée d'une
certaine manière en me lisant Emmanuel
Macron c'était dans son programme alors
oui vous l'avez dit en barrage pour vous
à Marine Le Pen mais il a été élu
Emmanuel Macron alors ça c'est les
arguments en formel très bien je
si on me pose la question qui est le
président de la République je réponds
c'est Emmanuel Macron je conteste pas
qu'il est président de la République
maintenant quand on est républicain il
faut aller seulement au-delà de ça la
question c'est un homme qui est au
premier tour des élections
présidentielles rassemble 18% des
électeurs inscrits des électeurs
inscrits c'est-à-dire 24 26 des exprimés
au second tour dans son rejet de Madame
Le Pen beaucoup de gens qui ont voté un
soumis mais pas seulement si je vais
quand même voter pour lui parce que je
sais pas encore avec papa il fait 38 %
des électeurs et au soir de cette
victoire il dit ce vote m'oblige je sais
que beaucoup de gens qui ont voté pour
moi n'ont pas voté pour mon programme
mais pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite normalement ça devrait amener à
ce que
ce président soit un peu mesuré et de la
décence n'impose pas une réforme
antipopulaire dans ces conditions et il
ne le fait pas donc il prend le risque
lui-même par cette attitude être un
accélérateur de la crise la dernière
question avec sikorbert est-ce que en
faisant descendre à nouveau les gens
dans la rue avec les syndicats comme
vous le faites vous ne leur donnez pas à
faux espoir la réforme est passé le
Conseil constitutionnel a validé est-ce
que au fond vous continuez à les faire
descendre mais pour pas grand chose le
résultat de la lutte il est donné par la
lutte elle-même c'est pas vrai je dirais
pas c'est fini on n'en sait rien parce
que je viens de vous décrire peut-être
maladroitement qu'on est dans un moment
de crise politique quand même
l'apparence institutionnelle peut donner
momentanément le point Macron il n'a
politiquement le pays n'est pas
stabilisé d'ailleurs ça peut mal finir
de mon point de vue c'est à dire ça peut
être même l'extrême droite qui en
profite Macron n'a pas restabilisé le
pays autour de sa politique la preuve
symbolique les casseroles il aura beau
faire le malin au Stade de France des
copains qui étaient m'ont dit on l'a vu
jamais une seule fois sur un écran donc
il a un problème qui est pas seulement
c'est la faute à Mélenchon et Corbières
qui tape sur des casseroles il sait bien
qu'il est il a une impopularité qui est
un problème politique et ça c'est un
sujet qui qui va falloir qui continue à
s'exprimer là donc il faut se mobiliser
et je termine enfin le 8 juin il y a une
niche à l'Assemblée nationale donc ça
est-ce que c'est la niche là c'est une
journée du groupe yote et qui va déposer
une noix pour la progression de la
retraite à 64 ans parce que la loi a
fait une loi appel de faire quand on est
républicaine on peut gagner là-dessus
donc il y a beaucoup de raisons de se
mobiliser de le faire encore et les gens
qui sont là en raison merci beaucoup
Alexis cover député de la France
insoumise vous l'avez compris du côté de
l'insoumis et dans la manifestation on y
croit encore à ce que cette réforme des
retraites puisse être arrangé et puisse
ne jamais voir le jour
si beaucoup Thibault effectivement le
message était clair Joseph touvenel la
valeur travail c'est abstrait c'est ce
que dit
Alexis Corbière c'est votre point de vue
aussi non non pas du tout mais il est
très cohérent avec
les travailleurs pour lui c'est le monde
ouvrier et les salariés
pour le social chrétien que je suis un
travailleur c'est évidemment un salarié
c'est un artisan c'est un commerçant
c'est un chef d'entreprise c'est même
des parents une mère de famille qui
élève ses enfants toutes ces personnes
travaillent et le travail c'est très
compresse c'est quoi c'est participer au
bien commun être co-créateur participé à
une œuvre et c'est ça qui veut
revaloriser c'est ça qu'il faut reporter
dans notre pays ce sens de participer au
bien commun mais ça veut dire aussi que
le bien commun pour un pays c'est la
nation
a commencé en étant internationaliste en
lisant le 1er mai c'est international
c'est pas la fête du Travail oui c'est
pas la fête du travail c'est le
c'était international mais en face
internationale quand on voyait les
malheureux par milliers qui devait
défiler le premier mai dans les rues de
Moscou parce que le pouvoir soviétique
en avait décidé ainsi moi c'est pas ma
fête ça m'a fait c'est effectivement
celle du travail comme je viens d'où
l'indiquer celle de tous les
travailleurs
situé par Vichy le message alors qu'il
soit obsédé par un passé peut-être parce
que les origines communistes font que
les communistes avant de se séparer des
nazis m'ont attendu qu'il y a une
fâcherie entre Hitler et Staline c'est
possible moi c'est pas mon cas moi je
suis fils de résistant j'ai un père qui
était emprisonné à Fresnes alors j'ai
pas du tout le quand il y a quelque
chose qui est bien et bien si ça a été
institué sous Vichy officiellement je
m'en moque totalement j'y en ai aucune
responsabilité c'est la fête du travail
c'est la fête des travailleurs et
comment redonner dans notre pays sa
vraie valeur et au travail ça passe sans
doute par des salaires je pense à des
professions comme les professions de
santé mais pas que mais ça passe à cette
notion de rétablir la notion de bien
commun et d'être co-créateur de
participer à une œuvre merci beaucoup
Joseph tout venait merci d'être passé
d'un studio du Firo je rappelle votre
revue ces capitales sociales
c'est-à-dire c'est passionnant chaque
voilà on voit notamment un des numéros à
la France au travail mensonge et vérité
tous les numéros sont à lire merci
beaucoup Joseph d'être venu merci
beaucoup votre invitation et puis vous
reviendrez on va retrouver Damien
Canivez qui lui est dans une autre
partie du cortège à l'avant du cortège
on avait eu des tensions tout à l'heure
Damien est-ce que c'est toujours est-ce
que c'est toujours le cas on voit
également que les forces de l'ordre sont
rassemblés est-ce que c'est le cas
autour de vous
oui absolument Vincent c'est toujours le
cas c'est extrêmement tendu ici
boulevard Voltaire vous voyez que les
manifestants ont tenté de ont tenté de
diriger une barricade et ils ne laissant
pas parvenus puisque les forces de
l'ordre sont intervenues ici à toute
vitesse alors je sais pas si vous
m'entendez bien parce que j'ai le masque
pour éviter d'être atteint par les gaz
lacrymogènes juste devant le nez ici
c'est assez irrespirable pour nous les
les journalistes et même les
manifestants puisque un nuage de gaz
lacrymogène vient d'être lancé par les
forces de l'ordre pour pour faire en
sorte que le black bloc se disperse vous
savez que il y a eu plusieurs charges
qui ont eu lieu depuis le début de la
manifestation on a quand même
l'impression que c'est plutôt bien géré
ici en termes de en termes de sécurité
les forces de l'ordre viennent repartent
viennent repartent de façon à ce que il
n'y a finalement aucun black bloc qui ne
se constitue et c'est plutôt réussi on
doit dire ici puisque les 2000 et 500
manifestants qui étaient très très
compact tout à l'heure
et bien son
ce sont un peu dispersés de façon à ce
que les les forces de l'ordre puissent
les maîtriser là il y avait et aussi une
nouvelle charge juste derrière nous
c'est policiers qui sont assez malmenés
depuis le début de la manifestation
puisque ils ont essuyé des tiers de
mortier on peut vous en dire quelque
chose d'ici avec Julien Leclerc qui
filme ses images puisque nous étions
juste derrière le cordon de de policier
et on a pu voir c'est j'ai de projet de
projectiles et c'est j'ai de mortier
d'artifice depuis les éléments radicaux
et on a même été d'ailleurs avec filtré
un moment donné parce qu'effectivement
ça devenait extrêmement dangereux pour
tout le monde alors pour le moment c'est
assez confus ici vous avez des cordons
de policiers qui se trouvent un peu de
part et d'autre de cette avenue il y
avait énormément de manifestants qui
étaient compacts tout à l'heure et
maintenant ils se sont dispersés en un
tout petit nombre malgré eux bien
évidemment puisque leur objectif était
de rester très compact et là ils sont
effectivement par par petit groupe il se
trouve par petit groupe sur ce boulevard
Voltaire merci beaucoup Damien pour ces
précisons bien entendu vous prenez soin
de vous vous prenez pas de risque
inutile et pas de risque du tout
effectivement on voit quand même tout
c'est manifestants de masquées c'étire
de gaz lacrymogène bonjour Grégory
syndicaliste policier SGP Police
on voit il y a un poste qui est donné
sur le live texte du Figaro qui est
juste en dessous de ce player
on tient au courant on tient informé les
internautes du Figaro minute par minute
seconde par seconde presque et on peut y
lire notamment que les Black Blocs sont
contraintes jongler avec les drones on
l'entendait à l'instant Damien Cadillac
disait que les taux des Black Blocs
c'est desserré à un moment est-ce que
c'est justement est-ce qu'il faut en
attribuer le fait de la cause à la
présence des drones
je pense qu'il y aura un retour
d'expérience justement c'est la première
fois que les drones sont utilisés sur la
préfecture de police et pas la
préfecture de police sur un sur un
événement comme comme celui-ci donc
faudra voir exactement l'appui technique
que ça a amené justement pour pour mes
collègues dans l'appréciation de des
mouvements de foule notamment
celui des Black Blocs parce que
l'intérêt des drones c'est celui-ci
c'est de pouvoir essayer d'anticiper
les mouvements le fait que le black bloc
se réunisse et de pouvoir justement être
un peu en avant et et les empêcher de le
faire donc si c'est si c'est grâce au
drone j'ai envie de dire tant mieux
puisque c'est ce qu'on attendait vos
informations à l'heure actuelle comment
ça se passe pas très bien il y a à peu
près 900 individus avec un profil
extrêmement dangereux de nationalité
nationalités étrangères pour certains
pas mal d'allemand pas mal d'Italiens
donc qui sont vraiment venus là
confirmer la présence d'éléments venus
de l'étranger
pour créer un certain nombre de
violences
des collègues du service enseignement
que j'ai pu croiser d'autres qui étaient
sur le sur la manifestation parce que
j'en viens qui m'ont confirmé qu'en
effet il y avait des des Black Blocs
étrangers pour le coup vous étiez à la
manifestation comment ça se passait
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu qu'est-ce que
vous avez entendu j'étais au début à la
République avant de venir dans vos
studio donc l'ambiance comme ça là
exactement c'était un bon enfant de la
musique malgré la pluie qui qui tombait
mais je pense que ça s'est amélioré ce
qu'on a pu voir là c'est bien sûr bien
avant bien devant le cortège et et je
vous le répète 900 individus
particulièrement avec un profil
inquiétant 2500 en tout et de nombreux
étrangers notamment allemand et italien
ça s'est avéré dans quel état d'esprit
sont actuellement les forces de l'ordre
13e événement mais au-delà de ça il y a
aussi tous les déplacements politiques
on a dû évidemment encadrer parce
qu'aujourd'hui il demande une sécurité
assez importante donc
forcément émoussé
un peu fatigué par par la récurrence
justement et la séquence qui commence à
être longue d'ailleurs c'était les parce
que là c'est pas dangereux justement
parce que c'est pas là qui peut y avoir
de dérapage il y a une forme de
résilience quand même dans les forces de
l'ordre notamment les forces mobiles et
les collègues de compagnie
d'intervention parisienne et les
gendarmes ou on a l'habitude de ce genre
de journée qui il faut lui aussi le dire
durent très longtemps on prend pas le
service à 14h qu'on a la manifestation
commence on est déjà en place quatre ou
cinq heures avant et on va souvent
terminer deux ou trois heures après donc
on sait déjà que ça va être d'évacuation
très longue on sait que c'est éprouvant
physiquement mais il y a aussi de
l'entraînement il y a aussi de la
résilience et surtout il y a de la
manœuvre Collective on est on est quand
même dans une dans une dans une voilà
dans un métier collectif pour le coup et
c'est ce qui je pense aussi nous
préserve de certains de certains de
certains débordements ou de certains
gestes situation tendue à nous signale
un des
envoyés spéciaux du Figaro notamment au
niveau du boulevard Voltaire c'est ce
qu'on a pu voir également sur certaines
images encore que là les images que l'on
peut voir qui sont en tête de cortège
sont un petit peu plus calmes et moins
montre moins de tension que ce qu'on a
pu voir auparavant Laurent l'unesse ne
craint pas plus des débordements que
lors des journées précédentes vous
partagez sa sérénité
de toute façon il y avait à peu près les
mêmes remontées de risques avec le même
nombre d'éléments violents sur les
manifestations précédentes notamment on
craignait une participation des jeunes
qui sont toujours plus difficiles
encadrer et moins respectueux des
cortèges prévus etc et je vous rappelle
quand même et je le rappelle il y a eu
1200 fonctionnaires de police blessés on
va écouter
on va revenir sur ces sur ces points là
on va écouter justement Fabien Roussel
qui est une des forces montantes à
gauche qui visiblement est au micro de
Thibault Gauthier est-ce que c'est
toujours le cas
[Musique]
manifestants ont défilé dans les Russes
selon les contes réalisées par Le Figaro
data avec les chiffres préfectoraux
s'étaient à 15h alors c'est plus que le
13 avril à la même heure à l'époque à ce
jour-là on dénombré 221
000 manifestants mais c'est beaucoup
moins que le 7 mars c'est moitié moins
que les 7 mars ou on avait dénombré ce
jour-là à cette heure-là 1,28 millions
d'individus dans les rues de France un
peintre le pavé contre la réforme
notamment contre la réforme des
retraites on voit quand même que ça se
tend régulièrement sur les images qui
n'ont pas bien également de
du trajet entre Bastille et boulevard et
place de la Nation oui vous servez comme
ça quasiment tout le long ça a commencé
très tôt donc là on sait que ça va être
du gain terrain à chaque fois que le
black bloc ou que les éléments ultra
vont essayer de bloquer le cortège ou
faire des points de cristallisation le
travail de mes collègues ça devait être
rapidement les évacuer parce que
derrière le cortège pousse donc il faut
essayer qu'il qu'il poursuivent sa route
sans être saccadé c'est la plus grosse
difficulté tout en protégeant les
manifestants en faisant attention au
bâtiment au départ de feu enfin c'est
assez complexe c'est un numéro
d'équilibré ce dangereux de situation on
parlait tout à l'heure de de l'emploi du
droit des drones donc ils font des
balles la justice en la limite et voir
interdit l'accès notamment ce que nous
disait tout à l'heure Mathieu Valley en
Seine-et-Marne
[Musique]
colère notamment contre le Syndicat de
la magistrature qui me semble qu'elle
est magistrat qui en avait appelé à leur
interdiction vous les trouvez utile mais
ça sera utile après moi je vais
simplifier les choses je trouve ça
incroyable d'avoir encore des
oppositions comme ça bien sûr qu'il faut
être en faire attention aux libertés
publiques bien sûr que pour faire
attention aux libertés individuelles
bien sûr qu'il faut faire attention à
celle d'aller venir etc mais là on parle
de sécurité je veux dire nous faire tout
de suite le procès de la police
d'affichage potentiel de d'espionnage on
va dire ou
alors on est quand même dans une société
particulière la plupart des gens qui
critiquent ce système là ont leur carte
de fidélité à Carrefour ou ailleurs ou
un téléphone cellulaire sont quasiment
ils laissent des traces toutes les
toutes les 10 minutes et et épouse
décrits d'orfray quand on explique qu'on
va utiliser des drones pour pour
protéger les manifestations essayer de
judiciaire réserve un peu mieux le matin
le maintien de l'ordre je trouve ça
hallucinant Damien Canivez vous êtes sur
place on a vu encore
des tirs de grenades lacrymogènes ça
s'est passé autour de vous visiblement
oui absolument nous sommes au niveau de
la place du 8 février 1962 la police est
en train de reprendre un petit peu du
terrain voilà donc nous sommes toujours
sur cette itinéraire qui relie la place
de la République à la place de la
macination à Paris et des pavés sont en
train de pleuvoir en direction des
forces de l'ordre des tirs de mortier
d'artifice également vous venez d'en
voir un sur les images tournées par
Julien Leclerc alors c'est vrai que
c'est assez confus parce qu'il y avait
énormément de de d'éléments radicaux en
début de manifestation et c'est assez
compliqué d'avoir un aperçu musculaire
de ce qui se passe sur ce boulevard
Voltaire parce que on a le sentiment
qu'il y a de nombreuses de le tragot qui
sont éparpillés sur ce boulevard
Voltaire à la suite de charge de la part
de la police et de la gendarmerie
nationale là pour le moment vous voyez
un cordon justement de gendarmes qui
vise à accomplir les manifestants
puisque précédemment ces conditions
qu'ils arrivent à mieux les à mieux les
appréhender de part et d'autre de ce
boulevard Voltaire il y a des policiers
qui sont là pour justement qui sont
prêts à charger la foule dès lors
qu'elle commence à commettre des
exactions on a vu tout à l'heure encore
une fois de plus et chaîne de de grandes
distributions qui ont été vandalisées
des assurances également des banques
c'est assez compliqué de se faire une
idée de ce qui se passe réellement ici
en tout cas vous voyez encore de
nombreux paramètres et peut-être sur les
images de génial Leclerc puisque vous le
savez la manifestation est suivie par
des drones de la préfecture de police de
Paris c'est-à-dire assez compliqué la la
la la la
façon dont les militants d'ultra gauche
sont en train de se DVD parce que l'idée
pour eux d'être habillé en noir c'est de
ne pas de ne pas être reconnu par les
caméras de vidéosurveillance et c'est
drone complique encore plus la chose
voyez une charge de la police un sous
vos yeux par les images de Julien et
lorsque il y a une charge de la police
il faut toujours être très très vigilant
puisque des pavés pleuvent sur ces
forces de l'or pour évidemment les
ralentir dans leur dans leur traversée
voilà là c'était une grenade de
désencerclement qui vient d'être un
ancré par les forces de l'ordre c'est
assez compliqué ce qui se passe là sur
la fin de ce boulevard alors on voit
aussi des de nombreux de nombreux
blessés de la part des manifestants
comme dans la part de la police
il y a des médecins aussi qui encadrent
cette manifestation et qui interviennent
dès lors que un manifestant se trouve au
sol on en a vu quelques heures depuis
tout à l'heure des policiers aussi sont
blessés on a vu quelques policiers qui
ont été justement exciteraient par leurs
camarades à la suite de cette
projectiles voilà où est-ce publié sur
les images de Julien Leclerc on assiste
depuis le début de cette manifestation
qui s'était lancée à 14h place de la
République à Paris c'est assez confus
des bouteilles vides qui j'ai qui vont
tous les sens là vous voyez encore cette
situation assez tendue sur les images
avec des jets de morte et d'artifice
vous voyez qui sont jetés en direction
des forces des forces de l'ordre et on a
le sentiment qu'ils sont sans être
vraiment dépassé mais qu'ils sont
vraiment prises à partie plus que jamais
ici sur cette manifestation la toute 1er
mai on en a couvert beaucoup avec Julien
Leclerc mais c'est celle de loin qui est
la plus violente au regard du nombre de
manifestants ultra violents qui sont ici
on rappelle que le ramunès s'attendait à
ce qu'il y ait 2000 militants d'ultra
gauche on a l'impression en fait qu'ils
sont beaucoup plus nombreux ici ils sont
là sur le boulevard Voltaire à Paris
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Damien pour ces
précisions effectivement on est un petit
peu dans la confusion ici parce qu'on a
des informations qui nous parviennent
mais elles méritent d'être confirmés
mais en tous les cas des bonnes sources
qui nous disent qu'un policier
aurait pris feu je cite visé par un
cocktail Molotov on est en train de voir
de confirmer ça
si c'était vrai en tous les cas Grégory
violence ce serait une première et ce
serait un en tout cas un cap qui serait
franchi dans la la violence et la
gravité malheureusement pas une première
d'ailleurs le premier policier qui a
fait l'objet vraiment de d'un cocktail
où il s'est transformé en torche humaine
c'était d'ailleurs sur un premier mai en
2018 ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut
avec un collègue qui a été brûlé au
deuxième degré profond presque au
troisième car risqué la grève de peau
autour de la bouche parce que justement
il y avait pas la cagoule à l'époque il
avait dû son salut grâce à un policier à
côté qui était ancien militaire et qui
avait du matériel personnel
ils mettent une grande bande de gel HYD
de gel
alcoolique une grande bande de gel en
fait qu'il avait pour pour éviter que la
brûlure n'aille plus profond et donc en
fait normalement on a eu plusieurs
épisodes comme ça rappelez-vous de
certaines images médias où on avait
justement des CRS transformés en torche
humaine on a déjà eu le cas si c'est le
cas par contre il y a vraiment des
risques de blessures extrêmement
importants c'était la question que
j'avais à vous poser c'est est-ce que
c'est ça qui est pas le plus compliqué
dans ces manifestations si c'est très
difficile parce que vous voyez des
projectiles on parle quand même de
bombes agricoles on parle de mortier on
parle de cocktail Molotov on l'a vu sur
les épisodes précédents ce sont des
projectiles des amas de plâtre ou de
ciment avec des clous des vis qui sont
qui sont entre enchevêtrés et qui
peuvent créer vraiment des blessures
assez importantes donc si la difficulté
c'est ça parce qu'on est face à ce feu
nourri de projectile ça tombe de partout
c'est ça dure des fois plusieurs minutes
avant qu'on puisse manœuvrer et
forcément c'est extrêmement compliqué à
gérer et on sait que ça génère beaucoup
de dégâts dans nos rang puisque
on le disait tout à l'heure c'est plus
de 1200 de mes collègues qui ont été
blessés depuis le début de cette
séquence
que vous raconte justement vos collègues
alors après c'est toujours un sentiment
mitigé parce que on sait qu'on est là
pour faire ce boulot là particulièrement
ceux qui sont engagés sur ces
manifestations parce qu'en général ils
aiment ce métier de maintien de l'ordre
et et c'était et c'est des missions
quand même qui sont particulières mais
de l'autre côté c'est vrai que forcément
il y a une forme d'appréhension quand on
voit le nombre de blessés encore une
fois et notamment je pense par exemple à
la 22e compagnie de Périgueux à Nantes
où il y a eu une trentaine de blessés
d'un coup 18 personnes
hospitalisées tout ça en l'espace de une
demi-heure parce qu'ils ont été coincés
dans un dans un dans un dans un dans une
mauvaise gestion on va dire et ça a été
très compliqué donc toujours ce
sentiment de on est là et on doit y
aller parce que c'est notre mission il y
a une forme de noblesse quand même dans
ce métier et de l'autre côté quand même
malgré tout le fait de savoir que de
toute façon on risque quand même
d'être blessés et regarder c'est là
exactement en fait voilà tout à fait
alors ça les internautes vous le voyez
pas mais justement on essaie de
d'authentifier l'image pour l'instant et
pour pour effectivement vous la montrer
mais effectivement les images sont assez
impressionnantes qui nous parviennent
sur sur Twitter on voulait on va vous
les montrer dans un instant mais on va
montrer le compte Twitter d'où ça
provient d'abord qui est celui de voilà
de Mathieu Valley voilà on va on voit
les ces images là ou avec donc des
des personnes qui sont effectivement
victimes de tir de de cocktail Molotov
voilà
c'est c'est effectivement assez
impressionnant
en étant en flamme clairement donc là on
a rien pour pour éteindre
il y a des collègues qu'on peut
peut-être des extincteurs autour alors
après c'est forcément une situation
dégradée donc c'est extrêmement confuse
toujours compliqué
maintenant on a des tenues qui sont
non-feu en espérant que qu'elle qu'elle
soit en bon état cette nuit au collègue
qu'elle puisse l'avoir protégé ça
empêche pas que vous prenez quand même
un sacré coup de chaud et
potentiellement faudra prendre de ses
nouvelles pour savoir si malheureusement
il y a pas il y a pas malgré tout des
brûlures assez profondes parce que parce
que c'est c'est ce que ça engendrons
engendre pardon on le sait on l'a déjà
vécu est-ce qu'il y a vous lisez donc il
y a une lassitude chez les policiers par
rapport à ces rassemblements
et d'un autre côté on se dit plus il y a
des
il y a ce genre de rassemblement là plus
on est à guéri donc
oui ça fait partie on peut pas que
s'entraîner évidemment ça fait partie de
l'expérience acquise c'est ce qui fait
la force je pense moi des forces mobiles
puisque je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est une mission collective donc il y a
beaucoup de retour d'expérience bien sûr
il y a beaucoup il y a aussi une mémoire
collective donc après vous avez des
réflexes quand vous êtes face à des
situations dégradée parce que vous avez
vous les avez déjà vécu parce que c'est
ancré parce que vous en parlez parce que
vous débriefer en effet et parce que le
coût d'après vous serez peut-être mieux
positionné peut-être avec une relation
une réaction un peu plus rapide encore
un peu mieux coordonnée pour justement
vous permettre d'être le plus efficace
possible dans dans votre action pour
vous protéger mais aussi pour protéger
les manifestants donc c'est évidemment
de l'expérience c'est une expérience qui
coûte cher on va pas se mentir parce que
j'imagine qu'à la fin de la journée on
va dénombrer quand même plusieurs
dizaines de blessés dans nos rang c'est
une réalité
on va retrouver dans un instant Thibault
Gauthier qui lui est dans une partie
plus pacifique du cortège
on reste quelques instants encore parce
qu'on a le plaisir de la voir avec nous
avec Grégory Jorand est-ce que vous
prévoyez est-ce que vous craignez un
retour des gilets jaunes dans tous les
cas dans la manifeste dans la partie la
plus radicale de la manifestation de
leur manifestation clairement non les
notes de renseignement en tout cas
particulièrement des renseignements
territoriaux ne font pas
montrent d'un gros regain d'activité au
niveau des gilets jaunes il y a toujours
les éléments ultra qui sont quelques
quelques milliers à peine en France et
sur le territoire mais clairement là le
gros de la masse et quand même répond à
l'appel des syndicats et des grandes
confédérations les gilets jaunes à Paris
c'est des ultra jaune et doivent être à
peu près 1000 ou 1500 aujourd'hui vous
voyez c'est quand même très peu par
rapport par rapport aux chiffres des
manifestants qui répondent à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale donc il y a pas il y a
pas de
gilet jaune pour le coup à craindre pour
l'instant
comment ce sont de mes dernières
questions c'est comment vous vous de
votre côté dans votre syndicat vous
pensez qu'il faut relever le défi lancé
par les Black Blocs et la difficulté
elle est non seulement à les heures
préhender mais même aussi à les empêcher
de pouvoir
se former et et nuit en force de l'arbre
je pense qu'il y a trois choses très
rapidement il y en a qui a la première
chose c'est qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
avant parce que pour le coup une fois
qu'ils sont sur le terrain on voit bien
quel que soit la démocratie européenne
quel que soit les techniques de maintien
de notre mise en place dans les
différents pays quand il y a des
éléments ultra dans les manifestations
c'est extrêmement difficile à
appréhender la Belgique est en
difficulté l'Allemagne est en difficulté
l'Espagne la Suède tout le monde est de
difficulté d'Italie donc ça c'est le
premier point donc déjà il faudrait nous
donner des outils légaux pour faire en
sorte d'empêcher les éléments les plus
radicaux et bien de venir manifester je
pense que la clé elle est là elle est là
ensuite évidemment
des choses à améliorer en termes de en
termes de techniques de maintien de
l'ordre de matériel etc et puis il y a
le troisième temps c'est celui de la
judiciarisation on voit bien que
justement souvent
la justice estime les éléments
constitutifs d'infraction qu'on relève
trop fragile parce qu'on est dans une
situation dégradée parce que tout le
monde
un peu préventives je pense qu'il nous
faut des outils en tout cas pour nous
permettre rappelez-vous c'est ce qui
avait essayé de faire Castaner sur la
loi d'identité pour la résumer et
malheureusement il voulait donner des
des pouvoirs de police administrative au
préfet ça avait été retoqué je pense
qu'il va falloir un moment donné qu'on
prenne ce chemin là quand même pour
empêcher justement ces éléments les plus
ultra de venir pourrir nos
manifestations comme ils le font depuis
des années maintenant merci Grégory
Joron je rappelle que vous représentez
SGP Police merci beaucoup d'être venu
dans le studio nous donner vos
témoignages on voit justement la
situation vers la place ça doit être
vous et on ça doit remonter vers la
place de la Nation apparemment entre
quand on n'a pas la situation exacte
mais ça y ressemble on va retrouver
retourner un petit peu en arrière dans
le cortège retrouvé Thibault Gauthier
quel est l'ambiance là où vous trouvez
en cher Thibault
de ce qu'on vous entend dire et
d'ailleurs on avait des séquelles
parfois regardez ce magasin par exemple
alors que la manifestation se passe très
bien ici avec des champs avec des souris
avec de l'espoir pour certains et bien
lorsqu'on s'approche en fait on va sur
on repasse sur les lieux où sont passés
les casseurs vous le voyez ici vous
voyez cette cette boutique de courtage
en crédit évidemment la cible de
certains militants de l'ultra gauche
vous le voyez ici avec les cas c'est
fini de l'autre côté lorsqu'on traverse
et bien il a également un Vélib par
exemple je vous amène et je vous montre
chez au milieu d'un de la fin d'un feu
voyez au milieu des au milieu des
cendres alors que par tout ailleurs et
bien autour de cela l'ambiance est bonne
il faut il faut dire avec des gens qui
espèrent avec des gens qui se
réjouissent de la fin de la pluie parce
que la manifestation au début a pu
refroidir a pu être refroidie par par un
orage qui a frappé violemment la place
de la République et maintenant dans le
cortège en direction de la place de la
soie bien tout se passe parfaitement
bien et on le voit on passe sur les
décombres de ce qu'il s'est passé plus
en amont nous avons l'impression d'une
certaine manière de suivre les casseurs
sans jamais les rattraper voilà
merci beaucoup Thibault merci pour pour
ces précisions on est avec Thomas en
grand en plateau Thomas Engrand c'est on
a les gauchologues il y a les
syndicatologues
donc vous suivez donc l'actualité vous
suivez vous couvrez les syndicats aux
figures économiques doit-on le rappeler
vous étiez en tête de cortège en début
de en début de défilé comment ça se
passait qui a été l'ambiance bah c'est
sûr que ça a rien à voir avec ça quand
on assiste en ce moment
bah forcément déjà en tête de cortège il
y a tous les services d'or notamment des
syndicats à commencer par celui de la
CGT qui est assez important et qui a une
vraie maîtrise de ce genre d'événement
vu que la CGT un long passé de
manifestation mobilisation et grève en
tout genre donc non en général ça se
passe bien malgré tout on a quand même
vu bien avant le début du cortège parce
que moi j'y suis arrivé vers midi le
cortège a démarré vers 14h si j'ai pas
de bêtises le
a déjà avait déjà été doublé par je
dirais un groupe dans à peu près 150 200
gilets jaunes un peu alors radicaux ça
paraît enfin ils ont pas été violents
excité je pensais le terme mais très
remonté notamment contre la CFDT et même
compte les syndicats en général on sait
que les les deux syndicats d'un côté
gilet jaune de l'autre ne se porte pas
forcément mutuellement dans dans leur
cœur donc donc effectivement il y a eu
quelques phrases de gestes on va dire
notamment direction de Laurent Berger
qui était pas des plus sympathique donc
effectivement
parce que
d'être trop conciliant c'est à dire que
bah alors il fait déjà face à cela de la
part d'une partie des syndicats comme la
CGT surtout de la base de la provaticale
de la CGT qui pourrait le point de salut
que la grève générale les manifestations
et puis qui veut rester bloqué sur cette
question de retraite ad vitam eternam
voilà et les gilets jaunes sont un peu
dans cette mouvance
alors est-ce que c'est la retraite ou en
fait c'est tout en général ils sont dans
une posture extrême de refus de de haine
du gouvernement et des institutions donc
clairement un syndicat comme la CFDT ça
peut pas ça peut pas fonctionner et donc
la position qui a été inflexible de
Laurent Berger pour l'instant n'oubliez
pas en tout cas crédité par les éléments
les plus radicaux bah sans surprise
c'était déjà c'était déjà le mot d'ordre
lors du congrès de la CGT fin avril ou
beaucoup de délégués reprochait alors à
Laurent Berger l'ancien indirecteur
Philippe Martinez l'ancien numéro de la
CGT d'être trop proche des positions de
Robert je vais être trop dans le
dialogue donc il y a 11 ans de la part
de toute une base
syndicalisée un besoin de une envie de
rupture un besoin d'une conflictualité
plus forte
mais très clairement Laurent Berger a
l'habitude de faire face à ce genre de
remontrance de la part de la gauche de
la gauche du syndicalisme je vois pas de
raison qu'il y cède il reste sur une
ligne de une ligne très claire qui a
toujours été assiette et en fait même
s'il y a des tumuls c'est une ligne qui
est payante au fil de ses dix années à
la tête de la CD de sfdt il a fait de
son syndicat le premier de France devant
la CGT et sa posture radicale donc ça
tant approuver que il fait le bon choix
alors c'est intéressant parce que ça
c'est un point que vous abordez dans
votre article paru ce week-end dans
l'édition paquet du Figaro et qui est
toujours accessible sur le site on va y
revenir pour autant aujourd'hui quel est
l'ambiance au niveau de l'intersyndicale
alors
ça donne l'impression d'être plutôt
enfin plutôt positif je pense que du
côté des réformistes on s'est fait à
l'idée que bon pour les 64 ans c'est
foutu Laurent Berger le dit lui-même
mais alors enfin il disait l'inverse au
Grand Jury hier
enfin en tout cas pour aujourd'hui il
dit aussi on demande aux gens là qui
c'est qui croient que ce soir même avec
2 millions de personnes dans la rue le
gouvernement va dire bon bah écoutez
j'ai rien dit dans les 12 premières
journées et là 1er mai vous m'avez
convaincu je retire la réforme personne
n'y croit lui-même est assez lucide sur
sur ce point là après pour ce qui est
effectivement des suites les syndicats
continuent de miser éventuellement sur
le Conseil constitutionnel qui doit
rendre un avis le 3 mai sur un
référendum d'initiative partagé il y a
il y a aussi
officiellement oui
et dans la réalité la réalité tout le
monde a conscience que les gens sont
faibles pourquoi parce que le premier a
été refusé que c'est très compliqué
d'écrire un
mur rédigé oui est-ce que est-ce que
c'est suffisant j'ai entendu dire que
une des raisons qui avait motivé aussi
le président de la République a
promulgué la loi très rapidement dans la
nuit qui a suivi la décision du Conseil
constitution du Conseil constitutionnel
viendrait du fait que certains députés
PS étaient déjà en train d'écrire un
troisième un troisième proposition de
RIP parce qu'ils étaient toujours pas
sûr de la seconde chose qu'il pouvait
faire tant de choses il faut le proposer
autant que le temps que le test n'est
pas promulgué c'est pour ça que Emmanuel
Macron leur aurait coupé l'herbe sous le
pied en le premier du gant très vite bon
ça j'ai pas l'épreuve c'est c'est des
choses qui ont été dites donc ça prouve
que même les saints les députés
eux-mêmes sont pas parfaitement sûrs de
la deuxième version quand bien même elle
est meilleure que la première donc non
il y a une grosse inquiétude sur le fait
que le deuxième soit pas soit pas validé
à ce sujet d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
Alexis Corbière a disait qu'il misait
sur une niche parlementaire celle du
groupe fameux groupe idiote le groupe
centriste non macroniste il faut suivre
j'ai pas
Charles de Courson et qui s'est fait
connaître justement sur cette motion de
censure qui
a fait quand même un peu trembler en
tous les cas beaucoup parlé et un dépôt
de loi sur
abrojean le départ à la retraite à 64
ans est-ce que là encore côté syndical
on croit à la réussite de cette
opération
en tout cas ils veulent tout faire pour
que ça en soit une ils vont essayer de
mettre tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir
pour d'autres mobilisations d'ici cette
échéance alors avoir
là on sent des habits divergent personne
n'est clair je pense que du côté des
radicaux personne ne verrait
d'inconvénient à qu'on en rajoute une
ligne 2 la CFDT elle est beaucoup plus
réticente effectivement le 1er mai avait
un peu vocation à être alors ils aiment
pas le terme il aurait pu mais un bar où
d'honneur avant
avant de se quitter bons amis cela dit
j'ai pu parler avec Cyril Chabanier de
la CFTC qui est aussi un syndicat
réformiste et qui disait que lui-même
serait pas opposé si ce n'est à une
journée de mobilisation au moins
organiser certaines choses avant le 8
juin autour de juin pour mettre la
pression sur les parlementaires c'est
donc le 8 juin effectivement merci de me
rappeler la date quel est l'objectif de
l'intercitive syndicale de cette journée
de cette manifestation il est multip il
est multiple déjà faire passer le
message au gouvernement que même si ils
abandonnent demain les mobilisations la
colère est toujours là c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est aussi une
réponse peut-être vis-à-vis enfin pas
peut-être mais une réponse vis-à-vis de
leur base leur base et donc elle-même
toujours en colère difficile pour les
syndicats de partir un peu comme ça en
disant bon bah bien joué on a fait ce
qu'on a pu on a perdu on se revoit lors
du d'une prochaine mobilisation donc il
y avait aussi un peu chercher à donner
une sortie digne incontestation
quelqu'un a été historique qui a duré
trois mois pour voilà pour essayer de
canaliser la colère et qu'elle déborde
complètement
hors de contrôle et puis un dernier
point c'est que les syndicats
ont quand même conscience d'être dans un
rapport de force ultra favorable quand
bien même ils ont perdu la question des
retraites le gouvernement depuis
plusieurs semaines n'arrête pas de
multiplier les appels du pied aux
partenaires sociaux en disant on
avancera plus sans eux on veut leur avis
sur tel et tel sujet ils savent que
c'est le moment ou jamais de
faire avancer certains de leurs dossiers
et quoi de mieux pour mettre un petit
coup de pression que de rassembler
encore plusieurs centaines de milliers
de personnes en France avant de
retourner à table les négociations on va
essayer dès que
la caméra ne fiche plus essayer de
retrouver Thibaut courtier on va
peut-être essayer de retrouver Damien
calivez parce que apparemment la tête de
cortège est arrivée place de la
République on a vu de certaines images
avenue Philippe Auguste on est tout près
de la place de la République et d'après
les images que je vois on est plus très
loin où en êtes-vous mon cher Damien
[Musique]
oui et bien effectivement nous sommes
arrivés place de la Nation et nous
sommes sur une attraction pour enfants
de façon à ce que en fait nous sommes
sur un poids et vous le voyez on voit
tous les manifestants qui arrivent sur
cette place de la Nation pour l'instant
le cortège syndical n'est pas encore
arrivé et vous voyez une célèbre banque
qui est en train d'être saccagé à
nouveau par les manifestants c'est ça
résume un peu l'ambiance que l'on a vécu
tout à l'heure en tout cas sur tout le
long de ce de ce parcours qui a relié la
place de la République à la place de la
Nation ça a été systématiquement des
boutiques qui représentent entre
guillemets le capitalisme qui ont été
saccagés à coup de à coup de pierre à
coup de de parapluie puisque vous savez
que les parapluies sont extrêmement
utilisés ici dans ces manifestations et
qui sont extrêmement pratiques pour se
protéger des vidéos surveillance ainsi
que des drones qui vous le savez
maintenant encadre cette manifestation
ils ont été autorisés par le tribunal
administratif tout à l'heure en fin de
matinée donc
[Musique]
on ferait aussi selon une partie
du capital du grand capital vous voyez
dans leur logiciel on ne peut pas
rentrer dedans donc voilà vous voyez
toujours cette cette agence bancaire qui
est en train d'être saccagé qui n'a pas
été qui n'a pas été protégé par des par
des palissades contrairement à de
nombreuses agences sur l'itinéraire ce
qui est assez étonnant d'ailleurs parce
que la préfecture de police de Paris
avait bien indiqué et avait conseillé
aux commerçant soit de fermer leur
boutique soit de les protéger avec un
dispositif de façon à ce qu'il ne se
fasse pas vandaliser voilà nous sommes
arrivés à la fin et vous voyez voilà
c'est les policiers aussi qui sont en
train d'escorter les les derniers
manifestants que l'on pourrait
considérer comme manifestants ultra et
le cortège syndical devrait arriver dans
dans quelques instants merci beaucoup
Damien pour ces pour ces précisions
précises effectivement que les
journalistes ne font que leur travail et
ne font pas ne font partie
un complot
précisément on voit effectivement encore
ces images et quelque chose quand même
d'étonnant c'est que et là quelque part
c'est saccage de commerce et saccage de
bois sont des scènes qui se répètent à
chaque
manifestation et on comprend pas trop
bien entendu alors on pourrait dire
qu'il faut que leur sécurité soit
assurée ça s'entend tout à fait et de
l'autre côté que ça soit pas protégé
enfin en tous les cas que
difficile de mettre j'imagine des
policiers tout au long en nombre
suffisant tout au long du cortège après
les
les syndicats eux-mêmes vu qu'ils sont
organisateurs de ces mobilisations ont
quand même fait le maximum depuis le
début de la contestation pour
que ça se passe le mieux possible alors
ils se sont toujours complètement
désolés d'arriver de ces groupuscules
ultra minoritaires et ultra violent qui
d'ailleurs n'ont vraiment pas grand
chose à faire de réforme des retraites
si ce n'est comme une excuse pour pour
casser des choses enfin ça serait ça ça
sera autre chose ça ça ne change rien
mais effectivement par exemple c'est
pour ça que très vite l'Inter syndicale
a arrêté de faire des mobilisations le
samedi et éventuellement les jours de
les jours fériés justement parce que ils
avaient conscience que 1 ça rassemblait
pas plus de monde que les en semaine
mais surtout que ça rameutait beaucoup
plus d'ultra que ça soit des Black Blocs
des gilets jaunes radicalisés et autres
et ils sont en weekend et parce que
effectivement ils ont du temps libre ou
en tout cas c'est le constat que la
violence augmentait souvent quand les
mobilisations avaient lieu le week-end
et c'est typiquement ce que cette
journée est en train de prouver c'est
que week-end de trois jours facilité de
déplacement pas de travail que sais-je
552 000 manifestants à 16h c'est plus
que le 13 avril 270 000 personnes et
moins que le 7 mars ou c'était 1 28
millions mais là on prévoyait de 500 à
600000 personnes attendues donc
autrement dit à 557 552000 on est plus
très loin du maximum qui était attendu
aujourd'hui quelle est la référence pour
la réussite les précédents 1er mai ou
les précédentes journées de
manifestation chacun utilise le
référentiel qu'il arrange et donc bah
pour les syndicats le référentiel c'est
le plus bas possible pour donner
l'impression d'avoir explosé par rapport
à ce qui se faisait avant donc sans
surprise les syndicats ont tendance à se
comparer par rapport aux autres 1er mai
et clairement
ils avaient annoncé un premier mai
historique en termes de participation
par rapport aux autres et c'est
effectivement ce qui va se passer ce qui
était ce qui est que moyennement une
surprise pour être honnête c'est la
première fois depuis très longtemps
alors après
ça dépend de référentiel comprendre mais
ça fait très longtemps que
l'Inter syndicale n'a pas n'a pas défilé
de façon unie un 1er mai
très intelligent
on va revenir voilà effectivement sur
les images en studio on rappelle donc
les journalistes ne font que leur
travail et ne font partie d'aucun
complot
donc voilà donc pour les syndicats
forcément ils vont considérer que c'est
un premier ministre ça reste quand même
un trait effectivement un gros problème
par rapport à la moyenne des journées de
mobilisation on va être dans quelque
chose de moyen effectivement mais faut
pas oublier que c'est la troisième une
spécificité cette année c'est en tout
cas une revendication la venue de leader
ou de représentants syndicaux d'autres
pays il y en avait à peu près une
trentaine on a vu plusieurs drapeaux
coréens anglais de différentes un peu
partout autour du monde
pour les syndicats c'était notamment un
moyen aussi alors les c'était sûrement
organise longue date mais un pied de nez
au gouvernement qui mettait souvent en
avant que cette réforme a été nécessaire
parce que dans les autres pays ça va
être déjà tous franchi le pas en partant
65 67 ans donc avoir le soutien de ces
gens-là étaient important pour le sport
donc le reste du cortège on est en train
d'en parler on vient de voir à l'instant
effectivement des gaz lacrymogènes place
de la place de la Nation à Paris où
effectivement il y a une tentative
visiblement
d'évacuation on a vu également des des
flammes au loin on va essayer de savoir
ce dont il s'agit de quoi il en retourne
on va retrouver dans un instant Tibo
Gauthier dès que dès que le la liaison
sera rétablie sur le fait que il y ait
des représentants de syndicaux étrangers
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut lier à la
tradition on a déjà vu souvent des
d'autres
représentants syndicaux et étrangers de
1er mai à Paris ou bien est-ce que c'est
aussi la volont est-ce que la
mobilisation en France et comme le
soutien
notamment Jean-Luc Mélenchon notamment
Alexis Corbière et des dirigeants de la
France insoumise manuel Bompard
la mobilisation en France fait en tout
cas référence en ce moment à l'étranger
plus une tradition c'est le hasard des
choses qui a fait effectivement que il y
a aussi ce contexte et que pour x ou y
raison c'était ça pouvait jouer son
petit effet déjà en terme de nombre et
puis en fait en termes
d'internationalisation de de la
contestation qui est des
heures de tous les pays on s'est après
que la France accueille une histoire de
la de la grève et de la manifestation
qui est ce qu'elle est qui est
complètement différente que dans
quasiment tous les pays en fait au moins
d'Europe si ce n'est du monde pour pour
genre de question donc non je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus
comment ça à y voir la quatrième ou la
cinquième internationale que sais-je
j'ai perdu le compte voilà
oui je voilà c'est ça donc non je pense
qu'il et est-ce que les syndicats vont
saisir la main tendue par le
gouvernement ou pour filer la métaphore
de lamberger ce matin ce matin sur
France Info
c'est le prix vont-ils saisir cette main
tendue alors ils vont la saisir ça au
moins les réformistes vont la saisir ça
ne fait aucun doute ils ont annoncé ils
attendent de recevoir l'invitation en
bonne et due forme ce qui n'est toujours
pas le cas le gouvernement Olivier du
subst ce matin a expliqué qu'elle
arriverait dans les prochains jours
après effectivement comme je dis tout à
l'heure ils savent qu'ils sont en
position de force cette fois-ci et bon
ben on va dire
c'est un euphémisme que les trois
derniers mois sont pas bien passés donc
très clairement entre syndicat et
gouvernement donc ils vont revenir oui
mais ils vont faire monter les enchères
parce qu'ils peuvent se le permettre
parce qu'ils doivent aussi vis-à-vis de
leur base
exigez beaucoup pour pour répondre aux
attentes aussi de des militants donc
déjà ils ont Laurent Berger a cité deux
choses importantes c'est un des
garanties en termes de méthode comment
ça va se passer qu'on soit effectivement
que le gouvernement soit vraiment à
l'écoute et pas juste là pour prendre la
photo à la fin 1 avec les syndicats en
disant regardez ils ont participé et
deux
Laurent Berger veut savoir quels sont
les marges de manœuvres possibles du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que s'il y a
moyen de négocier mais sur trois petits
détails et qu'en fait 99% de la réforme
est déjà écrite et ne peut pas bouger
Laurent Berget a déjà dit que ça
l'intéressait pas voilà donc c'est
vraiment les deux conditions principales
et
les raisons principales partage de la
valeur assurance chômage emploi des
seniors il y a des terrains d'entente
sur ces questions là
il y a oui il y a des terrains d'entente
avec le gouvernement toute façon il y a
aussi je pense que le gouvernement n'est
pas forcément très motivé à l'idée de
repartir sur un conflit social avec les
syndicats tout de suite
reste à savoir effectivement ce qui ce
qui va se passer mais pour un certain
nombre déjà il va s'agir de reprendre
soit des négociations qui ont déjà eu
entre patronat et syndicat c'est ce cas
sur le partage de la valeur soit de
reprendre des choses que le gouvernement
sur lequel le gouvernement avait donné
son accord et qui ont été toqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel et ça c'est
c'est tous les cavaliers et les fameux
cavaliers législatifs qui ont été toqués
par par le Conseil constitut on rappelle
parce que vous êtes quelqu'un de très
affûté mais rappelle peut-être ce qui
est un cavalier pardon c'est c'est
constitutionnel c'est tout plein de
mesures qui
en fait faut savoir que la réforme des
retraites était une loi budgétaire c'est
voilà et donc on ne peut pas mettre
n'importe quoi dans une loi dans une loi
budgétaire un certain nombre de formes
qui ont pas forcément commentaires
respectées exactement
c'est ce qu'on appelle des cavaliers des
choses qui n'avaient rien à y faire et
qui ont été notamment tout ce qui a
trait à l'emploi des seniors voilà ça a
été exactement donc ça effectivement
c'est un terrain d'entente ça peut être
un terrain d'entendre ça entre le
syndical gouvernement de retrouver un
dispositif sur l'emploi des seigneurs
déjà il y a ceux qui ont été retoqué
avec le patron on a peut-être non pas
forcément d'ailleurs c'est un des choses
étonnantes une des effets secondaires
inattendus c'est que l'opposition entre
syndicats et gouvernement a rapproché
syndicat et patronat puisque il y avait
c'est notamment ce qui a permis de
déboucher sur l'accord sur le partage de
la valeur qu'un accord entre syndicat et
patronat
non non le partage de la valeur
qu'est-ce que apporter cet accord alors
en fait c'était en gros en résumé c'est
faire en sorte que les entreprises
multiplient toutes les dispositifs qui
existent déjà que sont l'intéressement
et autre chose comme ça pour faire
bénéficier à tous les salariés
ben la bonne que tous les salariés
profitent de la bonne santé de
l'entreprise
ça existe déjà beaucoup dans les grands
groupes mais c'est vrai que c'était
assez peu présent dans les TPE et ben
exactement donc en fait c'est un peu
essayer de contraindre toutes les
entreprises à déjà en faire et les
grands groupes à en faire plus il y a un
autre enjeu un autre terrain de bataille
ce sont les décrets d'application
effectivement
ça aussi enfin le décret d'application
et la mise en place de la loi qui doit
entrer en vigueur progressivement à
partir du 1er septembre et c'est une
date qui semble trop courte pour les
syndicats depuis le début
effectivement vous voyez que c'est quand
même assez agité place de la Nation
actuellement c'est notre caméra qui
bouge et donc j'espère que rien de grave
arrive à notre équipe apparemment ça se
re stabilise en tous les cas vous le
voyez l'ambiance est tendue à l'arrivée
du cortège on va y revenir dans un tout
petit instant une dernière question deux
dernières questions Thomas promis de la
première pourquoi la CGT la CGC la
CFE-CGC François Hollande estime que la
réforme est inapplicable que le délai du
1er septembre pour faire entrer la
nouvelle loi sur la réforme des
retraites en vigueur et impossible je ne
cite parce qu'en fait la réforme des
retraites qui vient de passer et
beaucoup plus qu'un simple
molécules de l'âge légal de départ de 62
à 64 ans si ça consistait que en ça si
je puis dire bon ben vous mettez des
délais tout les six mois et vous dites
bon bah partez trois mois plus tard à
chaque fois mais en fait cette loi
consiste dans il y a tout un tas de
dispositifs à l'intérieur on a parlé
notamment des 1200 ans
les 64 ans mais les 1200 euros voilà non
et tout un tas de dispositifs comme ça
qui va d'ailleurs était pas très clair
quand ils étaient expliqués combien ça
personne était concernée voilà tout ça
et donc qui va demander à énormément de
travail
de la part de la CNAV et des organismes
en fait qui gèrent les retraites
exactement
pour savoir qui doit toucher quoi par
rapport aux nouvelles
[Musique]
enfin en tout cas ce que présente
prétend la CGC c'est patenables d'ici le
premier enfin c'est pas que la CFE-CGC
c'est
tous disent qu'effectivement les timings
sont beaucoup trop courts voilà que ça
va pas être possible et Olivier du socle
à retoqué que des ans il s'était préparé
des embauches avaient déjà eu lieu et
que les l'agenda serait tenu autre point
très intéressant vous êtes soulevé c'est
le retour des vieux clivages au sein de
l'interphone
oui oui alors ça effectivement disons
que ils avaient réussi à s'unir dans le
désaccord c'est ça qui avait permis
l'Union parce qu'en fait ils étaient
tous contre les 64 ans mais il l'assume
mais il le disent personne n'est
d'accord sur l'alternative c'est-à-dire
pour la CGT c'est 62 ans voire même 60
ans retour pour la CFDT c'est le retour
à la réforme de 2019 qui était la mise
en place la fameuse retraite à points
qui tend vers ce qu'on a appelé un peu
le système universel mais en tout cas
l'évolution donc ils sont pas du tout
d'achats sur l'alternative en revanche
qui a permis une union
c'est tous unique contre les 64 ans
maintenant
cette discussion des 64 ans cette
séquence de 64 ans se referme un peu
même si il y a effectivement plusieurs
échanges vient de nouveau de nouveaux
sujets avec de nouveaux débats nouvelles
discussions et très clairement
les dissensions entre les différents
syndicats redevenir plus visible
merci beaucoup Thomas pour toutes ces
précisions je précise qu'on retrouve
tous vos papiers dans le Figaro
économique et bien sûr peut-être la
recension un papier au sujet de cette
manifestation du 1er mai à venir oui oui
tout à fait dans l'édition de demain et
c'est à dire bien sûr dans les
prochaines heures sur le site du Figaro
dans la verticale économie merci
beaucoup
Thibault on va merci beaucoup Thomas
pardon je vois Thibault effectivement on
va le retrouver Thibault comment ça se
passe là où vous trouvez on a vu que la
tête de cortège est arrivée place de la
Nation est-ce que vous en êtes encore
loin ou est-ce que vous en approchez
nous sommes à équidistance de la place
de la République et de la place de la
Nation place Léon Blum oui c'est c'est
un symbole évidemment
assez étonnant et il a une ambiance si
j'ose dire Vincent 1er mai c'est-à-dire
que il y a du soleil il y a du muguet il
y a des familles ça c'est très important
on les voyait beaucoup lors des des
premières journées de manifestation
contre la réforme des retraites un peu
moins les dernières fois là il y a
beaucoup de familles qui viennent avec
des enfants qui ont un bras de muguet
qui ont des pancartes dans la main on a
vu plusieurs d'assez drôle d'ailleurs et
on se disait que après cette formulation
cette utilisation des 100 jours
Emmanuel Macron avait peut-être pas fait
le bon choix sémantique et bien beaucoup
de beaucoup de banderoles et de
pancartes à ce sujet 100 jours
rendez-vous à Sainte-Hélène oui
évidemment en référence à Napoléon on
voit beaucoup de monde avec une très
bonne ambiance à l'arrière du covoitage
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
on passe finalement sur les les
décombres et les vestiges du du passage
des des Black Blocs que vous nous
décrivez que nous ne voyons pas du tout
nous un peu plus loin dans dans cette
dans cette manifestation ce que je peux
vous dire alors toujours difficile
d'établir un nombre de personnes qui
peuvent cette manifestation ça c'est
toujours très compliqué en tout cas
c'est très dense parfois des
manifestations qui s'étale qui
s'étendent avec beaucoup de monde entre
les lendemains tout à l'heure avec avec
François Carpentier on s'est retrouvé au
milieu de cette foule à quasiment ne
plus pouvoir avancer avec cette immense
camion de la CFDT bloqué pendant de
nombreuses minutes lors du lors du
passage devant la
[Musique]
de Dieu ou se sont retrouvés les
insoumis donc voilà ambiance plutôt
bonne ambiance ici à au milieu du
cortège et je ne sais pas comment mieux
vous le décrire en ambiance très 1er mai
avec notamment le retour du soleil après
la très grosse averse de 14h qui a
laissé présager à l'après-midi difficile
pour les manifestants merci beaucoup
Thibault et je vous aiderai de ne pas
avoir employé l'expression ambiance bon
enfant même si je pense qu'elle vous
venez à l'esprit merci beaucoup autre
salle autre ambiance si j'ose dire c'est
en tête de cortège place de la Nation on
retrouve Damien Canivet apparemment les
choses j'allais dire les choses se sont
calmées non apparemment il y a encore
des jeux de gaz lacrymogène là où vous
vous trouvez
un petit peu tout ça je porte
actuellement mon masque FP3 pour être
très précis de façon de protéger et
pouvoir vous vous délivrer c'est
commentaires nous sommes place de la
Nation en effet le point de chute de
cette manifestation qui a démarré tout à
l'heure à 14h place de la République et
vous pouvez le constater effectivement
la tension est toujours de mise ici
c'est assez tendu en permanence ça se
tend ça se détend on a le sentiment ici
qu'il y a aussi une nouvelle doctrine en
termes de maintien de l'ordre peut-être
est-ce lié à ses drones qui qui sont en
train de de surveiller cette
manifestation parce que dès lors que des
manifestants
ultra violents tout de noir vêtus se
rassemblent les policiers font une
charge pour les pour les pour les
dispersés donc on peut vraiment dire ici
que malgré tout le le l'ambiance est
tenue par l'ordre est tenu pardon par un
les gendarmes et les policiers présents
on rappelle qu'ils sont au nombre de
5000 ici dans ce cortège parisien alors
que là derrière nous actuellement ce ce
déroulant encore des affrontements avec
les forces de l'ordre on voit des à
partir de mortier d'artifice avec des
Black Blocs ici c'est vraiment une un
théâtre de guérilla urbaine sur cette
place de la Nation il y a des poubelles
en feu et des policiers qui sont prises
à partir on a vu des des jeux de pierre
qui sont arrivés sur les casques des des
policiers alors certes sont-ils équipés
de façon assez importante mais on
imagine en tout cas le choc que ça
représente surtout quand certains sont
évacués par leurs camarades ici vous
voyez que l'ambiance est très compliqué
d'autant que je vous le disais tout à
l'heure tout au long de ce parcours les
policiers n'ont eu de scènes ce que de
faire des charges en direction des
manifestants ultra-violents pour les
disperser sur ce boulevard Voltaire mais
force est de reconnaître qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément réussi à les disperser au
niveau de la place de la Nation
puisqu'ils arrivent tous à cet endroit
là il y a un deuxième groupe de
militants ultra violent qui vient
d'arriver ici sur cette place de la
Nation les volets ils sont
reconnaissables puisqu'ils sont tous
cagoulés et tous vêtus de noir ils ont
également des parapluies pour se
protéger des des caméras de vidéos
surveillance et des drones dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est toujours
pratique pour eux de se vêtir et de se
dévêtir en dessous pour paraître
incognito et là on sent que ça va
vraiment vraiment dégénérer ici sur
cette place de la Nation parce que
contrairement à tout à l'heure où
c'était déjà violent et bien les
manifestants ici sont parvenus à ce
regrouper alors on voit de tout c'est à
dire qu'on voit effectivement deux
semaines manifestants mais il n'y a pas
que ça il y a également des personnes
âgées d'une cinquantaine d'années
peut-être voir plus on a aussi des des
gilets jaunes radicalisés que vos
interlocuteurs policiers ont qualifié
d'ultra jaune ils sont là également en
tout cas ici il y a une convergence des
luttes un type police on n'a pas
vraiment le sentiment qu'on se trouve
ici dans un mouvement contre la réforme
des retraites on est plutôt dans un
mouvement contre la 5e République contre
un système en place et on a vraiment
l'impression que cette manifestation ici
ne fait que de commencer place de la
Nation
merci beaucoup
Damien on va justement y revenir avec
Pierre Le Pelletier mais je vous
présenter
au service politique du Figaro on voit
que pas mal de tension là effectivement
en tête de cortège
moi j'allais vous poser une autre
question c'est quel est l'ambiance
aujourd'hui à gauche
je pense que la gauche craignait un peu
en fait ces images déjà ce soir et
d'ailleurs c'est que la fin d'après là
on est en milieu d'après-midi fin
d'après-midi donc on va voir comment ça
se poursuit mais de à gauche tout le
monde a 5 quêtes de ces violences en
disant finalement s'il y a des violences
d'une telle ampleur ça risque de voilà
de mettre un dernier coup de canif à
cette à la mobilisation il y a une vraie
crainte à gauche que ça soit finalement
la dernière manifestation
que ce soit le baroud d'honneur c'est
beaucoup moi je les ai vu tout à l'heure
et c'est vrai que c'était stable qui
répètait il faut il disait attention
c'est pas le bar au d'honneur c'est pas
le bouquet final en tout cas on va tout
faire pour éviter ça
donc effectivement il la perspective du
14 juillet mais il y a quand même
l'inquiétude de se dire comment machin
c'est le 14 juillet pour la gauche c'est
pas le 8 juin au niveau au moment de la
du dépôt de la loi de la niche l'iotte
puisque c'est Alexis Corbière qui me
disait tout à l'heure
c'est pas d'autres écoles même le 3 mai
il y en a plusieurs il y a effectivement
la date du 3 mai du 3 mai pardon avec le
RIB qui sera approuvé ou non par le
Conseil constitutionnel donc si ça a
prouvé effectivement on retourne dans
une séquence où finalement on est dans
une campagne pour collecter les
signatures et donc ça redonnera
forcément un engouement et un
enthousiasme à la lutte soit ce sera le
8 juin avec la proposition de loi du
groupe centriste liotte pour essayer
d'abroger cette réforme des retraites
donc là c'est plus sur le volet
parlementaire et il y a enfin le 14
juillet parce que c'est Emmanuel Macron
qui a fixé ça le cap des 100 jours et en
fait pour la gauche notamment la gauche
pour le radical de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est le bon moment pour enfin c'est une
date pour eux qui est culturellement
ancrée dans leur famille poétique la
prise de la Bastille enfin voilà c'est
fondateur pour eux donc ils sont saisis
ça c'est bon pour le narratif de la
France insoumise justement est-ce que le
succès rencontré par l'intercidical
puisque tout à l'heure
alors que effectivement on voit toute la
place de la Nation c'est extrêmement
tendu vraiment ces bruits et fureur
comme ambiance c'est rare de voir ces
images avec autant de autant de tension
c'est ce qui nous parvient en tous les
cas de filmer par nos envahisseurs là en
l'occurrence ça c'est plutôt par les
agences qui sont qui sont sur place il y
avait déjà eu un rassemblement place de
la Nation au mois de
au mois de février c'était beaucoup plus
calme là effectivement c'était
extrêmement tendu on a déjà vu des des
images de tension à des 1ers place de la
Nation mais
c'est pas tout le temps que on voit des
images de tension aussi forte donc là
actuellement
juste au dessus là de
notre image place de la Nation à Paris
d'ailleurs au total 40 il y a une
trentaine d'interpellations d'ailleurs
dans l'après-midi à Paris
vous disiez tout à l'heure oui vous
étiez sur place effectivement il était
encore tôt parce que ça devait être sur
les coups de 15 heures et on commençait
déjà entendre des gros pétards et voilà
des films hygiène etc enfin on sentait
que ça se tendait et les gens qui
sortaient du métro commencent à se dire
oh là là est-ce qu'on va y aller est-ce
que est-ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup
d'y aller donc ça montre que voilà en
fait toute cette violence mais un peu
encore une fois un coup de canif dans
cette mobilisation et donc il faut voir
comment la journée se termine et quel
impact sera sur la suite alors
précisément je revenais à ce que on se
disait tout à l'heure
est-ce que disait tout à l'heure
Thibault Gauthier qui était dans le
cortège mais avec les politiques et les
leaders syndicaux on se passe à côté on
ne se croise pas on ne se sert pas la
main c'est ce que me disait Thibault en
d'à côté les leaders syndicaux et de
l'autre les responsables de la nups
est-ce que le succès rencontré par
l'intersydical ne commence pas inquiéter
côté du Pesse en particulier je suis
Jean-Luc Mélenchon bah disons que c'est
la Jean-Luc Mélenchon et les insoumis
auraient adoré que ce soit eux qui sont
en première ligne de du mouvement social
enfin politiquement ça aurait été très
important pour eux pour la suite et en
fait ils se sont vite rendu compte que
les syndicats qui pensaient mort en tout
cas à bout de souffle
ont une entre guillemets une nouvelle
jeunesse dans la rue avec voilà des des
cortèges monstres qu'ils avaient réussi
à constituer est-ce que les insoumis et
les autres forces de gauche sont
incapables de faire donc il y ait eu une
erreur d'analyse dès le début ils se
sont trompés et ils le reconnaissent
aujourd'hui et donc
aujourd'hui le l'enjeu est de surtout
pas faire de la division dans ce
mouvement qui quand même on voit que la
mobilisation s'essouffle parfois de
surtout pas faire de la division et donc
de jouer voilà les seconds rôles et
surtout les syndicats comme le dit
Thibault ne veulent surtout pas que les
politiques
s'emmêlent sans mêlent trop et donc
c'est pour ça ça crée une ambiance un
peu particulière ou finalement les
syndicats sont regroupés devant le
cortège etc les et les politiques enfin
les politiques de gauche font un peu ça
à leur manière on dirait un peu les
villes un petit canard où ils sont dans
leur coin à faire leur discours etc mais
finalement il y a pas grand monde
puisque le cortège un peu plus loin donc
c'est assez étonnant effectivement on
est le très loin du front populaire sur
la violence ou encore l'un des fumées
noires qui montent place de la Nation
on sent que on a du mal à condamner oui
c'est sûr c'est toujours le même
problème puisque en fait le narratif
c'est de dire les Français sont à bout
et donc on peut on entend certaines
violences même si on ne la enfin on la
condamne mais on l'entend on peut
comprendre que certains cultures de
l'excuse
très gauche il y a une culture de
l'excuse tout simplement parce que il y
a une grande partie de l'électorat aussi
qui voilà qui vote un soumis qui vote
Mélenchon et qui peut voilà en tout cas
il condamne mais toujours en disant mais
voilà la violence aussi vient du vient
du haut de l'état du sommet de l'État de
d'Emmanuel Macron de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron enfin c'est le
narratif c'est le narratif il y a disait
Thomas en grand des risques de fissures
côté Intercel est-ce qu'il y en a côté
gauche de la gauche on la voit déjà un
petit peu puisque tout à l'heure encore
une fois il y avait un point presse
comme ils font généralement des
différents responsables de gauche et
dire à différents responsables de la
nupaisse et il en manque forcément sur
le même c'est Fabien Roussel et le Parti
communiste ou en fait eux font leur ils
font ça dans leur coin donc forcément ça
fait un peu tâche surtout que le Parti
communiste est quand même un parti
ouvrier qui a longtemps été en première
ligne de ces manifestations de ces
mobilisations populaires
du coup entre les quatre de la nupette
il en manque un donc ce qui n'est pas
complètement négligeable justement on va
retrouver Thibault Gauthier qui lui
était du côté de la gauche justement
aujourd'hui et quel était l'ambiance
Thibault côté politique quand vous les
vous les avez rencontrés est-ce que on
sentait un peu ces fissures dont parle à
l'instant pierre
ambiance du côté des politiques alors on
veut toujours montrer
qu'il y a une cohésion que oui on espère
et on a toujours envie de manifester
contre cette réforme des retraites on
espère qu'elle puisse tomber alors c'est
vrai que on les interrogeant les
différentes personnalités politiques on
a du mal à bien saisir comment ils
veulent s'y prendre alors si il y a deux
points qui qui veulent mettre en avant
très précisément d'abord le référendum
d'initiative partagée ils espèrent
toujours que le Conseil constitutionnel
valide ce rythme mais alors ce serait
encore long derrière ils le savent les
politiques présentes dans la
manifestation ils savent très bien que
même si le Conseil constitutionnel
venait à valider un RIP il faudrait
ensuite 10% du corps électoral ce n'est
pas gagné c'est possible pour une fois
étant donné le nombre de Français qui
sont
contre la réforme des retraites ça c'est
ce que nous disent les sondages mais
après il y a encore différentes de
technicité qui pourrait compliquer un
vote et un référendum d'initiative
partagée un autre point intéressant
c'est cette niche parlementaire la niche
parlementaire et bien c'est une journée
pour un groupe en l'occurrence le groupe
le groupe indépendant qui avait réussi
lui à fédérer autour de lui parce que on
le sait à l'Assemblée nationale la
gauche la nuit passe ne veut pas voter
les motion par exemple déposées par par
le rassemblement national
ne voulait pas voter avec la gauche
c'était très compliqué en revanche le
tour du groupe Liot il y a un consensus
et donc ce groupe va utiliser sa niche
parlementaire cette journée et donc
proposer l'abrogation de cette réforme
des retraites comme il n'y a pas eu de
vote à l'Assemblée nationale on s'en
souvient Emmanuel Macron Elizabeth
n'avait préféré utiliser le 49-3 pour ne
pas prendre de risques et bien ils
espèrent à gauche à droite je les
républicains ceux qui ne veulent pas de
cette réforme au rassemblement national
et dans ce groupe pendant l'iode ils
espèrent réunir assez de voies à ce
moment-là pour faire tomber cette
réforme des retraites là aussi c'est
encore très technique ce n'est pas gagné
mais c'est une possibilité voilà les
points sur lesquels s'appuie les
personnalités politiques pour continuer
à bien fédérer autour de continuer à
croire à faire croire peut-être à
certaines personnes qui descendent ici
dans la rue que cette réforme des
retraites peut encore tomber merci
beaucoup Thibault pour ces précisions
on va revenir justement
sur sur cette sur ces narratif pierre
avec vous à propos de narratif il y a un
arrêt on est moins littéraire mais on
est plus mathématiques sont les chiffres
550 000 manifestants à Paris selon la
CGT donc effectivement chiffre qui sera
évidemment contestée on peut dire
objectivement contestable ce qui est
intéressant c'est la tendance 400 000
manifestants qui étaient revendiquées
par la centrale
le 13 avril dernier au même moment donc
on voit quand même en tous les cas c'est
ce qui est c'est ce qui est prétendu et
on le voit également notamment avec les
chiffres et les dépôts qui sont faits
par le fil data sur la base des chiffres
qui sont donnés par les différentes
préfectures qui y a une tendance quand
même plutôt haussière par rapport à la
mobilisation du 13 avril dernier vous le
disiez tout à l'heure le Parti
communiste fait un peu bande à part en
ce moment
le parti monte en puissance en ce moment
en tout cas
c'est ce qui semble c'est ce qui ressent
un peu les camarades de la nipplex bah
disons que surtout Fabien Roussel donc
il se prépare nationale du PCF qui est
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle
voit très bien qu'il y a quelque chose
autour de lui il le voit dans les
enquêtes d'opinion ou c'est la
personnalité de gauche préférée des
Français parce qu'il parle en fait assez
large c'est pas quelqu'un de se taire
tous les débats mais sur la table par la
peu à tout le monde voilà il est plus
dans le social aussi que dans le
sociétal donc ça parle plus voilà après
côté de la nupesse il y a forcément de
l'agacement parce qu'on l'accuse de
jouer sa carte perso et de ne pas jouer
le collectif or dans une formation
coalition qui à peine un an
il faut un collectif assez soudé
notamment à l'approche enfin notamment
dans ces dans ce genre de mobilisation
mais aussi à l'approche d'autres
échéances je pense par exemple aux
européennes
sa ligne moins sociétale un peu plus
sociale voire un peu plus national
est-ce qu'elle peut s'imposer à gauche
c'est difficile aussi le vrai problème
de Fabien Roussel c'est que c'est son
parti finalement parti communiste
français est-ce que 51% des Français
accepteraient de voter pour ce parti
pour un parti communiste c'est compliqué
après voilà il est effectivement plus
populaire
il est plus populaire chez les français
ce qui les plus populaire dans les
électorat de gauche c'est aussi ça
principal mission c'est le principe
c'est
on sent que cette ligne un peu plus
sociale voit un peu plus nationale ça
doit être toutes les intellectuels dans
tous les cas tout ce qui produisent des
idées et qui sont dans la production de
logiciels d'idées à gauche la récuse on
voit que c'est pas la ligne dominante
actuellement soit chez les écologistes
soit chez à la France insoumise
c'est un débarrassage qui doit qui doit
quand même franchir
ils assument ça c'est une stratégie
qu'ils assume au PC Fabien Rousset c'est
de dire ils veulent parler aussi à
l'électorat du rassemblement national
aux abstentionnistes et donc forcément
ils doivent sortir du périmètre de la
gauche traditionnelle Thibaut Gautier
vous étiez avec tout à l'heure avec
Fabien Roussel on n'a pas pu la voir on
a eu lors de précédentes manifestations
mais vous avez les paraît-il une
anecdote à nous raconter
on a eu Fabien Roussel tout à l'heure
alors il devait partir mais au moment où
on lui parlait pour lui demander si on
pouvait l'interroger plusieurs personnes
sont arrivées et ont crié Fabien Roussel
n'est pas un camarade Fabien Roussel
n'est pas un camarade et c'est pas c'est
pas rien c'est assez assez intéressant
de voir que dans les gens qui sont dans
cette manifestation et bien tous ne
considère pas que Fabien Roussel fait
partie intégrante de cette nuit pèse de
la gauche et c'est une gauche qui peut
peut-être déranger dans ce cortège et au
sein des manifestants ici
alors la question Thibault c'est
question subsidiaire est-ce qu'on sait
pourquoi ces manifestants disaient que
Fabien Roussel n'était pas je les cite
un camarade
alors nous on est avec Fabien Roussel
non c'est pas approché d'eux c'est lui
qui semblait en sourire qui leur faisait
un signe presque un peu provocateur en
leur disant oui bon je vous entends je
ne vois pas pourquoi il avait l'air de
pas vraiment comprendre on le sait
Fabien Roussel il est pas forcément
apprécié il a eu des propos dernièrement
sur l'immigration par exemple et ça et
bien les gens qui sont ici sont des gens
souvent politisés qui s'intéressent à la
politique et qui écoutent Fabien Roussel
ça ça ne leur plaît pas
effectivement c'est ça qui est
intéressant merci beaucoup Thibault pour
pour ces précisions vous me revenez vers
nous pour la prochaine anecdote il y a
mais je trouve qu'elle est très
intéressante sur ce qu'on on se disait
ça illustré tout à fait ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure
justement sur le sur le sur
l'immigration sur le National
précisément il ira jusqu'où Fabien
Roussel bah c'est toute la question
après Fabien Roussel là sur
l'immigration il a un peu revenu en
arrière en disant qu'il parlait des
frontières et qu'il fallait respecter
les frontières surtout pour les accords
commerciaux mais
marchandise voilà ce qu'il avait
critiqué les les frontières qui
deviennent des passoires on n'oublie pas
que Fabien Roussel est un élu du Nord ou
quand même le rassemblement national est
puissant et que la question de
l'immigration et précisément des
frontières passoires notamment avec ce
qui se passe dans le département voisin
du Pas-de-Calais est un vrai sujet et
finalement ils sont quelques-uns
François Ruffin commence aussi à le
faire à parler d'immigration parce que
ils veulent se saisir de ce sujet à
gauche alors c'est très compliqué c'est
des sujets inflammable et d'ailleurs je
pense que s'il est aussi mal reçu Fabien
Roussel ça peut être lié assez propos
qu'il avait tenu mais ils sont
quelques-uns quand même à gauche à dire
on veut s'en occuper on veut s'en saisir
en tout cas il y a une étude de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès je sais que vous
l'avez reçu qui qui témoigne et que vous
avez reçu Adélaïde qui est venu
justement qui disait que le problème à
gauche c'est que l'immigration était un
tabou à gauche bien sûr on peut
retrouver cet extrait sur le portail de
cette interview sur le portail de de
Figaro live et que effectivement il y a
un impensé mais en plus on a
l'impression c'est ça qui est assez
curieux c'est une spécificité une
spécificité française puisque on voit
bien bon il y a toute une étude là qui
est faite par une autre étude la fond
d'Apple dans le nord de l'Europe où on
voit bien que il y a une partie des des
partis populistes en immigration qui
puisait leur réservoir et de voir dans
les parties de gauche on voit bien que
notamment en Allemagne ou le syndicat
aigu métal était dans des propositions
qui étaient proches de la préférence
nationale on voit bien on a bien vu
également en Grande-Bretagne qu'une
partie des des
électoratravailliste était et travailler
avec et son immigration il y a il y a
qu'en France que que que la gauche
charqueboute sur cette internationalisme
c'est pour ça que certains voilà
essaient de faire un peu bouger les
lignes et certains des pleurs en disant
finalement le rassemblement national
parle sur la à des discours de gauche
que nous on n'a pas et notamment sur la
question de l'immigration donc voilà
mais ça fait effectivement c'est un
tabou presque un impensé il y a un peu
tout a bâtir et certains s'y risques un
petit peu comme Ruffin aux Roussel mais
on en est vraiment au début après voilà
certains il y en a qui voilà de la
gauche radicale qui se disent nos
borders ça veut dire les frontières
finalement on s'en fiche et c'est
l'humain d'abord et d'autres non par
certains les idiots utiles du
capitalisme oui mais
vol pas eu nous dit alors juste une
question ce qui est vrai c'est que pour
l'instant les seuls à gauche qui avait
critiqué l'immigration c'était au début
des années 80 c'était le Parti
communiste c'était Georges Marchais et
Robert rue et donc finalement on en
revient un peu alors c'est que dans des
styles complètement différents et mais
il y a quand même une petite filiation
entre Fabien Roussel avec toute cette
époque là et on revient un peu vers ça
vol pas eu internet du Figaro fidèle que
salut alors dès qu'on parle de Roussel
ça fait tout de suite réagir donc il
nous dit le PC n'a plus rien à voir le
PC d'aujourd'hui n'a plus rien à voir
avec le PC d'avant alors ce qui est on
le dit moins marxiste et d'ailleurs sur
l'idéologie
plus maçonnique plus proche
avec avec les réseaux formation
maçonniques qui ont gardé qui eux-mêmes
sont travaillés paraît-il par par ces
débats entre l'internationalisme et puis
pas dire le
nationalisme en tout cas le
républicanisme non mais voilà c'est un
parti qui se cherche un petit peu on va
pas se mentir à l'époque il y a encore
40-50 ans en France il y avait l'Église
catholique et le PCF bon bah voilà on
voit ce que le Parti communiste est
devenu parfois il est même pas candidat
des élections quand il est il fait
vraiment des petits scores donc on voit
bien qu'il y a une tentative de Fabien
Roussel d'essayer de trouver un créneau
à gauche qui peut permettre de parler au
plus grand nombre et parfois et c'est
pour ça qu'il se singularisent un peu de
la nupette alors tout à l'heure on
attendait éventuellement la possibilité
d'une interview avec Fabien Roussel et
c'était la question que j'avais suggéré
à Thibault Gauthier puisque on voyait
qu'il y avait le stand de de l'humain
qui était juste à créer celui du PC or
mise en Figaro je vois qu'il y a entre
le entre le parti et la rédaction de
l'humain oui c'est de voilà c'est tout
ce que ce qui traverse un peu les débats
qui traversent la gauche radicale et qui
qui sont assez bien résumés parce que la
confrontation parfum moi je sais pas si
on parle de confrontation mais entre le
Parti communiste et l'Huma c'est des
lignes qui se qui s'entrechoquent et ça
crée du débat à gauche voilà on sait que
Fabien Roussel un peu du mal de Lima on
voit parce que les lignes de l'humain
ressemble quand même très souvent au une
de l'idée c'est une ligne plus plus
sociétale plus plus immigrationniste
effectivement c'est plus compliqué de
parler de frontières et c'est pour ça
que Fabien Roussel fait du bruit et
c'est pour ça qu'il est très critiqué
après on verra si électoralement puisque
finalement c'est ça le plus important si
électoralement ça paye ou non ça ne lui
a pas justement profité alors
précisément est-ce que c'est pas dû à un
autre phénomène c'est que il y a un
autre enjeu aujourd'hui c'est LE HAVRE
la ville dirigée par Edouard Philippe
avec les syndicats et et le RN
de part et d'autre comment on réagit que
tes nuits au gains engrangé par le RN
dans cette séquence on y revient
d'ailleurs dans un instant avec
Véronique Chris Hoult je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de frustrations il y a aussi
beaucoup de regrets des regrets dans le
sens où est-ce que la nups a eu la bonne
attitude pendant les débats
parlementaires ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux alors souvent sous couvert
d'anonymat mais ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à regretter en disant bah voilà
les Français ont finalement retenu qu'on
avait un peu bordélisé l'assemblée même
si et le travail qu'on a fait sur le
fond notamment les socialistes en fait
et balayé par toutes les polémiques et
les coûts d'éclats des insoumis donc il
y a beaucoup de regrets ça fait beaucoup
de débats en interne et voilà il
regrette de voir le rassemblement
national qui a été beaucoup plus discret
pendant cette séquence en sortir comme
le grand gagnant ils craignent que il
soit vraiment le les coiffures poteau
dans cette dans cette séquence
et quel gâchis parce que pour eux parce
que finalement c'est la retraite à 64
ans même avec toute la question des
retraites c'est quand même dans le champ
de la gauche généralement et de voir que
c'est encore le rassemblement national
qui va tirer les marins du feu alors
peut-être un commentaire on va retrouver
Thibault Gauthier alors qu'on voit que
il a encore beaucoup de tension avec des
évacuations
au canon à haut c'est assez rare
d'ailleurs de voir ces scènes là on les
on les voit dans beaucoup de pays mais
rarement en France ça se passe vous
voyez place aux alentours de la place de
la Nation dès qu'on peut on va retrouver
Damien Damien Canivet effectivement
tension là vous le voyez en cours place
de la Nation les manifestants reflux
Thibault Gautier vous aviez une réaction
par rapport à ce qu'on se disait avec
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure Alexis
Corbière
oui je lui ai demandé est-ce que ils
disent lui Alexis Corbière et Olivier
forge interviewé également ils disent
nous sommes dans une crise démocratique
Emmanuel Macron est dans une crise
politique j'en ai mais quel est votre
part de responsabilité dans tout ça en
refusant par exemple de voter ce fameux
article 7 qui aurait permis de trancher
cette question à l'Assemblée nationale
sur l'âge de départ à 64 ans mais disent
non nous regardez personne n'est allé
manifester dans la rue en disant
regardez la France insoumise et
laupestre bloque le pays alors que non
il y a des dizaines de milliers voire
des 1 million un million et une personne
qui sont descendus dans la rue pour
protester contre Emmanuel Macron ils ont
l'impression d'avoir tenu leur rôle et
je leur demandais également mais alors
les syndicats vous ont tenté sur cette
question et dit non non nous on a tenu
notre rôle on avait la possibilité de
bloquer l'Assemblée nationale on n'a pas
de regret non nous ne sommes pas dans
une crise politique et non nous ne
sommes pas responsables de cette crise
démocratique c'est bien la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron voilà ce qu'il réponde
et ce qu'il répète
effectivement il y a pas des
manifestations contre les souplesse
aujourd'hui mais en attendant c'est vrai
que l'alternative naturelle qui semble
se dégager dans les sondages c'est plus
le rassemblement national que que la
nuit pèse et donc il faut quand même des
remises en question alors voilà il a il
le disent Pascal caméra etc mais c'est
vrai que quand on en discute un peu plus
disons hors antenne hors micro bon ils
sont ils reconnaissent que c'était pas
forcément la meilleure stratégie merci
beaucoup merci d'être passé par les
ciseaux du Figaro ben on va suivre le
compte rendu de cette journée de
manifestation côté politique côté gauche
puisque vous en êtes le spécialiste avec
Sophie dravinel et on retrouve bien sûr
tous les articles sur la dans la
verticale politique du Figaro et bien
sûr dans l'édition papier du Figaro daté
de ce mardi 2 mai merci beaucoup pierre
on va retrouver d'abord voir un petit
peu quel est l'ambiance place de la
Nation où on a vu
des canons à eau et il continue d'être
effectivement vous le voyez être
actionné tout autour de la place de la
Nation
on va retrouver Damien Canier qui se
retrouve qui se trouve pas très loin à
je vois que l'image fige encore un peu
non ça s'affiche moi Damien est-ce que
vous avez subi pareil des jets d'eau
comment ça se passe autour de vous
oui absolument Vincent je me trouve
toujours place de la Nation amortier
d'artifice d'éclater à proximité
alors on va revenir
s'affiche un peu on a senti que
effectivement ça se tendait place de la
Nation et c'est ce que montre également
les images qui nous parviennent vous les
voyez en haut à gauche les voilà en
plein pot grâce à la magie de Riad
beckhia là c'est plus les images que
vous avez en plein pot voilà vous les
avez en plein pot et on a le plaisir de
recevoir Véronique reissoult en ce
moment et dès que on pourra on
retrouvera
Damien canviez également Thibault
Gautier bonjour cher Véronique
quel est l'ambiance sur les réseaux
aujourd'hui animé il y a beaucoup de
monde sur les réseaux c'est est-ce que
le défi des captive autant les réseaux
que les médias ce que je vois c'est que
il y a pas mal de monde sur le site du
Figaro et pas mal sur le sur la page
Youtube de figarologue donc il a
effectivement la séquence visiblement à
trouver un public si vous voulez
deux catégorie il y a beaucoup de gens
qui relèvent des images des
manifestations qui a eu le reste de la
France où il n'y a pas eu que des
violences loin de là 300 manifestations
sur les 300 manifestations vous avez des
diplômes
comme Quimper une Perpignan bref
énormément énormément d'images parce que
les gens filment partage sur les réseaux
sur Twitter sur facebook beaucoup sur
Facebook pour montrer la mobilisation le
fait que ça se passe bien le fait qu'il
n'y a pas forcément toujours des
violences et c'est aussi une façon de
critiquer les violences qui ne sont pas
particulièrement soutenues dans
l'opinion hormis une petite catégorie
qu'il a à l'inverse voilà les violences
en expliquant que c'est de la faute de
la police que c'est de la faute d'une
forme de pression mais globalement si tu
regardes sur majorité des gens regardent
plus pour s'informer étonner de voir la
tournure que certaines manifestations
sont en train de prendre à ça c'est
intéressant c'est il y a un étonnement
en tous les cas qui est en train de
monter sur la route parce qu'en fait les
uns les autres s'attendaient à ce que ça
soit
et des débordements mais plus tard pour
eux le fait qu'il y ait ma personne
syndicale qui soit là devait assurer une
forme de calme que beaucoup de gens
voulaient manifester en famille et
calmement exprimer leur mécontentements
mais mais sans violence et les violences
étaient plutôt attendues en fin de
journée par des ultras que ce soit ultra
gauche ou ultra jaune mais c'était pas
forcément il pensait pas que ça allait
aussi vite dégénérer donc si je le suis
j'en ai je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente et fondatrice de backbone
Consulting ça c'est marqué sur le sur le
synthé juste en dessous de vous juste
avec vous et qui est une institut de
mesure un institut de mesure des réseaux
sociaux et de communication autour des
réseaux sociaux est-ce que je n'ai pas
oublié ne vous inquiétez pas je parlerai
de votre futur de votre futur œuvre mais
je peux vous la montrer et en
avant-première vous avez bien fait de
regarder figarolive parce que ça c'est
quelque chose que vous allez pas voir
beaucoup encore aujourd'hui parce que
c'est ça doit sortir dans 10 jours et ça
s'appelle l'ultime pouvoir la vérité sur
l'impact des réseaux sociaux
inutile de vous dire que on va y revenir
et on va y revenir souvent je prends
déjà date pour que vous venez nous en
parler au moment de la sortie ou un peu
avant on pourra le faire un peu avant
vous allez nous faire cette
avant-première pour nous alors justement
où dans les réseaux ça s'active le plus
aujourd'hui sur Facebook alors sur oui
mais sur Twitter c'est vous savez c'est
pas un lieu où on discute donc chacun sa
posture relève les informations Twitter
c'est une façon d'être vu de commenter
de façon désagréable ou agréable mais
c'est plus des postures sur Facebook
c'est intéressant parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'images qui étaient partagées
et c'est les discussions qu'il y a
derrière vous avez aussi sur Youtube
quelques chaînes qui sont en train de
relayer des images prises en direct et
les commentaires en dessous sont sans
doute là où il y a le plus d'échanges et
c'est assez intéressant parce qu'on voit
que les Français sont en colère avaient
peur d'aller manifester cette élite
cette fois-ci aujourd'hui ça serait un
petit peu plus calme ça n'est pas
forcément le cas dans toutes les vies
parce que là on montre beaucoup Paris
c'est d'ailleurs un des sujets qu'on lit
beaucoup sur Facebook mais il n'y a pas
que Paris alors effectivement en tout
cas si on parle de des violences c'est
ce qui était signalé tout à l'heure ici
en plateau et également sur le sur le
site il y a Lyon Toulouse et Lyon pardon
Nantes Irène particulier Grenoble aussi
et enfin voilà Grenoble il y a aussi
quelques violences quelques violences
Nantes et Lyon très clairement et puis
après le reste de la France c'est pas
toujours très bon enfant parce que je
sais que vous n'aimez pas cette
expression mais ça n'est pas une très
bonne en forme parce que
il y a beaucoup de gens qui brûlent qui
qui s'énervent mais il y a pas de
violence à l'encontre des policiers
c'est plus l'expression de l'armée
contentement parfois de façon un peu un
peu on va dire choquante mais mais
globalement il y a trois villes qui qui
il y a plus de violence et ce qui est
tonne beaucoup sur Facebook c'est la
rapidité à laquelle cette violence est
arrivée parce que les démarrages de tous
ces de toutes ces manifestations étaient
assez calme avec des enfants des
familles des champs des danses enfin
voilà une façon d'exprimer sa colère un
peu un peu plus positive dont les
Français ont envie parce que globalement
vous au fil des semaines nous avons
produit pour vous avec odoxa beaucoup de
sondages qui montrent que les gens
continuent à soutenir ce mouvement mais
quand on regarde vous le soutenez ce que
vous l'avez dans la rue les gens disent
non je ne veux pas aller dans la rue je
soutiens mais je ne manifesterai pas
parce que j'ai peur parce que ça coûte
cher parce que c'est compliqué ce qui
explique d'ailleurs pourquoi 300
manifestations partout en France parce
que les gens n'ont pas forcément envie
de se déplacer et puis ils craignent les
grandes villes et aujourd'hui ça va
conforter leur crainte c'est dangereux
par un petit nombre de personnes qui
caricature le mouvement et qui ne
recueille pas forcément leur soutien ce
qui est vrai en tout cas on a un certain
nombre de chiffres qui qui nous
parviennent à une cinquantaine un peu
plus de cinquantaine 53 interpellations
qui sont signalées effectivement on a vu
des policiers qui ont été victimes de
brûlures et qui ont été brûlés
authentiquement brûlé c'est ce que l'on
a montré des images alors que on assiste
à une charge lancée place de la Nation
ou est arrivé la tête de cortège
et on retiendra donc que les les
premiers sentiments celui qui a dominant
c'est l'étonnement la mauvaise surprise
si je suis et que la communauté le
discours majoritaire c'est la
dénonciation justement des violences et
non pas la l'excuse des violences les
violences en fin de journée il ne les
excusez pas mais à partir du moment où
c'était bien identifié comme le les
conséquences d'action de petits groupes
très minoritaire ça pouvait
potentiellement non pas être soutenu
mais compris là ce qu'il reproche c'est
en fait ils arrivent au milieu d'une
fête au milieu d'une manifestation qui
était censée être pacifiste ils mettent
en danger les policiers et les
manifestants et c'est ça qui est plutôt
reproché est-ce que la sortie de
François Bayrou disant la réforme a été
mal expliquée a eu un écho sur les
réseaux alors Monsieur
incroyable sur les réseaux mais disons
que son expression rejoint celle des
internautes et des Français ce sentiment
que tout à l'heure il est plutôt dans le
jusqu'au bout de la réflexion est-ce
qu'il est plutôt à la remorque de
l'opinion plutôt qu'elles sont à son
origine je dirais pas jusqu'à la
remorque mais disons que il est aligné
avec l'opinion et que c'est pas sa
tribune qui a une résonance et ce
sentiment que les Français ont que les
choses ont été prises à l'envers en
particulier dans ce qu'on lit le plus et
c'était flagrant aujourd'hui autour de
la notion le 1er mai ça fait du travail
donc au delà des retraites c'est le
sujet du travail en disant mais les
conditions de travail et l'ensemble des
discussions autour des conditions de
travail aurait dû avoir lieu avant la
discussion sur la réforme des retraites
donc c'est cette impression que tout a
été pris à l'envers qu'on les a pas
écoutés que dans le fond il y a une
espèce de déconnexion d'autant que dans
ce que j'ai lu depuis ce matin les gens
croient peu au fait que la réforme va
être tirée donc en fait ils ont envie de
dire est-ce qu'on pourrait prendre les
choses dans le bon sens cette fois-ci
alors ça c'est très intéressant parce
que ça rejoint la question du jour sur
le site Figaro à savoir après le premier
qui est le formuler en ces termes après
le 1er mai le gouvernement va-t-il
réussir à tourner la page de la réforme
des retraites d'ailleurs vous pouvez
voter la question est en ligne depuis la
mi-journée si je vous suis il y a cet
élément c'est que il y a quand même la
conviction et qui est un élément capital
pour faire passer une réforme on l'a vu
la conviction que le la loi de toute
façon maintenant est adoptée et on
retarde on retardera l'âge de la
retraite oui un petit espoir sur lui
mais un petit espoir globalement le fait
de descendre c'est pas tant parce qu'on
entend beaucoup depuis quelques jours la
notion de baroud d'honneur c'est pas
ainsi en tout cas que les Français
l'expriment c'est plus pour dire non en
fait il va pas falloir refaire cette
méthode là nous ne sommes pas contents
nous avons compris que la réforme va
s'appliquer dans quelques temps nous
pourrons voter et peut-être venir en
arrière mais ce que l'on souhaite c'est
que les prochaines discussions en
particulier les discussions autour des
du travail des conditions de travail des
seniors de la pénibilité enfin
l'ensemble de ce qui pourrait être la
loi travail doit être discuté
correctement en amont en tenant compte
non seulement de des syndicats mais
aussi de la rue alors dans le sondage
que vous avez réalisé je reviens sur un
point que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure avec odoxa pour Le Figaro et qui
est paru dans l'édition papier du Figaro
de cette fin de semaine ce week-end 60%
des Français pensent que le mouvement
lui doit continuer doit se poursuivre
dans ces conditions là sous quelle forme
mais alors c'est un mouvement pas
forcément pour que la réforme soit
retirée enfin ils aimeraient bien mais
ils ont compris que pas forcément pour
eux c'est une façon en maintenant le
mouvement de dire effectivement nous
sommes là de dire sur tout ce que nous
allons avoir comme discussion et de
nouveau en particulier sur le travail on
a besoin que d'être écouté donc c'est
pas tant la poursuite de ce mouvement
que descendre dans la rue ou signer des
pétitions il y a beaucoup de discussions
autour du Rip même si là aussi les
Français ne croient peu au fait que de
trois mai le rythme accepté mais envie
de s'exprimer en fait si on regarde il y
a une espèce de fil rouge qui est votée
pour quelqu'un et lui donner un blanc
sain pour 5 ans ça marche plus on a
envie d'être consulté les Français à
envie qu'on leur demande régulièrement
leur avis donc c'est ça quand ils disent
poursuivre le mouvement c'est surtout ça
il y a une en tout cas on vous écoutant
et pas simplement aujourd'hui on sent
que que ce soit le rip le RIC en tout
cas est-ce que vous venez de dire cette
envie de consultation permanente
cette figure du référendum est quand
même en train de de monter en puissance
et de d'être très forte est-ce que une
fine et il y a comme prétendent certains
l'amertume
du référendum de 2005 ou à l'époque
effectivement une majorité française
avait voté contre la Constitution
européenne et puis après finalement
Nicolas Sarkozy avec le traité de
Lisbonne c'était assis dessus en
essayant de faire rentrer le texte par
d'autres voix et est-ce qu'il y a ce
sentiment là à ce qu'il y a cette
amertume là qui est toujours
présentes un certain nombre de
de référendum qui n'ont pas été
respectés ou en tout cas le résultat n'a
pas été respecté ça n'empêche pas les
Français de croire que un référendum est
nécessaire sur plein de points ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ça remet pas
en cause parce qu'on entend beaucoup de
personnes dire c'est la cinquième
république qui est en cause c'est la
remise en cause la Cinquième République
pourtant le référendum c'est précisément
l'un des scrutin
totémique de la de la Cinquième
République c'est plus que ils n'ont plus
confiance dans les politiques donc ça ne
les étonne pas que des politiques n'est
pas suivi les résultats des référendums
mais pour autant ils croient que un
référendum aujourd'hui parce que les
deux cas que l'on cite sont assez
anciens aujourd'hui avec une
mobilisation dans la rue pour dire cette
fois le résultat des référendums il
faudra en tenir compte les Français sont
peut-être optimistes parce qu'en tout
cas ils pensent que ça peut fonctionner
et c'est pas forcément renverser la 5e
c'est poser nous des questions
interrogez nous nous ne pouvons pas vous
laisser un blanc sain sur des événements
que on ne peut pas anticiper alors on a
quelques coupures de réseaux en ce
moment à l'heure où parler alors on voit
ça c'est les images qui nous parviennent
de l'AFP mais nos équipes qui sont sur
place nous indiquent que place de la
Nation et enfin à l'entrée de la place
de la Nation il y a des blocages ou les
policiers ne laissent pas rentrer sur la
place de place de la Nation alors
question est-ce que c'est lié à ce que
l'on voit là en direct ce qui nous est
depuis cette place là où justement il y
a une volonté de d'évacuer le maximum de
personnes pour laisser arriver le reste
du cortège et de que ça se produise de
la façon la plus pacifique possible
est-ce que c'est pour une autre raison
et bien c'est j'espère que on va pouvoir
rentrer de nouveau en relation avec nos
vous envoyez spéciaux sur place pour
avoir ces réponses et pour savoir ce qui
se passe vraiment mais en tous les cas
voilà sachez que il y a ça ralentit le
cortège et bloqué à l'entrée de la place
de la Nation Véronique j'en reviens à ce
qu'on se dit sur les sur les réseaux
puisque vous en êtes une spécialiste
est-ce que il y a une volonté que ou un
refus que les syndicats saisissent la
main tendue par le gouvernement
notamment sur les sujets
dont on parle depuis le début de
l'après-midi
que sans le partage de la valeur que
sont
l'assurance chômage ou encore l'emploi
des signes pas du tout
il y a pas du tout il y a pas du tout
d'intérêt il y a pas du tout
l'expression sur ces questions là il y a
beaucoup d'expression et au contraire le
sujet n'est pas du tout de dire non le
sujet est d'abord les syndicats sur les
grands vainqueur ou en tout cas sont
sortis renforcer de la séquence que nous
venons de traverser ce qui que les
Français ont apprécié c'est qu'ils sont
alignés et que il y a une forme de
cohérence et en fait ce que l'on lit
c'est que
il ne faut pas qu'ils acceptent
n'importe quoi n'importe comment c'était
l'objectif et la façon de c'est le c'est
la base donc il faut c'est pour eux il
faut qu'ils aillent mais pas à n'importe
quel condition c'est exactement ce que
dit Laurent verger ce matin sur France
Info il va falloir payer et payer cher
pour qu'on vienne c'est ça à la rue les
Français dispament pas payer mais ils
disent soyons très clair sur l'objectif
soyez entrer clair sur les modalités
parce que en fait les syndicalistes
l'ont mal pris mais les Français aussi
en disant mais on a dit que il n'avait
rien proposé ce qui n'était pas
forcément le cas donc ils disent si
c'est pour faire
il faut pas que les syndicat aillent si
il y a une vraie volonté avec un
objectif bien défini des modalités
opératoires bien définies au contraire
les syndicats avaient tout à y perdre
dans le pignon public en yantant
il y a un centre de commentaires dans le
chat c'est certain disent mais après les
législatives avec des résultats comme ça
le général de Gaulle aurait démissionné
est-ce que c'est un
sentiment qui a sur les réseaux où je
vous pose ma question différemment
est-ce que la communauté
prend Macron en tous les cas de soutien
au président et et mobilisé alors elle
est pas énorme elle s'exprime très peu
elle s'est un peu exprimée ces derniers
temps parce que fatigué de voir des
attaques constants donc on voyait des
messages qui remontaient pour dire
arrêtons le
groupe ça commence
mais il y a une donnée qui a toujours
très intéressante sur les réseaux c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'engagement
c'est-à-dire la réalité de est-ce que
les gens partagent commentent like voilà
quel que soit les réseaux on va dire que
les soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron étaient
peu présents s'exprimait peu était peu
engagé depuis quelques temps ils le sont
un peu plus et il y a des ministres qui
suscitent plus d'engagement que d'autres
dans le gouvernement
en particulier monsieur Attal par
exemple et généralement un des ministres
qui
s'exprimer un peu plus soutenu que les
autres ou en tout cas il a plus
d'engagement mais ce qui est clair c'est
que par rapport à d'autres périodes
voilà c'est une communauté qui est pas
très active et peu visible contrairement
à ce qui était par exemple les fans de
Monsieur Sarkozy en leur temps sur le
réseau sociaux alors on va revenir place
de la Nation où il y a pas beaucoup de
fans de Nicolas Sarkozy je pense
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui on retrouve
Damien Canivez ce qui est qui est sur
place alors Damien on voit encore la sur
vos images une pas sur celle qui sont
diffusées mais sur celles qui nous
parviennent une charge de la police on
nous signale que la place est bloquée
qu'en est-il de votre côté
alors écoutez on n'a pas la vue sur la
place enfin le boulevard Voltaire ce
boulevard d'où les manifestants influent
sur cette place de la Nation nous avec
Julien Leclerc nous sommes plutôt si
vous voulez sur le côté gauche de cette
place lorsqu'on regarde la place de la
Nation en face et c'est assez compliqué
pour l'instant d'avoir une visibilité
puisqu'il vient d'avoir une charge de la
police et de la gendarmerie juste devant
nous qui a noyé cette place sous les
grenades lacrymogènes pour que les
manifestants se dispersent on a bien
compris que c'était vraiment leur
stratégie depuis tout à l'heure depuis
que nous sommes arrivés sur cette place
dès lors que les policiers arrivent sur
cette sur cette place de la Nation il
dégaine systématiquement leur leur
grenades lacrymogènes pour que les
manifestants se dispersent vous avez vu
aussi tout à l'heure sur les images de
Julien Leclerc des canons à eau qui ont
été utilisés aussi en nombre sur sur
cette place il y en a on en a compté au
moins au moins deux qui se trouvent dans
des rues par dans des rues adjacentes et
pouvez aussi assez efficace pour faire
reculer les manifestants il recule mais
il ne se disperse pas c'est assez
difficile à vrai dire pour les forces de
l'ordre puisque les manifestants c'était
le point d'aboutissement de cette de
cette manifestation cette place de la
Nation et
les policiers n'ont pas réussi à les
faire
à les extraire dans des rues dans des
voitures sur le fil désolé si j'ai un
petit peu de mal à parler ici parce que
comme je vous le disais la place est
noyée soudée grenades lacrymogène et
vous imaginez les effets que ça peut
faire au niveau du nez et des poumons
mais tout ce que je peux vous dire ici
aussi c'est que la brave vous savez
cette unité motorisée de la préfecture
de police de Paris est intervenu à
plusieurs reprises pour disperser et
interpeller les manifestants et ils ont
été particulièrement hués puisque vous
le savez ce qu'ils font partie ils sont
dans le viseur des manifestants d'ultra
gauche c'est brave m qui sont accusés de
de violences policières donc il les
appelle et ils ont été aussi employés
sur sur cette manifestation
le calme ne revient pas on est toujours
sur le même niveau de violence que
lorsque je suis intervenu sur figarolive
il y a quelques minutes de ça et comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure on se
demande bien comment cette manifestation
va se terminer on regarde du nombre de
d'éléments radicaux qui se trouve ici
place de la Nation à Paris
merci beaucoup Damien effectivement on
comprend tout à fait que il s'est
variations de temps et que effectivement
vous faites bien de remettre les masques
quand sont tirés des grenades
lacrymogènes il faut en avoir respirer
une ou deux fois pour savoir quelle est
l'effet que ça fait
il y a un concert de casseroles sur les
réseaux
gouvernés
les Français ne sont pas très d'accord
avec les violences qu'on voit les
casseroles ça n'est pas violent en tout
cas c'est pas ainsi que les Français le
perçoivent en plus les Cassoles elles
sont plutôt populaires elles sont un
symboles assez simples finalement entre
je fais du bruit pour être entendu je
fais du bruit pour couvrir la parole que
je ne veux pas entendre c'est aussi un
symbole sur cette expression populaire
traîner des casseroles qui disent que
voilà on n'est pas toujours très fier
des actes que l'on traîne derrière soi
et enfin c'est un symbole autour de
l'inflation que votre casserole est vide
et bien vous pouvez faire du bruit et
quand elle est pleine elle fait moins de
bruit donc oui c'est plutôt populaire il
y avait pas mal de consignes sur les
réseaux pour dire il va falloir aller
taper sur des casseroles dans les dans
les cortèges finalement les violences et
l'ensemble des actions que l'on voit là
font que il y a eu moins de casseroles
finalement que attendues dans dans les
cortèges mais pour autant sur les
réseaux c'est un symbole de toute façon
les casseroles elles ne vissent pas être
dans les dans des cortèges comme
celle-là des casseroles elles sont
faites pour lorsqu'il y a des trucs de
mais ça aurait pu être ça aurait pu être
un peu plus fort que ce que c'était
aujourd'hui ce qui est intéressant dans
le sondage de luxe à baboune de ce
week-end c'est que
le c'est ce que à travers le mouvement
des casseroles la popularité
qu'il y a enfin vis-à-vis du mouvement
des casseroles c'est que Emmanuel Macron
c'est ce que révèle le sondage est
inaudible en tous les cas ils veulent
pas les couper
c'est pour ça que ces casseroles sont si
populaires c'est que voilà ça fait du
bruit pour être entendu mais ça couvre
aussi la parole de quelqu'un qu'on n'a
pas envie d'entendre donc ça explique
pourquoi c'est si sympathique au regard
des uns et les autres et pourquoi ce
mouvement qui la question était pas
est-ce que vous soutenez mais est-ce que
vous le comprenez et oui les gens
comprennent ce mouvement et pas
forcément en train de me soutenir non
il y a eu
est-ce qu'il y a eu un regain justement
de casserole de soutien en tous les cas
et de dénonciation
Macron au moment de
la finale de la Coupe de France en tout
cas au niveau des réseaux alors sur les
réseaux on voyait bien que il y avait
des Templiers
parce que quand pacifié envoyer bien que
le sujet c'est un sujet du sport et
c'était pas trop un sujet autour des des
cartons d'autant qu'il y avait beaucoup
de messages où les uns et les autres
disaient mais c'est en siffle ça a
perturbé le match avait perturbé les
joueurs la vraie question que les gens
se posaient c'est est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron va aller sur la pelouse ou pas en
se disant à ce moment-là le sifflet ou
faire du bruit ne mettez pas en danger
le match donc ils avaient plutôt envie
de ça ce qui n'a pas été le cas mais ça
n'a pas il y avait pas une attente
autour de ce match dans le pays en
public aussi fort que dans les médias
est-ce que le meeting du RN aura au
Havre aujourd'hui a eu un impact sur les
réseaux sociaux il a été commenté mais
pas énormément pas autant j'imagine
qu'il aurait souhaité et c'est toujours
pareil pour le moment ça reste toujours
sur la même sphère donc on va mettre de
côté les observateurs et les
journalistes politiques qui de fait le
commandes donc j'ai des sentir des
volumes qu'on a observés mais après
quand on regarde les Français
globalement ils en ont pas beaucoup
parlé ils ont plus fait des parallèles
sur la ville plutôt que sur le où ça a
eu lieu au Havre et en rappelant que
peut-être c'était la ville du futur
opposant à Marine Le Pen ou en tout cas
c'est sans doute ce qu'elle souhaite et
après les commentaires étaient
essentiellement sur les sphères
rassemblement national droite et extrava
on peut dire aujourd'hui que en terme de
sur la bataille du buzz c'est quand même
ce que l'on voit actuellement qu'il a
emporté et qui domine les commentaires
sur les réseaux sociaux tout le support
confondu sans conteste sur tous les
supports même sur les plateformes de
jeunes comme petit frère voilà et même
les gens du rassemblement national ont
presque plus commenté les et des
manifestations que
la prestation de Jordan Bardella
première prestation en tant que
président du Rassemblement national
enfin de ce style lors du premier mai
les casseroles ne sont pas interdites
nous dit Charlène ce sont seulement les
moyens
amplifiés qui le audio qui le sont
amplifiés qui le sont
c'est effectivement il y a pas mal de
réactions autour de ça également autour
du des gazages qu'il y a place de la
place de la Nation à la place de la
Nation en ce moment c'est ce que
rapporte à la fois notre équipe sur
place également les autres journalistes
du Figaro qui sont sur le terrain et
bloqué par la force de l'ordre un petit
peu comme sur les éléments qui nous
parviennent sont manifestants sont
quelque peu Nasser place de la Nation
dès que nos équipes sur place
rallume les caméras dès qu'on retrouve
les images on va on va les on va les on
va les justement les interroger j'ai une
dernière question avant de retrouver
Arnaud benedettis qui avec nous en
duplex est-ce que le bad buzz autour des
pages sulfureuses du dernier roman de
Bruno Le Maire a reculé
je croyais que vous aviez demandé ce
qu'on en a parlé oui oui ben justement
ça c'est difficile il s'en recule pas du
tout non et les internautes font preuve
d'une imagination sans bornes pour
utiliser ce passage pour le dérouter et
pour utiliser l'expression enfin voilà
donc et ça ne recule pas et même des
manifestations comme ça
c'est à notre sujet c'est voilà les gens
commentent beaucoup les images
manifestations les violences mais là
c'est un autre sujet c'est d'abord ça
fait rire donc en règle générale sur des
réseaux sociaux quand vous faites rire
ça se calme pas tout de suite on est
plutôt dans une espèce de compétition
sur les internautes pour trouver des
détournements des images des phrases
drôles donc non ça ne s'arrête pas ça
finira par forcément redescendre mais
pour le vraiment voilà on peut dire que
en tout cas le musée
de l'économie en tout cas fait un bad
buzz avec son roman
on va revenir merci beaucoup Véronique
on va revenir place de la alors avant de
revenir place de la Nation d'abord ce
livre qu'il faut absolument
effectivement lire et l'ultime pouvoir
la vérité sur l'impact des réseaux
sociaux c'est donc le livre de Véronique
resoult qui était bien entendu à lire
bien entendu aux éditions du Cerf passer
sous les fourches collines de grands
éditeurs de grands responsables
d'édition voilà je vois Arnaud Benedetti
sourire à autre habitué des éditions du
Cerf mais effectivement d'excellente
éditions néanmoins et on va vous dire
avec avec beaucoup d'intérêt parce que
c'est effectivement une question que
l'on se pose et donc vous viendrez nous
en parler en plateau merci beaucoup
Véronique d'être d'avoir été avec nous
on va retourner place de la Nation
quelle est la situation quelle est
l'ambiance d'Amiens Canivet
ambiance toujours très tendue ici
Vincent roux nous sommes place de la
Nation où le pré-corpège de la
manifestation du Premier ministre arrivé
il y a un petit moment maintenant ça
fait de très très longues minutes qu'il
y a des scènes de guérilla urbaine ici
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
éléments d'ultra gauche qui sont arrivés
ils sont extrêmement nombreux ici et la
stratégie de la police est si vise à
charger un patron retrait à charger un
repas en retrait et à essayer de
disperser ces éléments radicaux il se
dispersent très difficilement parce
qu'ils sont tellement nombreux qu'ils
prennent quasiment la totalité de cette
place de la Nation donc c'est très
difficile pour les forces de l'ordre de
ce Fred il y a un chemin et d'arriver à
disperser ces éléments d'ultra gauche
qui sont qui sont ici on a l'impression
qu'ils sont un petit peu en manque
d'inspiration les policiers parce que la
situation ne se détend pas là vous voyez
une charge de police qui se sous nos
yeux qui est filmé par la traque de
subir Leclerc vous voyez c'est systém
comment ce qui se passe depuis tout à
l'heure c'est à dire des charges de la
police la police qui part en retrait etc
et vous allez voir que là effectivement
on va avoir un semblant de calme qui va
revenir et très vite un black bloc va se
reformer et des jeux de projectiles vont
revenir le cortège syndical n'est pas du
tout arrivé en retard là il y a même des
policiers vous voyez qui se font cailler
assez juste sous le jeu ça devient
extrêmement dangereux pour eux parce que
vous avez des des personnes qui se
trouve au milieu de cette place de la
Nation et les policiers qui trébu chez
forcément des manifestants en profitent
pour leur balancer des des des
projectiles et une charge de la police
effectivement vient en renfort pour
tenter de protéger leurs camarades c'est
toujours très très tendu ici place de la
Nation alors vous voyez on est encore
noyé sous des grenades lacrymogènes
c'est c'est vraiment ce qui se passe
depuis tout à l'heure on sera capable de
vous dire le nombre de grenades
lacrymogènes qui ont été tirés depuis
tout à l'heure mais on va dire que c'est
très difficile de voir à 10 mètres ici
sur cette place
la fumée épaisse à cause de ces de ces
grenades nous sentiraient depuis tout à
l'heure il y a voilà on envoie encore
là-bas des policiers qui qui chargent
des manifestants il y a des petits
groupes sportifs de policiers qui qui
charge des éléments radicaux vous avez
également des feux qui sont allumés sur
cette place pour tenter diriger des
barricades et pour les manifestants se
protéger contre les charges des forces
de l'ordre mais ça n'a que très peu
d'effet sur eux ils parviennent
systématiquement à atteindre leur cible
mais en tout cas contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu entendre plus tard sur votre
plateau c'est vrai qu'on a entendu qu'il
y avait une cinquantaine
d'interpellations ici dans dans les rues
de Paris nous n'en avons pas vu voilà il
y a énormément de de manifestants ultra
violents ici donc on regarde de la
violence que l'on voit 50 ça paraît
assez peu
53 exactement Damien et avec un policier
brûlé également un policier blessé c'est
on a vu les images tout à l'heure c'est
en tous les cas le bilan qui est donné
pour l'instant il y a également des
chiffres qui sont avancés notamment par
la CGT dès que on a une confirmation
officielle on va vous la donner
il est comparé bien sûr avec les autres
les autres manifestations et ben voilà
le chiffre est tombé 2,3 millions de
manifestants ça c'est le chiffre donné
par la CGT tout à l'heure et pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'éléments de
comparaison avec les autres journées de
manifestation donc c'est un chiffre brut
bien évidemment
il faut le le comparer et le mettre en
balance avec les autres sources on avait
on avait autour de 500 000
la manifestants ça c'était le les
chiffres qui étaient donnés par
le fil data
par tout en fin d'après-midi
pour 400
418000 614000 personnes dans la rue à
17h ça c'était ce qui était donné donc
par le feed data voilà
je le retrouve ce qui est un chiffre en
tous les cas qui était au-delà de des
chiffres de la fourchette qui était
attendu qui était entre 500 et 600 000
personnes 614 000 manifestants à 17h
c'est beaucoup plus que le 13 avril à la
même heure puisque c'était 299
000 personnes donc c'est c'est de plus
de deux fois plus et c'est moins que les
manifestants le 7 mars où c'était 1,28
millions à l'époque
bonjour Arnaud Benedetti est-ce que vous
m'entendez bien
je vous entends parfaitement alors merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous d'être en
visio avec nous
600 donc on l'indique 614 000
manifestants en fin d'après-midi
sur ce plan là sur le plan des chiffres
le défilé les défilés puisqu'il y avait
300 villes qui sont
300 manifestations qui étaient
organisées sont plutôt en tout cas au
plan des chiffres c'est plutôt un succès
non
oui c'est à peu près en tout cas ce qui
avait été
par les renseignements territoriaux
depuis quelques jours on est un peu
au-delà même en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il va y avoir une bataille sur
les chiffres suite à cette mobilisation
entre d'un côté la majorité de l'autre
côté des syndicats ça me paraît à peu
près certain mais il est clair que c'est
plutôt une mobilisation qui reste très
forte un 1er mai beaucoup plus forte que
les premiers mai de ces dernières années
clairement et beaucoup plus forte que
les enfin en tout cas plus forte que les
dernières mobilisations que l'on a connu
c'est dernière semaine donc de ce point
de vue là les syndicats peuvent
exciter un succès au moins sur le plan
quantitatif ensuite il y a quand même un
deuxième élément qu'il faut prendre en
compte ce sont ces images que l'on voit
depuis maintenant circuler depuis
quelques depuis quelques heures à la
fois à Paris à Nantes à Lyon de violence
qui émaillent les cortèges reste à
savoir comment ces images vont être
aussi métabolisées d'une certaine
manière ou interpréter élu par une
opinion publique ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qu'il faudra se regarder de très
près dans les heures et dans les jours
qui viennent
maintenant on a cette donc c'est
violence on a également cette
mobilisation qui en tout cas se
maintient
j'allais vous poser la question et
maintenant qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
qu'est-ce qui doit se passer
si vous voulez c'est la grande question
est-ce que le 1er mai qu'est-ce qui se
passe du côté des syndicats qui d'une
certaine manière ont expérimenté toutes
les formes de mobilisation depuis
maintenant près de trois mois plus trois
mois après ce que plus trois mois en
effet depuis le 19 janvier
qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce qui
concerne le soutien d'opinion publique
qui à ce stade reste massif et qui et ça
c'est une surprise que l'on attendait
pas vrai semblablement continue à rester
constant vis-à-vis des mobilisations
c'est à dire malgré l'adoption malgré la
promulgation de la loi malgré
vraisemblablement la rédaction dans les
jours qui viennent et l'action des qui
ont du texte sur les retraites une
majorité depuis considèrent que il faut
que les mobilisations perdurent c'est
assez surprenant et assez
contradictoires par rapport à une
opinion qui a toujours été certes
hostile à le texte de loi mais qui a
toujours considéré qu'une finit il
serait adopté donc il y a quelque chose
d'assez paradoxal si vous voulez dans ce
dans cette j'allais dans cette dans
cette dans cette attitude de de
l'opinion majoritaire mais en tout cas
clairement elle soutient pour l'instant
les les mobilisations dernier point
c'est qu'est-ce qui va se passer
politiquement qu'est-ce qui va se passer
politiquement dans dans les jours qui
viennent notamment à l'Assemblée
nationale le vrai sujet aujourd'hui pour
Emmanuel Macron au delà de la grande
sociale qui reste très forte et qui
semble en tout cas ne pas retomber
il y a la question de la façon dont il
peut opérer avec une Assemblée nationale
qui est une Assemblée nationale de plus
en plus compliquée qui était compliqué
déjà du fait des résultats des élections
législatives de 2022 qu'il est encore
plus depuis la discussion et le passage
avec le 49-3 du texte sur les retraites
et on l'a vu encore il y a trois jours
ou quatre jours la première ministre
madame borne annoncé qu'elle reportait
cinédié un des projets pourtant qui
avait été annoncé
avec force par l'exécutif et par le
ministre de l'Intérieur le projet de loi
sur l'immigration y a-t-il encore une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour
permettre à l'exécutif de pouvoir
déployer une feuille de route réformiste
ça c'est la vraie question
publique
et contenu de ce qui se passe dans la
rue ça devient de plus en plus
contrainte on va on va justement on va y
revenir Arnaud une question d'abord si
je reviens à cette journée on vient
d'avoir Véronique reichsoul qui vient de
nous donner l'analyse des réseaux
sociaux et l'impact que c'est
mobilisations ces questions là ont sur
les sur les réseaux est-ce qu'on peut
dire quand même que
au terme d'ailleurs de peut-être pas au
terme mais en tout cas depuis le début
de cette séquence les syndicats ont
gagné une bataille celle d'avoir enrayé
leur déclin et puis celle de réoccuper
le terrain médiatique et le terrain du
débat
clairement si vous voulez la bataille de
la communication politique a été gagnée
ces derniers mois par des syndicats qui
semblaient affaiblis depuis un certain
nombre d'années ils sont revenus au
centre du jeu ils sont revenus au centre
du lieu d'autant plus qu'ils sont unis
aujourd'hui et ça c'est quand même un
facteur politique qui est extrêmement
important on n'avait pas connu une telle
unité syndicale depuis une dizaine
d'années
ils sont revenus au centre du jeu parce
que en effet quand on regarde les études
d'opinion ils sont à nouveau crédités
comme des interlocuteurs avec lesquels
les pouvoirs publics doivent
nécessairement dialoguer donc ça c'est
un point important et ils sont soutenus
dans cette séquence de contestation de
la réforme des retraites donc c'est en
effet ce point de vue là le retour au
des syndicats comme c'est le retour des
corps intermédiaires en général c'est
que en effet
exercice du pouvoir qui se veut vertical
moi j'aime pas trop cette expression
parce que je pense qu'il est plus
managérial que vertical en l'occurrence
et franchement d'ailleurs managérial
mais c'est une autre question
il y a aujourd'hui un besoin qui se
manifeste dans la société française
qu'on avait vu d'ailleurs au moment de
la crise des gilets jaunes ou les élus
locaux étaient remontés en première
ligne aussi pour essayer d'apaiser les
tensions que l'on a vu du nom de
certaines d'une certaine manière aussi
durant la crise covid au début de la
crise covid quand un certain nombre de
maires de conseillers régionaux de
président de conseil régionaux ont
essayé là aussi sur le terrain de de de
mener un certain nombre d'actions
sanitaires il y a un retour aussi des
corps intermédiaires et les syndicats
font partie des corps intermédiaires ça
veut dire quand même qu'il y a un besoin
de démocratie qui s'exprime à travers la
question des retraites la question des
retraites est certes une question qui
mobilise mais au-delà de la question de
retraite il faut voir ce qu'il y a
derrière il y a ce besoin de démocratie
et la démocratie dans une pas si
représentative elle fonctionne aussi par
les corps intermédiaires dont les
syndicats qui reviennent aujourd'hui
dans le jeu oui mais d'un autre côté on
entend quand même une revendication qui
est en train de monter Véronique
reissoult le disait à l'instant c'est de
recourir à quelque chose qui n'est pas
très correct intermédiaire mais qui est
très très démocratique en revanche c'est
le référendum oui tout à fait mais si
vous voulez c'est bien le sujet c'est un
sujet de fond parce que cette crise elle
dit quelque chose sur la façon dont
finalement aujourd'hui le pouvoir
politique et je suis patient d'ailleurs
que cette époque différent avec d'autres
offres politiques de Macron mais là en
tout cas le problème d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est qu'il a un problème avec les corps
intermédiaires et quand vous avez un
problème avec les corps intermédiaires
ça pourrait être le cas du général de
Gaulle qui n'était pas toujours d'accord
avec les parlementaires qui n'étaient
pas toujours d'accord avec les syndicats
qui n'étaient pas toujours d'accord avec
le patronat mais quand vous avez un
problème avec les corps intermédiaires
et bien vous avez démocratique
qui est celui de la démocratie directe
et là en effet il y a ce besoin qui est
déjà manifesté lors de la crise des
gilets jaunes souvenez-vous avec la
revendications sur le le référendum
d'initiative citoyen et là aujourd'hui
également il y a une demande de
référendum à travers le riz pour avoir
d'ailleurs ce que donnera le ce que va
répondre le Conseil constitutionnel dans
48 heures au projet de de RIP des
référendum d'initiative partagée déposés
par la par la par la vitesse il y a ce
besoin là mais aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas choisi cette voie il
essaye de gagner du temps il l'use
jusqu'à la corde madame borne sa
première ministre espérant que elle va
tenir jusqu'à l'été qu'une fois l'été
arrivée mais on passera à autre chose
c'est un pari qu'il fait mais c'est un
pari qui n'est pas sans risque
Marine Le Pen et le RN se sont
décentralisés au Havre aujourd'hui à
Paris était au syndicat même si on le
voit avec ces images ces images de
violence est-ce que là aussi c'est pas
une victoire pour eux
pour les syndicats
le fait que
pardon aujourd'hui oui clairement
aujourd'hui quand on regarde et je
rejoins ce que ce qui était dit tout à
l'heure auparavant qu'on regarde les
réseaux sociaux même si il faut pas
regarder la société à travers seulement
les réseaux sociaux mais quand même la
focale médiatique elle est du côté de ce
qui se passe avec les mobilisations
syndicales dans toute la France et à
Paris et dans les grandes villes même si
le rassemblement national a essayé de de
telle manière de d'apparaître de ne pas
perdre du terrain médiatique dans cette
journée très spécifique
bon il en demeure pas moins
qu'aujourd'hui quand même après sur un
plan politique ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui depuis maintenant un certain
temps le rassemblement national
capitalise capitalise pour plusieurs
raisons parce que une fine et la gauche
n'a pas réussi à faire fructifier d'une
certaine façon
le mécontentement il a colère contre à
ce projet à cette loi sur les sur les
retraites
elle participe certes à
l'affaiblissement du gouvernement mais
elle n'en tire pas vraiment profit pour
l'instant le fait qu'à droite les
républicains n'ont pas réussi pour
l'instant à se reconstruire donc la sœur
la seule force politique qui est
aujourd'hui disons en ordre de marche
clairement avec un président avec une
candidate certes non déclarée à la
présidentielle mais dont tout le monde
imagine qu'elle le sera à nouveau
ce parti est aujourd'hui en tout cas le
mieux placé pour occuper politique on
est très loin on est encore très très
loin des échéances de 2027 évidemment
on va revenir justement sur peut-être
pas les prochaines échéances celle de
2027 dans un instant avec vous Arnaud et
surtout sur la question du jour sur le
site du Figaro sur justement ce que peut
faire et ce que doit faire le
gouvernement même si vous avez déjà
abordé cette question mais on va y
revenir parce qu'on l'a pas épuisé ce
que je vous propose c'est d'aller autour
de la place de la Nation retrouver
Thibault Gauthier qui est un de nos
envoyer spéciaux avec François
Carpentier Thibault vous étiez bloqué
tout à l'heure à l'entrée de la place de
la Nation est-ce que c'est toujours le
cas
alors ça y est nous sommes sur la place
de la de la nation alors en fait ce
qu'il s'est passé c'est très simple
c'est qu'il y avait des affrontements
sur la place de la Nation vous voyez
comment elle est faite cette place vous
avez les images en surplomb je j'imagine
avec ce grand rond-point et donc c'est
comme si les affrontements tournaient
autour de la place et au moment où bien
les affrontements sont arrivés à
l'entrée de l'artère du boulevard
Voltaire et bien tout le monde s'est
arrêté tout le monde était bloqué alors
c'est vrai que les forces de l'ordre ont
bloqué pendant un instant et puis
ensuite ce qui s'est passé c'est très
simple c'est que plusieurs personnes ne
voulaient pas entrer sur la place de la
Nation en voyant bien que c'est là que
se déroulait plus les les affrontements
c'est intéressant parce que on avançant
progressivement on s'approchant de cette
place de de la nation on a senti que
l'atmosphère changeait
alors justement ça refige alors on va
retrouver tout de suite Arnaud Benedetti
le temps qu'on retrouve
Thibault Gauthier François Carpentier et
il y a du monde sur place c'est ce qui
explique un petit peu ces coupures mais
on sent qu'il y a un changement
d'ambiance et en fait effectivement on
le voit sur ces images c'est beaucoup
plus calme pour l'instant on va voir on
va continuer de regarder comment comment
ça se passe on revient vers vous Arnaud
Benedetti c'est la question du jour
alors peut-être avant de revenir vers
vous je vais peut-être aller faire un
tour avec
toujours du côté de la place de la
Nation avec Damien Canivez Damien quelle
est l'ambiance là où vous trouvez là ça
a l'air beaucoup moins calme
ah c'est beaucoup moins calme mais pour
être honnête avec vous ça n'a jamais été
calme en fait dans cette manifestation
depuis qu'on s'est lancé à 14 heures
depuis la place de la République à Paris
et là c'est la tension atteint son
paroxysme les policiers sont vraiment
pris à partie et ça devient extrêmement
compliqué vous voyez que là un immeuble
risque d'être en feu il y a eu des
travaux visiblement au niveau de cette
entrée et le matériel qui s'y trouvait a
été incendié vous voyez que c'est
flammes elles sont extrêmement hautes il
y a un vrai risque d'incendie et de
propagation des flammes ici au niveau de
cet immeuble qui se trouve Place de la
Nation on imagine que les immeubles
alentours vont être évacués dans
quelques instants parce que c'est
extrêmement dangereux ici ce qui se
passe alors les policiers ont du mal
même à se faire à se faire un chemin la
fumée noire est extrêmement dense ici
franchement c'est c'est assez calvité
parce qu'il se passe c'est parti d'un
tout petit départ de feu mais la police
pourtant chargée mais ils ne sont pas
parvenus à sécuriser ce bâtiment qui est
en train de de partir alors pour
l'instant l'immeuble ne semble pas en
feu c'est vrai que sur les images c'est
très impression mais c'est à vrai dire
un espèce d'auto là qui est en train de
de prendre feu à l'entraide de ce
bâtiment voilà il y a eu tout un tas de
de matériel inflammable qui s'y trouvait
à côté d'ailleurs on se demande pourquoi
cela n'a pas été et ça n'a pas été
enlevé à à la veille de cette
manifestation on a vu aussi tout un tas
de tout un tas de de travaux sur le
parcours qui a été utilisé tout un tas
de oui c'est ça de travaux qui est tout
en cours sur l'itinéraire de la
manifestation évidemment des bastins des
solivettes enfin bref tout ce matériel
de chantier a été utilisé contre les
forces de l'ordre vous voyez et là on
imagine que les pompiers devrait arriver
incessamment sous peu vous savez que
c'est c'est ces incendies ces monnaies
courantes dans ces manifestations où on
envoie des manifestants radicaux issus
de l'ultra gauche vous vous souvenez
sans doute il y a quelques semaines de
salle La Rotonde qui a eu aussi été
victime d'un départ de feu et bien là
c'est un peu la même chose qu'est-ce qui
se passe c'est un chantier tu vois vous
voyez les braves ms qui la brigade
motorisé la préfecture de police de
Paris qui est en train d'encercler les
manifestants aussi pour les mettre en
sécurité parce que les flammes se
rapprochent petit à petit de deux il
s'agirait pas que un manifestant se
toucher par ses flammes on imagine
derrière effectivement le le le le que
ce serait très très compliqué ne
serait-ce que pour les pompiers de
d'intervenir sur cette place qui est
complètement quadrillée enfin par les
forces de l'ordre là d'ailleurs les
forces de l'ordre sont devant derrière
nous nous sommes vraiment assez dans un
côté de la place alors est-ce que c'est
la nouvelle stratégie de force d'or
c'est jusque là lancer des grenades
lacrymogènes puissent se retirer dans
les rues adjacents à cette place de la
Nation donc c'est pas en tout cas pour
l'instant la situation est toujours
extrêmement tendue ici place de la
Nation
merci beaucoup Damien et on continue
bien entendu de suivre la situation on
revient avec eux Arnaud Benedetti à
l'instant effectivement cette ces images
peut-être un commentaire Arnaud ces
images de violence elle elle son
harcèlement sur ce que l'on voit mais
elles sont en ce moment sur tous les
médias
est-ce que c'est quand même au bout d'un
moment ce qui risque ça ne risque pas de
de ternir l'action du l'action syndicale
et en tous les cas la mobilisation
contre cette réforme des retraites
et c'est toujours la même question c'est
à dire en d'autres termes est-ce que ces
images de violence qui sont bien
évidemment pas acceptables vont-elles
réfléchir le soutien de l'opinion
publique au mouvement et aux
mobilisation sociale on a le comme
élément de comparaison on a le mouvement
des gilets jaunes qui étaient un
mouvement de nature très différente il
faut le signaler quand même mais où on
avait quand même pu observer et ça c'est
une nouveauté dans le paysage j'allais
dire politique français de ces 20
dernières années malgré tout un soutien
constant et et et et soutenu si je puis
dire à des mobilisations qui avaient
donné lieu par certains côtés donc
parfois aussi assez violent je pense
notamment à la journée du 1er décembre
est-ce que l'on constate là aussi quand
on regarde des études d'opinion ce qui
n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs rassurant
sur le sentiment démocratique collectif
mais peu importe c'est une réalité avec
les réalités c'est que vous avez un
pourcentage non négligeable de Français
qui considèrent que
une certaine forme de radicalité
politique aujourd'hui et légitime c'est
une réalité qui s'est construite depuis
un certain nombre d'années et qui
réapparait
assez fortement aussi lorsqu'on observe
les évolutions de l'opinion compte à
cette mobilisation syndicale le fait que
l'on considère je regardais un sondage
il y a peu de temps de cela que une
majorité de Français considère à plus de
50% que finalement les insultes du
président de la République sont quelque
chose de légitime dit quelque chose sur
l'état d'esprit et l'état de l'opinion
donc il y a cette réalité là aussi qui
faut dont il faut tenir compte après
bien évidemment les images de violence
sont des images qui d'une certaine façon
viennent
par leur répétition sur les réseaux sur
les chaînes etc viennent
cannibaliser l'image positive pacifique
que les syndicats souhaitent évidemment
diffuser de leur mobilisation sur le sur
le terrain
112000 manifestants à Paris selon la
préfecture de police le chiffre vient de
tomber à l'instant c'est plus que ce qui
avait été prévu qui plus que ce qui
était annoncé alors on en vient à la
question du jour sur le site du Figaro
après le premier mai le gouvernement
va-t-il réussir à tourner la page de la
réforme des retraites
Cassandra nous disait tout à l'heure sur
le forum du Figaro en réaction à cette
question du jour
en écoutant les gens qui travaillent
autour de moi je constate une colère
sourde est-ce que c'est moi j'ajouterai
un autre chiffre un OBD c'est le sondage
au doxa backbone publié sur le Figaro
samedi qui montre que 60% des Français
soutiennent encore le mouvement et sans
doute on le voit avec la forte
mobilisation qui a autour du défilé en
dépit des images de violence
oui mais si vous voulez plaire et il est
installé dans la société française
depuis longtemps c'est-à-dire que elle
n'avait pas trouvé le moyen de son
expression et de sa cristallisation
sociale et politique mais là elle est en
train de la trouver c'est une réalité et
quand même les chiffres que vous voulez
citer sur Paris sont des chiffres qui
sont importants qui vont au-delà de ce
qu'il y avait été prévu et qui était
déjà important donc ça veut dire que
quand même maintenant on commence à
avoir des chiffres qui arrivent et qui
traduisent une réelle une réelle
amplification de ce mouvement sur le sur
le terrain ensuite en effet on constate
lorsqu'on le remplit lorsqu'on regarde
les études qualitatives pas seulement
les études quantitatives notamment par
exemple de l'Observatoire
sur la confiance du CES vipof que il y a
une montée en puissance dans les
verbatimes de jugement qui sont très
sévères vis-à-vis de la classe
dirigeante quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs mais bon là en ce moment elle
se cristallise plutôt vers le pouvoir
donc ce sentiment qui s'est depuis de
très nombreuses dans la société
française
bien avant d'ailleurs l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron il ne fait que
s'amplifier et à la faveur finalement de
ce de ce j'allais dire de ce texte sur
les retraites dans un contexte encore
une fois où on a une Assemblée nationale
il n'a pas donné les pleins pouvoirs les
électeurs en 2022 n'ont pas donné les
biens pouvoirs aux présidents de la
République puisque s'ils avaient voulu
lui donner les plein pouvoir et il y a
une majorité absolue on a un exécutif
qui a vraisemblablement géré la
situation comme si il avait obtenu une
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée chocolat
dans 2022 et faisant fit de ces éléments
de colère qui avaient déjà été largement
véhiculé durant la crise des gilets
jaunes mais qui avait été ici aussi
véhiculé durant la crise sanitaire il
faut s'en souvenir donc tous ces
ferments aujourd'hui
trouvent une traduc est une traduction
sociopolitique qui en effet
nous laisse quand même plein de doutes
quant à la capacité aujourd'hui de
sortir rapidement de cette situation ça
c'est je crois une réalité on voit pas
trop pour l'instant si ce n'est que tout
d'un coup une forme de lassitude
collective qui l'emporte on va pas trop
comment sauf cette lassitude collective
le gouvernement trouvera une missure
rapide à la crise dans laquelle il est
aujourd'hui enterrer
à l'instant un nouveau chiffre
780 de mille manifestants en France
le ministère c'est un chiffre qui émane
du ministère de l'Intérieur je précise
que on annonçait oui on attendait de 500
à 600 000 manifestants là aussi c'est le
signe d'une forte mobilisation
et il va rendre difficile peut-être
est-ce que ça aussi ça peut paraître
difficile justement
l'opération pour le gouvernement de
vouloir tourner la page la réforme des
retraites
mais vous savez la page elle va pas être
tournée facilement parce que encore une
fois moi j'insiste là dessus c'est pas
parce que je dirige une revue qui
s'appelle la revue politique et
parlementaire mais ce qu'on recommande
je vous remercie
ce qui se passe Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui est quand même révélateur je
crois que dans un mois le groupe
parlementaire qui a déposé la fameuse
motion de censure transpartisanes le
groupe yacht va à l'occasion de la
discussion vous savez de ces fameuses
niches parlementaires où il est laissé à
l'initiative des groupes parlementaires
de déposer des propositions de loi va
déposer une proposition de loi le 6 juin
prochain en principe visant à
l'abrogation du texte de loi qui vient
d'être promulgué sur les retraites avec
une chance non négligeable que cette
proposition de loi soit adoptée tout
simplement parce que il suffit d'une
majorité simple
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
absolue de 289 ce sont ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle qui votent
tout simplement uniquement les présents
donc en l'occurrence il y a une
possibilité que cette proposition soit
acceptée ça veut pas dire qu'elle aille
jusqu'au bout et les chances qu'elle
aille jusqu'au bout sont infinitiales
mais la réalité c'est que ça va créer si
vous voulez un effet politique un effet
médiatique qui va j'allais dire
resservir d'une certaine manière la
séquence de contestation sur les
retraites donc on est loin d'avoir
tourné la page et et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui les efforts qui sont ceux
de l'exécutif pour essayer de tourner la
page en envoyant des ministres sur le
terrain en envoyant en faisant que le
Président de la République
aille à la rencontre des Français à
travers finalement une opération qui est
une opération uniquement de
communication ne répond pas j'allais
dire à la gravité de la situation en
tout cas n'est pas perçue comme le
répondant à la à la gravité de la
situation
par de larges segments de l'opinion
publique et en fait ce qui est assez
frappant aujourd'hui c'est que Emmanuel
Macron a pris aucune initiative
politique il n'a pris aucune initiative
politique mise à part des initiatives de
communication c'est à dire les
initiatives politiques ça pouvait être
faire un remaniement à minima resserré
par exemple en gardant en gardant madame
borne resserrer son gouvernement son
rythme être un changement de Premier
ministre
j'allais dire au pire ou au mieux c'est
selon ça pourrait être une dissolution
c'est pas on est loin on est loin de ces
hypothèses
on est loin de ces hypothèses mais il me
semble que ça sera très difficile pour
Emmanuel Macron de tenir
s'il ne prend pas un moment donné
initiative réellement en politique
est-ce que
les demandes d'un nouveau RIP ont des
chances d'aboutir auprès du Conseil
constitutionnel d'après votre expérience
moi je suis pas constitutionnaliste mais
David est constitutionnaliste quand j'en
parle avec mon ami Benjamin Morel que
vous connaissez bien au Figaro ou quand
j'en parle avec un autre
constitutionnaliste comme Didier Moss
qui a été président
de l'Association française des profs de
droit constitutionnel ils ont émettent
quand même un certain nombre de réserves
quant à la possibilité que le Conseil
constitutionnel
dont Titus
à la demande des
députés de la nupesse nous verrons bien
ce qui se passera le 3 mais en effet ça
serait une porte de sortie pour essayer
de détendre l'atmosphère d'une certaine
façon parce que aujourd'hui il y a quand
même un sujet qui sur lequel avec lequel
il faut compter c'est que les syndicats
ne peuvent pas si vous voulez sortir de
cette épreuve sans avoir le moindre
regain la réalité c'est que pour
l'instant ils n'ont aucun gain certes
ils ont mobilisé serti ils ont ils ont
une opinion publique et des soutiens
certes il reviennent un peu en cours
dans le cœur des Français et dans
l'opinion publique mais le gain
politique est pour l'instant nul puisque
l'exécutif n'a rien cédé puisque
l'exécutif a affaire adopter sa loi en
utilisant tous les outils du
parlementarisme rationalisé puisqu'il a
réussi à la faire valider par le Conseil
constitutionnel puisqu'il a il l'a fait
promulguer dans les 24 heures et puisque
selon toute vraisemblance je pense que
les décrets d'application de cette loi
vont sortir très rapidement eu égard
notamment par exemple à la dégradation
de l'annonce de la de la de la de la de
la nôtre de la note de la France
par une agence de notation donc si vous
voulez
il va bien falloir un moment donné que
les syndicats est un peu de grains à
moudre et là ils en ont pas pour
l'instant et donc on peut pas rester
dans cette situation de blocage
peut-être que le Conseil constitutionnel
donnera donnera quitus à la à la demande
de RIP on verra bien mais enfin le
conseil pensionnel est censé jouer en
droit est-ce que ça pourrait jouer un
rôle justement dans le fait de tourner
un peu cette page est-ce que les
syndicats n'ont pas intérêt à saisir la
main tendue par le par Elizabeth borne
même en faisant monter les enchères
c'est ce que disait François ce que
disait Laurent Berger ce matin sur les
questions de partage de valeurs d'emploi
des seigneurs et d'assurance chômage
oui alors évidemment mais alors là là je
pense que la c'est là que le France
syndical peut
peut-être se les arder puisque
manifestement il n'y aura pas la même
appréciation
du côté de la CGT vraisemblablement mais
peut-être du côté de FO que du côté de
la CFDT
la réalité c'est que même pour la CFDT
il y a quand même une difficulté c'est
que la base aujourd'hui
ne veut pas entendre de cette loi qui a
été promulguée donc ils sont un peu dos
mur ils sont dos au mur vis-à-vis à la
fois de leur de leur de leur base
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique et
allez aujourd'hui à des négociations
comme si de rien n'était après avoir mis
surtout
près de 800 000 personnes dans la rue ce
1er mai il y a quelque chose qui
apparaîtra contradictoire donc dans
l'immédiat je ne suis pas sûr que le
retour des syndicats à la table des
négociations soit à l'ordre du jour on
verra bien on n'est pas l'abri de
surprise
une question de petite question encore
sachant Arnaud je rappelle que on est
sur la question du jour est-ce que après
le 1er mai le gouvernement va-t-il
réussir à tourner la page de la réforme
des retraites est-ce que et vous pouvez
continuer à voter vous avez déjà
nombreux à le faire vous êtes nombreux
sur le site profitez-en exprimez-vous
est-ce que
si je vous ai bien compris
la réforme une fois passée ça va c'est
difficile pour Emmanuel Macron en tous
les cas de soulever les autres sujets
vous parliez notamment du sujet de
l'immigration il y a plein d'autres
sujets peut-être qu'ils peuvent faire
consensus je sais pas l'euthanasie par
exemple
oui enfin si vous voulez
les
sujets d'ordre
sociétaux
pas des sujets qui sont si vous voulez
suffisants pour tenir pendant 4 ans
quand même donc
le vrai problème aujourd'hui pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est que
immédiatement quand même il faut s'en
souvenir il y a quelques semaines il
avait fixé à Madame borne
un agenda qui était un agenda
d'élargissement de sa base majoritaire
jusqu'à preuve du contraire le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que la première
ministre n'est pas parvenue et c'était
l'évidence à élargir cette base majorité
donc ça c'est un premier point donc on
reste si vous voulez dans les tirages
parlementaires qui est celui-ci des
élections de législatives du printemps
dernier mais ce qu'il faut quand même
voir de près et ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est qu'à l'intérieur même de
la majorité vous voyez bien qu'il y a
des dissensions qui apparaissent
il y a des dissensions à l'intérieur du
groupe Renaissance madame Pompili a pris
ses aujourd'hui après ces distances par
rapport au groupe parlementaire suivi
par croix de ses collègues du groupe
Renaissance par rapport au groupe
Renaissance mais écoutez monsieur Beyrou
qui quand même dispose d'un groupe
parlementaire avec 48 parlementaires
qui dit que la méthode qui est utilisée
par l'exécutif n'est pas la bonne donc
le problème pour Madame borne
aujourd'hui c'est même plus tendre
d'élargir sa base majoritaire c'est de
pouvoir tenir sa base par le mentale
telle qu'elle est née des élections
législatives encore une fois du mois de
juin dernier et contenu de la pression
de la rue contenue de la pression de
l'opinion publique ça va être de plus en
plus difficile donc finalement
l'enjeu a très court terme sur le plan
politique c'est de savoir si une fine et
allaité madame borne sera encore ou non
première ministre parce que si on reste
dans une situation qui est une situation
de forte mobilisation sociale
de difficultés de plus en plus grandes
quant à l'équation parlementaire avec
des textes qui ne peuvent plus passer ou
qui ne sont susceptibles de passer qu'à
coûte 49-3 ce qui va être de plus en
plus difficile fait de la faiblesse du
droit de tirage pour la 49-3
au roi mal comment elle Macron va
pouvoir maintenir en l'état un chef de
gouvernement où une chef de gouvernement
qui finalement n'a pas de latitude pour
avancer socialement ni parlementairement
donc il faudra bien un moment donné
qu'il tente quelque chose et le seul
moyen il a l'outil l'objet dire le plus
le plus facile qu'il a sa disposition
dans l'immédiat même s'il est loin de
régler tout c'est le changement de
Premier ministre et on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est en jeu c'est
évidemment la place de Madame de Madame
borne à Matignon
une question
encore
Arnaud ce serait ma dernière
est-ce que paradoxalement Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas réussi sur un point au
cours de cette séquence certes il a
énormément chuté en termes de popularité
mais il consolide plus que jamais son
socle
oui ce que vous dites est juste sauf que
vous faites une interprétation qui
serait j'allais dire d'autant plus
j'allais dire justifier
s'il disposer d'une majorité encore une
fois à l'Assemblée nationale et quand le
veuille ou non le problème central
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis le nouveau
quinquennat c'est le fait qu'il n'a pas
de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et
qui n'a qu'une majorité très relative
extrêmement relative excessivement
relative même donc quand vous avez un
socle électoral à 28% certes vous pouvez
considérer que ce soit électoral
constitue en effet un matelas de
sécurité mais il constitue un matelas de
sécurité parce qu'à côté vous avez quand
même un outil institutionnel qui est un
amortisseur formidable qui est celui de
disposé d'une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale mais quand vous avez un
potentiel parce que ça reste un
potentiel en plus de 26 ou 28%
de gens qui vous font confiance mais
quand vous en avez 70 qui vous font pas
confiance et que vous ne disposez plus
qui plus est
d'une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et qui plus est que vous n'avez même
plus les syndicats qui sont prêts à
s'asseoir à la table des négociations
force est de constater que vous êtes
dans une situation qui est extrêmement
compliquée et le problème de fond c'est
que est-ce qu'on peut gouverner le pays
et c'est là que la notion de crise
démocratique prend tous ensemble avec un
potentiel de soutien de 28%. c'est quand
même une vraie difficulté c'est une
vraie difficulté sur la sur la distance
et c'est ce qui quand même eu des mines
les institutions depuis de trop
nombreuses années beaucoup de présidents
de la République ces dernières années
c'est vrai on continue à gouverner avec
des socles qui étaient des socles de cet
ordre là mais la crise démocratique
entre temps n'a fait que s'approfondir
et elle ne fait que s'approfondir
aujourd'hui donc
j'allais dire dans l'absolu vous avez
peut-être raison en tout cas sur les sur
la conjoncture mais la réalité c'est que
c'est de plus en plus difficile et c'est
de moins en moins gouv ernable on va
revenir dans un instant avec les images
qui nous parviennent qui figent encore
un peu donc je j'en profite pour pour
conclure avec vous Arnaud bénédictine
vous remercier d'ailleurs par la même
occasion donc si je vous suis
la question du jour après le 1er mai le
gouvernement va-t-il réussir à tourner
la page de la réforme des retraites à
vous entendre c'est plutôt non
possible concerne ça sera plutôt
difficile en effet
sachez que les internautes du Figaro
sont très partagés il y a quasiment
moitié-moitié
49,84 % à l'heure où je vous parle qui
répondent oui et 50,16 % qui répondent
non il y a déjà beaucoup de votants près
de 100000 vous pouvez continuer à voter
si vous nous suivez en direct et en tout
cas merci beaucoup Arnaud pour toutes
ces précisions pour toutes ces analyses
et pour toutes ces lumières et et c'est
perspectives bien évidemment on
reviendra vers vous parce que
visiblement la mobilisation est pas
complètement terminée deux échéances
notamment celle du 3 mai avec la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel et
puis celle du 8 juin avec la niche
parlementaire du groupe lyaute qui va
déposer une proposition de loi demandant
que le renoncer à
l'âge de départ à 64 ans on va revenir
place de la Nation on va retrouver
Damien Canivet alors effectivement ça
refige mais est-ce que Damien nous
entend
moi je vous entends très bien Vincent je
sais pas si c'est le cas l'ambiance est
un petit peu détendue depuis quelques
instants à l'arrivée des pompiers que
vous voyez peut-être sur les images de
Julien Leclerc les pompiers qui sont
toujours très acclamés dans ces
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites contrairement aux policier on
a entendu du slogan même qui est les
étagères tout le monde elle me confier
un contrat à Lyon on entend tous tout le
monde des personnes à police dans ce
genre de manifestation alors tout à
l'heure quand je vous ai laissé il y
avait un il y avait un pied d'immeuble
qui était en flamme très vite les les
sapeurs-pompiers sont arrivés et les
canons à eau de la police nationale
aussi on peut utiliser pour l'éteindre
donc le feu a été assez vite contenu
malgré tout le calme est très relatif
parce que vous venez d'entendre la règle
des sirènes de pompiers et là les
tensions repartent une fois de plus avec
les policiers puisque il y a des
éléments radicaux qui sont en train de
balancer des GPS sous notre roi des
pierres sous sur notre caméra et les
policiers entreprise qui sont acculés
aux abords de cette place de la Nation
et qui devrait pas tarder à charger
comme ils le font depuis tout à l'heure
on sait qu'on sent que la soirée va être
très longue ici parce que pour le moment
il y a pas vraiment d'évolution de la
situation à la limite ça s'aggrave
fraîche que parfois avec des policiers
qui ont le sang sont très tendus et
peut-être parfois peuvent faire des
heures stratégiques et sont même
victimes de de la recherche on peut le
dire vous avez vu tout à l'heure sur nos
images ce policier qui a trébuché et qui
a été aussitôt pris à parti par exemple
c'est très compliqué le cortège cervical
on le voit pas encore donc peut-être
même pas encore arrivé place de la
Nation et on comprend parce que c'est
extrêmement dangereux ici les pierres
sont en train de voler de porter
d'autres de cette place les policiers en
cercle cette place de la Nation et et le
Black Bloc aussi
hop là excusez-moi je il y a un petit
moment de flottement parce que une
grenade vient d'être tirée en notre
direction et c'était des grenades
lacrymogènes donc ils sont évidemment
empreint d'être renvoyé du côté des
forces de l'orque par les manifestants
qui sont en train de nous entourer vous
voyez cette charge de la police
pour tenter de disperser une fois de
plus le black bloc
alors Thibault ne nous entend pas on va
regarder et laisser ces images je vous
donne les dernières informations les
informations qui nous sont parvenues
donc les chiffres qui ont été donnés par
la préfecture de Paris de police de
Paris 782 000 manifestants dont 112000 à
Paris ce sont les chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur c'est au-delà de ce qui a
été prévu de ce qui était annoncé
puisque on annonçait un maximum de 680
000 manifestants donc
manifestants c'est ce que annonce la
préfecture de police de Paris beaucoup
de violences beaucoup de heures beaucoup
de dégradations de déprédation 53
interpellations en fin d'après-midi et
un policier blessé gravement blessé
c'est ce qu'a également les communiquer
et c'est une impression qui a dominé sur
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux c'est
pour ça également qu'on vous la donne
qu'on vous la partage les prochaines
échéances pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'annonces de la part de l'intersydicale
ce que l'on sait c'est que les les
prochains des prochains rendez-vous
concernant la réforme des retraites le
prochain c'est le 3 mai prochain avec la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
la demande d'un référendum d'initiative
partagée un deuxième RIP qui a peu de
chances selon les spécialistes en tous
les cas ce qu'on a pu entendre
aujourd'hui d'être adopté mais en tous
les cas ça va être scruté et puis le 8
juin une niche parlementaire
avec une possibilité pour le groupe
liotte dirigé par Charles de Courson qui
avait déposé la motion de censure
transpart en avril dernier en mars
dernier qui donc va déposer une
proposition de loi abrogeant le l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire en terme de
commentaires vous restez avec nous les
images en direct continuent de nous
parvenir vous pouvez continuer à suivre
le la manifestation et ce défiler de la
fin de ce défiler en direct sur le site
du Figaro et sur la page Youtube merci
de nous avoir suivi d'avoir commenté
avec nous jusqu'à présent et je remercie
également toutes les équipes qui sont
mobilisées qui sont mobilisées Thibault
Gauthier François Carpentier place entre
la Place de la République et la place de
la Nation Damien Canivez et Julien
Leclerc en sentinelle et ici en studio
Riad Becker Sacha body et Margot Calvet
bien entendu les journalistes les
experts qui sont venus commenter tout au
long de l'après-midi
ces images on continue vous restez avec
nous le live texte en dessous de ce
player continu les envoyer spéciaux du
Figaro continue de vous alimenter en
informations également avec les dépêches
qui sont à côté du site du Figaro à très
vite et vous retrouvez également les
émissions en particulier bienvenue en
Île-de-France à partir de 19h et le club
Le Figaro international à 20h mais
également ces images donc qu'on vous
laisse sur le site du Figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au moins 15 balles sur le marché
[Musique]
faut en parler de ça
[Applaudissements]
à l'intérieur du mur à l'intérieur du
meuble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez s'il vous plaît on recule s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est en plein dans le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]